thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
I do recommend Meetup to a lot of my
friends that are looking for different
things wine tasting movies book clubs
meet a lot of new people a lot of new
friends and make you more social
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
dominance move after move again and
again and again we have a resignation we
have history he is the five-time fide
World chess champion
but a chess Dynasty can also be cruel it
forces most to defer their dreams until
next time if there is a next time oh my
god did he just block yeah he did I'm
Blown Away the game is over
as the Chess World Turns to Kazakhstan
the Magnus Carlson Dynasty is set to
close
the feed a world championship is finally
up for grabs
for two chess Superstars lying in wait
until next time is now
Jan napam Nashi has methodically done
what he needed to do to get another shot
at the title the pressure to seize the
moment this time rests heavily upon Him
John is running out of resources he's
built every threat that's possible and
things just counted it there's no way to
make progress all
Ison ding Lee Rand knows firsthand what
the end of this dynasty means an
unexpected chance to make history
can China's best turn his Good Fortune
into Eternal Fame it's a drop what an
amazing defense by ding the 2023 world
champion will be decided in speed test
the legacy of this Championship spans
across centuries it reads from the names
of Chess Giants for the first time in a
decade a new name will raise the trophy
and be etched into chess history
it's the 2023 feed a world championship
whose name will next be called champion
[Music]
it's Championship Sunday in Astana and
not far from here are the buzzing Halls
of the Saint Regis Hotel like every game
day today Jana pamushi and dingleren
will step into this playing Arena but
this is like no other day they'll walk
into the classroom and today with the
stunning trophy inside later hot side
and in the end one of them will be the
new world chess champion the Press is
ready we are ready Welcome to our
coverage of the playoffs for the 2023
video World Championship I'm
International Master Tanya and alongside
me the crew Grandmaster Robert has and a
grand master of Fabiano caruana it's
going to be an intense day of Chess
Robert has to spin the most
unpredictable world championship match
it's been an absolute roller coaster and
perhaps that's what happens when they're
two evenly matched players like Jana
palmchi and dingly Wren the numbers two
and three rated players in the world
just a few rating points apart coming
into this match with just about an equal
head-to-head record it's been exciting
it's been fun it is Sunday fun day but
for the players there's a lot on the
line
one day fun day I love it Fabi with your
experience of the 2018 tie breaks in the
world championship match how difficult
is today for the players
it's going to be incredibly difficult
for both of them and we can't pick out a
clear favorite I think we see that the
players have been completely evenly
matched In classical chess battling back
and forth but still reaching the 7-7
score in Rapid chess I think they're
also going to be completely evenly
matched although it's possible that in
just four games one of them will break
free and perhaps it's even likely that
we might see it end before we get to the
blitz but in Blitz chess who knows it's
going to be a bloodbath if it gets to
that point and at that point anything
can happen
that's gonna be crazy but we've seen all
kinds of crazy in this match Vision the
five-time world champion an absolute
Legend called it one of the most
exciting matches in recent history this
match has been jaw dropping from the
start we saw lots of decisive games five
decisive games in the first half
including a psychological meltdown in
game seven by Zing game eight Jana
bombshi with his trickiness survived a
tough scare and then finally kaisa was
on ding's side in Game 12 from a
difficult position saying leveled the
match going into game 14 which we saw
yesterday and with a draw a marathon
game it is 7-7 heading to the playoffs
game seven what game 14 game seven as
well was an iconic one and the longest
of the match Abby Jan was dismissive
about ding's attack with Knight G4
Knight G5 H4 coming in and his play
lived up to it sing survived the scare
yesterday
yeah I think Jan had the absolutely
correct initial uh reaction his
intuition told him that Knight G5 and H4
scary though it may look it's not really
based in terms of some sound positional
principle that you know white has
White's played better in the opening and
it's now time for an attack black was
playing completely healthy moves that's
what Jan said and that's why he didn't
believe that aggression like that would
necessarily result in some sort of
advantage for white and we actually saw
the opposite that black was the one who
was taking over in terms of evaluation
maybe not in large part until later in
the game when it suddenly started to get
super super dangerous for ding we were
starting to think maybe today is going
to be the day that we'll see a world
champion but the day was delayed today
we will absolutely see a world champion
but yesterday thing held up his defenses
held up it was a seven hour game and uh
I think we can't underestimate how
difficult it is to play precisely after
those seven hours and also after the
preceding three weeks of chests that
we've seen especially very bloody chess
but things uh calculation held up I I
mean whether he was tired or not he
played all the perfect moves in that
Rook end game and he survived a big
scare and perhaps Jana is a bit
disappointed but we just have to say
that you know ding was up to the task
and one of the biggest criticisms of
this world championship has been the
perceived lack of defensive tenacity but
that script was Rewritten yesterday when
dingley Ren he buckled down played for
seven hours and he was helped by a pawn
push heard around the world that B6
tactical idea where he gives up a pawn
that gives him a rook for a bishop just
to win a rook back entering a rook and
pawn end game down a pawn but holding on
that was impressive stuff from dingley
RAM and Jana Pomchi maybe he'll be a
little bit disappointed because he had
this match Victory it felt in the bag in
Game 12 he let it slip but he had the
upper hand yesterday so he can't feel
good that in the last game that they
played he was the one with all the
chances he may not have won the game but
he enters Championship Sunday with some
renewed confidence you would hope
that's a big upside for Yan playing game
14 just yesterday with the black pieces
being the one pushing the game for the
most part of it with dingler and found
some critical resources there and now
traditionally in the 2016 and the 2018
World Championship matches where we did
see tie breaks they happened after a
rest day that was arrested and then the
playoffs but this time after a grueling
game 14 the players straight away go
into the playoffs and they'll start with
four rapid games with 25 minutes on
their clock and every time a player
presses the clock gets an additional 10
seconds in case there's a tie after the
first four rapid games that's a 2-2
score we will see the match proceed to
the blitz playoff and that will be a
best of two with a five minute and a
three second increment if that one ends
in a tie as well then we go down to the
final tiebreaker which will be with
three minutes on the clock for each of
the players and a two second increment
the games will be played at till we have
a decisive result Robert we're gonna
start with rapid we're going to
potentially have Blitz is there in
either of these two formats a big
favorite
such a big question I know that's what
the people want the answer to who is
going to win today and going in to the
rapid portion we do not know I know
dingley Ren he has the slight nod in
terms of Rapid rating but he's inactive
over the board and janapamshi has played
some excellent speed chess he won the
rapid Chess Championship in 2022 on
chess.com he beat some big names along
the way so I feel like it's hard to pick
between these two they are both well
tested online and over the board they
are a bit of the top of chess for over a
decade I don't know who to pick
it is going to be an amazing fight and
we do know that the players have played
each other a bunch of times in speeches
as well these are their head to head
scores but fast scores are the least of
the concerns for these two players today
it's a totally different universe that
they're in none of the rules apply here
the only takeaway that we have from this
graphic in front of us is that it's
going to be a close call as Robert said
it's hard to pick a favorite but then we
didn't need a graphic to tell us that
it's going to be a close call it was
clear in the classical games just the
kind of fight that we're going to get
today now what's gonna matter today is
going to be energy both are extremely
fatigued not only from game 14 with all
the games preceding that as well it's
been a big fight from the very start
it's going to come down to who has those
extra seconds in time scrambles grit
determination stamina will come into
Play sabi is it fair to say that today
will be more about the player who makes
the last mistake and less about accuracy
but I think accuracy will play a huge
part in deciding who makes the last
mistake because very often these
mistakes that come at the last moment
they're the result of pressure that
builds up throughout the game so if
you're on the back foot throughout the
game or throughout the day of Rapid
chess then that's likely to lead you
astray in you know in those critical
moments because we know the pressure
it's not just a momentary thing it
builds up in in your mind and your body
and so
it might be down to like just who plays
the best chess and we might only see it
manifest finally in some like huge
blunder and when they're both down to
time travel but uh we have to recognize
that one mistakes and blunders don't
come you know in a vacuum they're
they're the result of uh previous
factors that build up
yeah it's really well worded by Fabiano
there that we often think how could they
blunder this piece that's what
Spectators may think but it's because of
continued pressure tough moves have to
be played and such a single moves it's
strategies ideas and when you're in
Rapid chess you can't sit for 30 minutes
because guess what you don't have 30
minutes to start with so I think when we
look at this match as a whole Jana
palmchi has been the quicker player he's
also been the first into the playing
Hall and that is true today as well and
I feel like for dingley Ren he knows he
can't sit in for those long things he is
going to have to find ideas quickly he
is capable of that we have seen in some
of the best players in the world they
may be slower in classical chess but
they speed up when the time gets lower
walked into the playing Hall he did
glance at that stunning trophy that we
saw earlier on that is the ultimate
dream for these two players so much
pressure so much tension the Champions
played their best chess in exactly these
clutch moments now we also had the
drawing of lots after the press
conference yesterday and dingler and
does start with the white pieces the
first rapid game and it is going to be a
lot about what the team didn't come up
with for this game one a result in game
one could potentially set the tone for
the rest of the rapid games Fabi how
crucial and how critical is game one for
these players with four games ahead
yeah I think that will really set the
stage and if we see a decisive result it
could uh really lead to some momentum
for whoever wins although we have a lot
of recent data in terms of four game
matches between top players you know in
the champions tour this is the format
and very often we see a lot of back and
forth so someone wins a game and he I
mean I can't count the amount of times
and this has happened my own matches as
well as you know if I'm watching matches
of Magnus or Hikaru we almost
immediately see a strike back and and
it's kind of remarkable
but because when the match stays level
when it's like draw after draw then
players struggle to break through but
once there's a decisive result very
often that leads to the person in the
lead they go into defensive mode their
play starts to suffer a bit I've seen
this countless times it even happens to
magnets that he wins a game and everyone
thinks okay he's going to run away with
the match then suddenly we see let's say
Wesley or Recaro a strike back in the
very next game and it could easily
happen in this match as well that we see
it back and forth because
there's this like psychological element
where you win a game and you feel like
you're already you know at the Finish
Line like I just need to not mess this
up I just need to draw the rest of the
games and that can have a bad effect on
your play so from from what I've seen a
lot there there is that tendency for
there to be not just like a clean you
know decisive game followed by draws on
a clean Victory but a little bit of a
struggle there
it's going to be a big struggle for
these two players and a dingler in with
the white pieces with black Looking
ready to start and Robert before we get
the gamer action going this one's for
chat and this one's for both of you
actually a prediction you know I love
predictions will we see this match go
into Blitz and I'll start with Robert
always put me on the spot I do not think
that we're going to Blitz I don't know
who is going to win but I do think we
will see a champion Crown in Rapid
mistakes happen more frequently and
quicker time controls I think one side
will take the lead and will not
relinquish it at a certain point and so
we will see a champion Crown in Rapid
predicts a match in Rapid what about you
Fabi I'm going the opposite direction I
think we've already seen so much back
and forth I don't think it's gonna stop
now and I think you might call me
superstitious but I think there's going
to be an element of uh a fate here in
terms of the dramatic twists and turns
of the match and that will continue and
it just feels like these guys are are so
evenly matched that it's hard to imagine
them not going the distance
we do have the first
person in the match so far and this is a
new position first time in the 2023
World Championship
well when dick is playing with the yeah
I like it too when dick is playing with
the white pieces every opening is a new
opening he is he has uh played pretty
much everything you can imagine after
um we see D4 Knight F3 he played one
time the London system Bishop F4 one
time McCoy system E3 and now he's going
for a third move C3 will we I mean he
doesn't want to put that pawn on C4
anymore uh so he's he's uh you know
uh choosing between all these small
systems that are kind of a little bit
interesting a little bit poisonous I
know the C3 system because uh Levon was
uh
quite Enchanted by it and I don't know
if you remember Robert when we were at
the Olympiad Levon was was telling us a
bit about this C3 stuff and it's it's an
interesting little system it's like a
modern approach trying to uh oppose
black some original problems and we see
already thing took upon and is uh trying
to hold on to it
by any means bishop and E3 a bit unusual
so but it does defend the pawn
yeah and I actually really like these
approaches when it comes to quicker time
controls and this is rapid and you may
see dings clock at 25 minutes and 56
seconds and be wondering didn't they
start with 25 minutes they have
increment they will gain some time with
every move they will gain 10 seconds and
I like stealing Pawns
if it doesn't compromise your entire
position in quicker type controls
because this potency five Good Luck
winning it back at some point ding will
push this Pawn to B4 that's why his
pawns on C3 and if he can establish the
defense of that pawn black will have a
lot to prove compensation is often a
vague term what competition does yonder
Palm she have he has two Pawns in the
center to one for white so there's some
good news for Yan I think there's more
bad news at the moment I think this was
a smart opening choice but we're just
getting started here we're only six
moves in too early to predict but I do
enjoy this decision from dingly Wren so
wait what happens after an ig4 now
because yeah I do want to get that
pulling back
and if the bishop goes to D4 there's E5
if the bishop goes somewhere else we
take that pawn so you have
a few choices I guess you can
you decides not to but it was looked
interesting to to attack the bishop
there yeah he Castle but let's look
Knight G4 Bishop D4 E5 is five easy to
get this bishop out of here I guess
there's H3 kicking this Knight away and
it's a very forcing sequence where white
take the Knight you take this Pawn this
Knight hops back and takes here so I
think black's position looks quite
flimsy I would not have advised going
for this if I were yawning he didn't he
castled instead but he does after D4 he
does regain the material because his G4
Pawn will be hanging
and yeah you might be right that uh
after Knight E4 maybe the H file being
opened is actually to White's benefit
but we didn't see that we saw castle and
ding decided to hold on to that pawn I
was I was gonna say like instead of
Bishop G2 he could have played B4 as
well just uh
yeah cleaned onto that pawn and now
Knight to G4 comes wow so yeah knows
this position
he must because that night May reroute
to E5 and over to C4 controls on the
scores but Tanya I was saying I like
grabbing pawns I know Yasser Sarah will
be proud what about you do you like
White's opening Choice thus far I don't
know if this is something I would go for
go far enough in a game but Robert I
love what we're seeing and to just add
to the excitement after Jana bombshi
made the move Knight C6 that's a
position I don't have in my database
it's a brand new fresh position right
out of the opening now when you're
playing in a rapid game time is such a
big factor I don't believe that Ding
would have would have played on in this
fashion and in this manner in a
classical game but in Rapid this just
makes it so exciting and so fun dingler
and hanging on to that extra pawn and
Bishop D4 on the board the ideas that
you were talking about E5 it reminds me
of some kind of a grunt-filled way of
trying to win upon back with reversing
colors so definitely sort of thematic
here to try and get E5 in to go into
those complications but this is fire on
the board from the start this is more
than what we could have asked for in
game one of the rapid and Rob it I love
the position that we have it's gonna be
fun quick question so you said what what
moves have been playing so Queen C7 was
John's pretty quick Choice here so this
is still familiar territory or do you
think they're starting to get on their
own
Bishop E3 is actually when it stops
after Bishop E3 shot Castle has been
played three times and that's about it
so already it's a very fresh position
Knight C6 never been played it could be
some sort of a transposition and which
is why I'm so amazed to see the speed
with which janapamishi is playing Bobby
you mentioned that Jan is perhaps
familiar with this uh
now after E5 I I don't understand
anymore because there we were getting H3
and the eight and the H5 was opened and
black couldn't take on before and they
had because there was Queen B1 I don't
know if we can just like show that very
quickly
um like if we go the previous move
oh it's a crazy seven yeah I think that
Queen C7 was was quite a clever move
because here E5 H3 ed4 hg4 dec3 Knight
C3 and if Knight takes B4 which is a
very important Pawn then Queen's B1
would win the piece because of the queen
H7 so that's why I'm a bit surprised
that he castled now because with the
Rook no longer on H1 all of this stuff
uh well Knight takes before can be
played and it's still a question Knight
takes before there's A3 in that final
position if we go down the same exact
line
DC3 Knight C3 Knight takes beef or or
Diamond like mad C300 94 then A3
this is a pretty critical line I think
um and that
was to say five that's why Yan is
sitting and thinking this is really deep
stuff so you know it we see the engine
off the side saying white is better do
you think ding knows this position
he might he's playing very quickly and
he didn't really pause after Queen C7
either
and this is some kind of
this is like a very concrete position so
you you would to figure these positions
out yeah I think that he must he must
know this position it must be in his
prep
shot H3 on the board E5 you might be
seeing this line and we might see a
bishop drop down on that long diagonal
in the end uh Robert I don't see a way
for white to actually avoid but black
for Yan to actually avoid this setup
that we're looking at with A3 in the end
yeah I mean maybe you can Retreat and
I'm just scared of the variation we were
looking at and John will be digging deep
right now he's down on the clock people
might be surprised by this wasn't
dingley Ren the one who was always in
time trouble but he has come extremely
well prepared he answers the question uh
excuse me uh ding your preparation was
supposedly leaked you haven't been
pressing with white so much at least not
in the opening stage he came to answer
that right here but Knight F6 as a
retreating move the E5 punt is defended
twice that would force the bishop back
to E3 and so what I'm saying is that
black has this strong Center White has
the extra Pawn Fabi how do you assess
that trade-off I think black always has
a degree of compensation
it's it's something which you're a bit
hesitant to go for because
there's no like concrete follow-up after
Knight of six Bishop B3 You'll Play A
Move like you can play Rook to d8 you
can play Bishop to F5 you have like
various ways of playing the position for
sure but nothing which immediately gets
backed upon very often black will maybe
even play B6
um and just try to trade off that pawn
and then use the open a file and the
better structure as compensation but
it's one of those
yeah here here like maybe B6 B5 you get
scared of this I think okay we can we
can kind of live with this kind of
compensation perhaps but after B6 B5 is
a bit concerning
uh but he doesn't go for he goes for the
concrete option I'm not surprised
because it feels like
it's just some maybe a bit more
practical with the black pieces in in
this situation too
so let's see Knight takes E3 is going to
be played
and then I think he has to play Knight
takes before what else I mean Knight D5
is too big a threat to to ignore so you
got to get rid of that pawn otherwise
you're just going to be down upon for
for not much in particular
so can I ask a quick question so England
has finally paused does that just mean
he's recalling and he's moving now so I
think the answer is yes he's recalling
his preparation uh so how deep do you
think his prep goes here
I really don't know because it's a C3
line allows black so many early options
like I I guess you could
you could prepare the C5 rather
uh in quite a bit of depth especially if
they're following the computer's
recommendation it's possible that he
just kind of got a bit Lucky in terms of
uh that Eon went into something that he
just happened to know pretty well
but black capture C3 can play like C you
know C6 uh Bishop F5 Knight D7 basically
there's a bill a billion options because
it's not a concrete position C3 is
obviously not a move which immediately
threatens black uh so that if he's
actually in prep it's quite
uh quite remarkable that that he managed
to
to get this position in his rep I mean
it's there were so many options for both
sides you know early on so now the
question is
uh you have a bunch of logical moves
with black you have Bishop to F6 I think
Tanya you mentioned this idea uh is
super logical
probably Bishop F6 and I just want to
point out one small tactic black should
not get tempted to take the C5 pawn
queen C5 here which hits the Knight on
C3 and of course if white does Recapture
the B4 Knight Black's a happy camper
picks up that Knight on C3 but there is
the Intermezzo with the Knight jumping
to A4 now you've got a double attack
going you hit the queen on C5 next move
you pick up the piece and you're
basically just winning on the spot so
Queen C5 is a little trap here and as
you were saying Fabi the Knight cannot
Retreat the D5 Pawn is hanging in the
current position so Bishop F6 would make
a lot of sense it's on the board hitting
that Knight on C3 are we expecting ding
to Simply sidestep with that Rook bring
it to C1 defend the night and renew the
threat on the night only on B4
Rook C1 makes a lot of sense or a takes
B4 makes a lot of sense
uh ab4 Bishop C3 Rook B1 because you're
you're saying that your queen side pawns
are kind of valuable
and let's say Bishop takes G4 Queen
takes D5 on the other hand black does
have the the bishop pair
but those Queen side pawns are pretty
menacing and the bishop on C3 is a
little bit out of the game for the
moment maybe A5 was actually important
instead of Bishop takes G4 maybe you
really need to break up those Queen side
pawns ASAP and and probably win the C
Pawn I guess black is is going to be
doing very very well here so maybe
dingleplay Works C1 as you mentioned
very logical can't be a bad move kind of
forcing Bishop takes C3 because you
don't want to lose your D5 Pawn on the
board we might see all of this so the
move Rook C1 was just played just to
show what happened here protecting this
Knight and yeah fobby's saying you have
to take this Knight because if this
Knight Retreats thank you very much for
your Central Pawn with Tempo against
your queen against your Bishop white
would be up a pawn and just with the
advantage uh in all directions so I
think that Bishop takes his Force but in
this line Bishop takes Rook takes Knight
C6 Queen takes D5 Bishop takes G4 we see
equal material but white is very active
here on some nice squares but how much
is this
yeah it depends on if white can generate
some threats quickly because if given
time black will be positionally doing
completely fine
of course black is not going to be
better black is still
at best going to be equalizing
but after Bishop G4
yeah I guess does he have options
besides Bishop G4 he does
have maybe move like Rook to d8
also makes a lot of sense Bobby does why
actually have to take this Pawn because
that's a long-term weakness so now I'm
just thinking can white push this Pawn
to G5
um
yeah G5 Rooks a DH so how is that going
and then and an id4 or something like
that yeah that's what I was thinking
yeah but then Queen to E5 will that G5
Partners is also a weakness which is
going to be the Knight may be tied to
the defense of it and also blackheads D4
here I'm starting to think that black is
gaining a lot of very important space
right so how would you continue C5 Pawn
is loose as well so I have some nice
looking uh ideas here but I also have to
be worried because my ponds white spawns
are very loose in this position and yeah
that's a bit of a struggle because
Knight D4 is you point a queen E5 is a
nasty way of attacking the knight in the
center attacking the G5 Pawn
yeah this is getting a little tactical
and maybe good for black to me it looks
like black has equalizing here you can
still tag on C6 play Queen D2 but you're
not absolutely thrilled to have taken on
C6 and uh helped black deal with the
weakness of the B7 pawn and also the
weakness of the D5 Pawn now both of
those pawns are quite secure so this is
definitely an option like it looks like
a position where white can certainly
play on
but probably not for serious chance of
advantage
yeah G5 is an option Queen D5 those are
the two moves that Ding will be thinking
about here
I just say I think both players approach
the opening quite welding had some
original ideas Beyond played quickly and
it seems like in a very healthy manner
so so far so good for both of them
yeah and Tanya I guess you know I just
asked father you gotta ask you too would
you grab this Pawn on D5 I know it's
hard to pass up or would you push this
Pawn to G5 and say you're isolated Pawn
is a long-term weakness if I can
accurately play around it
Robert I have to admit that G5 would not
have come to my mind but the moment you
pointed it I I love that move G5 you
kind of just hold on to your own Jeep on
and say D5 long term weakness and I'm
gonna try and Target it the line that we
were looking at with that pawn perhaps
advancing to D4 off to G5 Rook slides
into d8 to defend it you're threatening
D4 white can have long-term plans of
Shifting the queen away from D1 doubling
up on the D file I just feel that I can
start targeting your D4 pawn my Bishop
on G2 will be an absolute monster once
you push D4 look at that long diagonal
uh and yes G5 is a Grand Master Level
move I'm not sure how easily I would
have found it but the moment that you
mention it I do like it I do like G5 and
the fact that Ding has slowed down at
this moment hasn't just automatically
captured the pawn on D5 he's definitely
looking at that and we've been talking
about who this opening has been a
success for an amazing idea by ding to
go for this as mentioned earlier a brand
new position very very early on a fresh
idea perhaps a certain Richie Richard
rapper had something to do with that but
it's worked really well so far but also
equally impressive how Yan hasn't gone
into any kind of panic mode or shock
mode he's been playing fast and so far
so good for black as well big option as
they grab on D5 or does he keep the
pressure with G5
well now I'm wondering about a third and
Favi I'm gonna throw it to you because
Tanya's idea where you can play G5 and
queen A4 let me think can I just start
with Queen A4 and then try to put a rook
on the D file I protect my Pawn from the
fourth rank so the big question I think
we're looking at two branches either we
trade D5 or G4 or if we're going to try
to keep our G pawn and go after the
d-pawn later is a move like Queen A4 a
good idea for white
yeah I was considering this option a bit
as a queen A4 it comes to mind as a way
to prevent black from playing D4 so for
example after Rook d8 you can play Rook
to D1
and you would like to blockade
on that square
uh it also makes it more difficult
because the Jeep on push it does allow
the F5 Square to be used for Black's
bishop and now it's not easy to say
where the bishop blackbish will go it
can go to E6 but it's a bit passive
there it can go to D7 I don't think
tactically white can take the D5 Pawn
yet but I don't see what it's doing on
D7 especially here Knight to E7
would material so uh y would have to
wait with capturing that pawn but then
white could maybe consider G5 at a later
moment I'm not sure how black can use
this what they discovered attack on the
queen unless it wins material tactically
because for example G5 Knight to E5 I
think white can play either Queen D4 or
queen F or both are very logical moves
Knight F3 Bishop of three and here we
have like an ideal situation for white
because the d-pawn is firmly blockaded
it's not advancing and white can also
consider a king side attack with King G2
Rook H1 and
potentially targeting the H7 Pawn it's
not
guaranteed that this will lead to some
sort of Victory because black has Bishop
of five at some moments to defend that
pawn but overall white is definitely
pressing here in a very very safe and
comfortable way so for Rapid chest this
is like dream for white and Nightmare
for black
but after Queen A4
uh I was thinking also Rook T8 is super
logical
but then I think Knight
how are you dealing with this maybe
Knight's D4 because E3 allows work to E4
and now we're 94 Queen D4 rookie two
uh it does grab a problem
oh my god there you go don't take on D4
it's okay it's rapid chess I forgive you
but ding I mean he hasn't moved yet so
Queen A4 Queen D5 g53 logical moves so
do you think Queen A4 is now becoming
increasingly likely the more he thinks
or what direction is he gonna take this
game and well he just answered it
immediately by taking on D5 I think the
most likely option is Queen takes D5 is
so this is logical I mean here here you
can continue with Rook to B1 I think
that's that's a pretty
interesting way to continue he also can
like Queen to E4 I think he would like
to see a trade on F3 because I would
give the white the very powerful Bishop
compared to Black's Knight
uh but it's not
I think maybe Queen A4 was a little bit
more of a testing option even though
they're probably equivalent moves I just
like like keeping control and trying to
establish that blockade on D4 here it's
more
like black can probably calculate his
way out of any trouble if that happens
yeah Tanya I mean you actually inspired
me with that Queen slides A4 so I I
agree but I guess the question is do you
feel like now Jan's pieces are more free
and that he has more ideas of his own
and maybe ding should not have swapped
those pawns just now
this is definitely a very open position
and as we can see black is coming in
with more development with tempos that
Queen on D5 can be targeted with the
Rook sliding onto d8 that pawn on E2 can
be targeted with the other Rook sliding
into EA so it does look like the next
few moves are going to be easier for Yan
to make and what's the follow-up here
you've got this C5 Pawn you've got to
watch out for that C5 and A3 are bonds
which have been disconnected perhaps
something to worry about in the long
term but that's a far away end game
possibility but just something to keep
in mind I think these kind of positions
white can't really afford to play super
slow you've got to find your own chances
and I'm trying to think what's the move
here do you start chasing the black
Bishop as a move like Queen G5 makes
sense I want to attack your Bishop I
want to start doubling up on the d-line
You're gonna laugh and maybe you both
will laugh at me or with me but you
remember that Knight G5 in game 14 could
we see another Knight G5 because it has
a pretty nasty threat of Queen E4
yeah that's nice most of those moves
that you guys mentioned are very
interesting Knight G5 uh has a very
direct threat oh also does Queen G5
big threat right now
so we can deal with this in a few ways I
think Queen maybe Queen E7 allows rookie
three though that's that would start to
look a bit dangerous
I mean to F6 suddenly's force and then
uh you know why get some time for Knight
to E4
um Knight to D6 ideas so even though
black is not tactically losing here just
the Knight being on D6 is enough to
travel block quite a bit so actually
after working through maybe Queen the
agents for us but you don't want to get
into that territory so Queen E7 feels
like uh you you don't want that move
H6 allows Queen to E4 I think this is
very interesting for white h625 Force
Queen G4 attacks G5 and queen to E5
would be the logical way to continue
this line
but white has pressure probably with the
variety of moves here
um
you know could it could be Rook B3 then
we there's a lot to calculate Rook b394
it could be root to C4 also some move
like that might be might be also very
pleasant for one if you get like E3 and
then you slowly pressure the B7 Pawn
then we're I think we're talking about
something for white here some pressure
seems way easier for white to play these
types of positions yeah for sure maybe
some Rook to E8 is the right way which
reproves ft8 and then why we'll play
Knight E4 right at some point
yeah why not pop a pony on D6 and see
what happens later these pawns are weak
that Knight is established and trenched
on the Square this looks very very nice
for dingly Wren even slacking the E2
Pawn because Bishop B2 Rook B1 I I it's
not the material it's like the B7 Pawn
is a really serious weakness
once the Knight comes to D6 the Tactical
danger is really through the roof
maybe maybe a want a six kind of
defends up on but you don't want to do
that to yourself right
hey Tanya that feels like a very very
sad issue I know it protects a pawn and
is protected by the pawn but then it's
out of play on the other side of the
board
I'm not Pony on D6 that you're talking
about that's no pony that's an absolute
dragon on the board a robin if that
Knight does land on D6 and that's what
we were talking about right white needs
to be direct here white needs to play
quickly for the attack and ding Lauren
going with the idea of Knight G5 a big
threat on the board with the queen
stepping back a double attack a mate on
eight seven a potential made on eight
seven and hitting that Bishop on G4 and
this has got to be a Deja Vu moment for
yeah because ding went for the attack
with this exact same move in game 14.
now that didn't work out so well but
here the foundation for this attack just
feels a lot better than it did in game
14.
you know what I I like how both these
guys are approaching the game I think
they're they're playing really well and
also I feel like they're playing better
and rapid than In classical chess
or maybe I'm wrong but it feels like
they're like why are we why are we
having these seven hour games when when
they play better with with 25 minutes on
their clock
are we commentating with Magnus Carlson
or five out of caruana because that
sounds like his argument I do think that
the play thus far in Rapid has been
really high level I know we're only 18
moves in we are gonna have a best of
four match here in Rapid time which of
25 minute plus 10 seconds added per move
but this has been a high level game ding
comes with exquisite opening preparation
and Jana Pomchi thanks for a little bit
in the early going it says you know what
I can handle this we're in a position
where it's not a symmetrical Pawn
structure white has these split pawns
that Tanya said is a worry in the long
term black has a healthier Pawn
structure but white has all the activity
with the Knight and the Queen the E4
squares available for the queen
threatening Checkmate or for the Knight
to reroute and hop into D6 so I like the
look of this position for white we see
the eval bar saying black is in this but
Fabi I'm getting the sense that it's
much more difficult for black to play
even on this turn you we could see the
evaluation bar swing heavily in White's
favor
yeah it's it's very easy to imagine
white so after H6 yeah I was going to
say that white has a choice here Queen
to E4 is what we looked at but I'm
really tempted by Knight to E4 it's
similar to rookie a94 because I I'm
sacking the E2 Pawn that's absolutely
true but that pawn is is not as relevant
I think as getting the Knight to D6
and after Knight to E4
I think we should examine this because
it's it's a really potentially critical
line
and ding
the reason why ding is thinking at this
moment is because it's a huge decision
for White Queen to E4 and Knight E4 are
both extremely logical moves and they
lead to very very different types of
positions one is a pawn sack the other
is just an attempt to kind of secure a
slight Advantage keep control of the
position
uh I guess black and I don't know if
black needs to take on E2 or if it's the
best option but let's have a look at
Bishop takes E2
I guess yeah Rook to B1 it's it can also
go to E1 but let's say the B1
and
how is how is black supposed to approach
this
um
I took a to d8 96 Bishop A6 but you
really don't want to put your Bishop 26
I would take I would take White's
position if black is forced to put the
bishop there I and I think what's very
instructive to our audience is that
Black's extra Pawn is this Pawn over
here it's not really playing a part in
the current dynamics of the game this
Knight on D6 means a rook can't go to E8
I'll take that it's putting pressure on
B7 which means your Bishop is offside
over here your knight it can move but
where too there is no strong Outpost for
it and later a knife can come to F5 and
try to help threaten uh Checkmate not to
mention Bishop E4 Queen F5 so we have
seen a move played it was indeed Knight
to E4 so it's a pawn sacrifice but you
know it's not a movie anymore this is
real life and this Knight is coming to
D6
I like John's move as well I mean uh
Knight D4 looked like the most critical
move
although it was really a tough choice
between that and queen E4 and I like
rookie because after 196 he gets his
Rook active and the the real problem
with Black's position in those uh Pawn
side lines we just looked at where that
Black's Rooks were being dominated by
the Knight on D6 because they couldn't
get access to the E8 square or the C8
square and so on d8 square is kind of
like looking into into a rock right
you're not you don't want to take on D6
so basically your Rook doesn't achieve
much there but on E2
it really does and also after 96 black
can considered a rook to E5 so he plays
E3 no longer a pawn sack Rook to E5 on
the board
uh so it's concrete now can white
establish a knight or is Black's
activity
like you can trade queen or try to trade
Queens I don't think black will take on
D6 in case I mean D6 happens I think
maybe Queen D6 could be met by Queen to
A5 for example
uh you can also be met by a trade on
blacks terms but I think I think Queen
A5 is very logical
with Queen D6 Queen A5 Knight F6 or is
it yeah it's probably the same thing but
the tactic doesn't work yes ah but it's
such a really instructive idea that
Knight F6 you give a knight to take this
Knight here and you're trying to go
after well this these pieces but
unfortunately this Rook on C3 is loose
over on the queen side but that that
idea Knight F6 by the way can't happen
if a rook comes to C4 or something on
the fourth rank this bishop is also
loose so Tanya is eyeing for some kind
of Knight F6 check tactics inside of
course can also sink its teeth into D6
and black can't afford to make a move
like B6 you're opening up this side of
the board and then your knight F6
tactics will play A Part after taking on
E6 there will be Knight F6 and getting
this Knight here on C6 so it's a very
precarious spot for Yonder Palms he is
up a couple minutes so Tanya what do you
make of this first ding was ahead in the
clock now Jan he's stabilized the
positions to some extent and now he has
the slight lead on time
it's a two-minute lead and in a rapid
game that could count for a lot just
depending on how quickly he makes the
next few moves but I like the way how
he's handled it Knight D6 is still a
scary threat to deal with this is a game
for all three results where draw is
perhaps the least likely that night
jumping on D6 and I still prefer ding's
position I think team dink can Pat
themselves on the back for how well the
opening has worked out for them in this
game one of the rapid I'm with you Fabi
so Knight D6 we know that's the main
idea what happens next like what is
White's plan to pile up on either B7 or
what's the main idea to follow Knight D6
yeah I think if white 96 happens white
continues with Rook B1 and black real
actually just needs to avoid that
scenario so it's not even so much what
is why do you have to 96 it's really how
does Black Avoid that because let's say
we put Rook d8 96 on the board I think
it's already just a a pretty bad
position for black uh and the main issue
for black is that B6 would be nice but
it just probably tactically does not
work after cp6 Queen D6 Queen D6 Rook D6
and B7 I think is that I mean it's
actually quite sharp but Knight B8 Rook
C8 does seem to win the game so wow okay
this is this this is really close to
being okay for black but unfortunately
for him it doesn't seem to work out but
Fabi is relevant because Rook d8 was
just played and just to remind everybody
how we got there the first move of the
variation was Rook d8 which earned a
question mark and you said as much you
said Rook date is not a good idea and
the Knight just plants itself on D6 and
the advantage is growing for dingley Ren
and black has no active counter play at
the moment Rook B1 is obviously the next
move and b7's in huge trouble
I think he missed I think he missed the
V7 and then just he was probably
thinking B6 works out
and maybe he should have played Queen A5
instead of Rook d8 because like before
my second point before he made the move
was going to be that white like needs to
prevent Knight D6 at all costs and maybe
Queen A5 was a way to do so by trying to
Target the C5 Pawn before
because now after Queen A5 I think it
might be too late to Target that pawn
white can just try to defend the C Pawn
with maybe Queen C2 there's there might
be other ways but then black has to see
what the Knight B7 is correct so I think
black needed to get ahead of the Knight
D6
a move and he maybe thought he was by
playing V6 here but V6 we saw just
doesn't work tactically because the
problem B7 it's a bit surprising maybe
visually that black cat doesn't have my
B8 there it feels like black is
able to cover the eighth rank with
something
but after B7 you just you just don't
have anything to cover the eighth rank
it's just very concrete one one move and
black would be fine but
so he's gonna make so he's gonna do
something else because this is
yeah really but B7 B7 is extraordinary
every other move it seems like black has
chances but B7 would win the game it
said Rook H5 so this feels like rapid
chess we are seeing a rook come to an
open H file is there going to be a
Checkmate well if this Knight gets the
E5 into F3 so Tanya I know the eval bar
is going up in White's favor but this is
at least double edged
yeah this is why you don't care about
what the eval bar is saying because your
opponent makes a move like Rook H5 95
ideas and also Queen D7 Bishop H3 I
really want to get my queen onto that H
file to give a Checkmate these are
things that you start thinking about you
start worrying about White's plan is
clear white wants to go for the B7 Pawn
Jan's plan is clear he wants to go for
ding's King here who gets where faster
is the question I'm expecting ding to
slow down and actually judge how
dangerous this attack really is a move
like Rook B1 is what he's considering
but then just does Black start following
it up immediately with a trade of the
fan shadowed Bishop on G2 that is the
key defender in White's position it
would be an absolute dream for black to
get these Bishops off the board I have
to show them it's I mean I thought I
know what you're gonna say so let's say
it together that Rook B one there's
Knight to E5 because that's a rook takes
B7 thank you for a free Pawn I'm getting
your queen but Knight F3 check is
devastating if you move your king thank
you for your queen with check as well if
you take this takes that is Unstoppable
Checkmate on H1 so Rook B1 would be a
huge mistake from dingling around at
this point
yeah absolutely rugby one allows I mean
it would be very strong enough for this
95 idea that you demonstrated
and then the question is how does why
deal with both the idea of 95 and the
other idea of tiny that you mentioned
The Bishop's H3 because
if White
if White made some passy move like A4 I
think black's idea would not be 95
because then F4 would come but to play
Bishop to H3 and obviously A4 doesn't
um
wait what if the velbar didn't my A4 was
my uh kind of demonstrative move and
then developer didn't move when I played
when you played A4 there so
but it doesn't do anything so there must
be a better move well I think what it
means Fabi is that White's just better
here because you have a knight that's
sitting on D6 and can't really be kicked
out so even if the bishop trade happens
and this is informative for us that
we're looking at this like okay Bishop
H3 that looks scary for White and the
computer's probably laughing I'll just
take and play King G2 so he does play he
plays Ruby one you saw yawn he's looking
like are you sure about that because
Knight E5 turns the tables oh he wants
to play E4 but black and black can play
Queen takes oh no black can't play Queen
okay I got excited
and
you even move you want to make it in a
bullet game but Knight E5 you need that
Rook on F1 so that you can get F4 in and
the F3 square is controlled and Yan in
seconds plays 95 this is turning around
and getting super dangerous for ding now
you want to play E4 for sure that was
the idea
but it feels a bit shaky and now you
don't threaten Rook takes B7 because of
Queen takes B7 so black is given room to
breathe and also
uh Bobby
I think I see it
like can you play through B6 because
after Pawn takes B6 Pawn takes B6 you
can't take the queen because Knight F3
check again I've given up the queen but
this is Checkmate on each one I think
this is the idea and I think Jan spotted
it I the way he looked at ding he's like
uh are you sure about this this Knight
only five is too strong
yeah that that's beautiful so I when I
got excited earlier I was going to
suggest Queen takes C5 with the same
idea but after Rook C5 Knight F3 Bishop
three Bishop three those who takes H5 so
I got like momentarily excited by this
queen sack but but I heard you I heard
you say queen 65 and I didn't show it
because I didn't want to put you on the
spot blundering this position but you
gave me the idea and so he plays Beast
spots it
are we gonna see that happen no well
ding will not take the queen but but
this is a brilliant uh brilliant Fun by
young but for sure ding ding will not
fall for it
gosh what do you have time to put in
have forehill he he might but then there
are all sorts of problems around this
King on G1 it's very open on the king's
side and this Rook on H5 it looked like
a strange move we you know you're saying
you're tuning on attack that's not gonna
happen but it might happen I mean this
is a huge attacking possibility and Jan
de palmshi
Ernest Hemingway I believe was him once
said that courage is Grace Under
Pressure he was under pressure on the
queen side he gracefully steps his
Knight into E5 he will give up her
majesty on C7 because Checkmate is more
valuable and that is what he's aiming
for
so I'm thinking about some like very
interesting lines after F4
is that drive four it's super super
direct super critical and black has a
move Knight to F3
yes and
so Knight F3 is four scene Bishop takes
up three
yep okay so it's uh
yeah it's exactly what ding's thinking
about F4 Knight F3 checks of takes taste
C takes B6 because you can't take on a
three Queen C5 will win the night back
my goodness checked his King and give me
that Knight okay but after C takes B6
lacks threat of Rook H1 Rook H2 it was a
threat but the queen on C7 is now
attacked and it's some chaos I mean uh
if you take Rook takes D6 then B takes
C7 white is promoting first and we'll
win the game wait or not wait oh yeah
okay the evaluation bar react a little
slowly but it is winning yes
and so
how is black responding here it might be
some queen move somewhere like it's it's
absolutely crazy position oh my gosh
it could be something it could be Queen
takes B6 Rook B6 Rook H1 king of two
Rook H2 I think that's that's oh it says
give me that Queen I don't know it's not
because the problem is rookie should I
take this on F3 yeah I thought Rook
takes D2 but that might
uh this is under attack this is under
attack Knight takes F7 probably wins
yeah oh okay so you just start taking
pawns good fine but Bobby you see these
things so deeply help us mere mortals
then you are being very instructive here
that this Knight was under attack Twice
The Rook was under attack so it starts
taking some Pawns in the process white
would be in a winning rook and pawn
ending over there so wow big idea F4
Knight F3 check but to see after C takes
B6 we haven't found the move for black
so the onus will be on janapamshi in
this position Knight F3 takes takes C
takes B6 maybe it's some kind of queen
move to go for a change yeah but that
looks no it's not that either I'm making
the most natural moves I'm making
mistakes this is how tricky the position
is
hmm yeah this is a this is not obvious
in that case yeah and then Queen G2
yeah you steal the bishop in Luigi too
good idea by Tanya just covering the
Checkmate trying to trade Queens you
pass Pawn so what in the world does
black have available there can black
just keep the contact with that Knight
on D6 and step one more Square to Woods
that King go Queen E7 right now I want
to pick up the Knight with my rook and
I'm just looking at these lines with B7
and I think you can still take Rook no
Rook D6 your queen with a check then you
then you take the queen Rook H1 Rook H2O
okay well we see him move let's go back
to the live board we see cb6 ab6 has
been played and that was an inaccuracy
apparently by doing the remember the
evaluation bar is still only slightly in
Jan's favorite a takes B6 is a brilliant
move that deserves not just two
exclamation points maybe 20 because that
was such a nasty idea just to remind
everybody you cannot take a queen this
isn't one of my games where I
accidentally blundered my queen in speed
chess Knight F3 check would be available
it was an unexpected amazing idea that
Jana pumps just worked in this first
game of the tie breaks in the world
championship but do not take what
appears to be a free queen that would be
a devastating blunder that would lose
dingley Run the game but so the question
that we have to answer is what can he do
to save this game it says it's only
slightly better for black but everything
only one move here I think what's that
thing Knight to B5 Knight to B5 has to
be played so after Rook D2 you play
Knight C7 you you don't lose contact
with the F3 square and for sure black uh
has a lot of activity but after Knight
B5 I don't see
like the Tactical issues and what are
the moves you have I think that this is
his plan because otherwise you just lose
your knight on D6
or you get checkmated so ABC's okay I
have a name for this this is this is the
Advanced photos Gambit you saw the botas
Gambit it didn't work out
this is Jan's prep is to you know he's
he's learned for from the greats of the
past and he's amended it and this is the
advanced protest camp and we see people
saying oh no my queen Allah Eric Rosen
and also Fabi saying oh who cares about
the White Queen because then you get the
black wing with your knight and it's
very important this is essential
everybody that The Rook needs to stay in
contact with the F3 Square because if
you take this queen just once more to
remind you all Knight F3 check the
bishop takes and then this bishop gets
in threatening Checkmate in the corner
that's why we tell you to keep your feet
and kettled Bishops on the board because
you created a mating net around your
king So Tanya Knight B5 Fabi pointed out
the only move for white to keep the
balance here do you think dingley runs
bosses now he's just over five minutes
remaining
and he has to right or he goes in for
this line with F4 directly hitting that
Knight on E5 as long as the Rook on C3
still has a df3 square under control I
think he's he is reaching out he finds
it he finds the move Knight B5 so we've
got to take this position in for just a
second right White Queen is hiding on D2
black screen can be picked up with the
Knight or The Rook on the move right
before this Yana promise is sacrificing
a queen for a mating attack on the king
side this is stunning chess Knight B5
plate will Yan go for the end game or
does he simply keep the pressure go
Queen E7 move that Queen away you're
still putting pressure on that D2 Queen
keep the tension on two tempting options
Fabi Queen E7 looks good for a potential
attack Rook takes D2 how could we not
let like Landing our Rook on the second
rank or the seventh rank if you want but
Knight takes E7 without Queens do you
think that Jan has realistic winning
chances
I think that he should probably trade
Queens because there's also risk for
black like you you could attack but your
Rook on a tribe could become stranded if
there was no attack and queen E7 white
can consider Queen to E3 uh
I mean you can also put the queen on F4
maybe that's it's hard to say exactly
which is better
between the F4 keeps some contact with
the bishop on G4 so but in any case I'm
not seeing like the clear uh direct
continuation for black there maybe to
trade Bishops on H3 because the bishop
on G2 is pretty as a really wonderful
Defender but I'm looking at Rook D2
Knight C7 and Knight to D3
as a very concrete approach I mean
rather than uh you know moving about and
going for some vague play let's go for a
direct play it's usually uh usually how
you're supposed to play when you have
the initiative you attack F2 Rook F1 is
met by Bishop to E2 that looks pretty
passive for white
uh maybe you can go back and forth Rook
V1
and wow maybe why I told him but here
it's nice for black because you have the
the uh uh safety net the drawing you can
you know Play Bishop G4 Bishop B2 and so
on if you want and after Bishop G4
but Bobby just quickly you're such a
super GM that you accidentally find
three move repetitions that nobody else
would find like like yeah this is before
Rook F1
okay Anish Anish will have a field day
with this one
but okay so instead of uh after Rook if
one or where did you wanna
well if if white doesn't play Rook to F1
and white tries to avoid this and plays
for example F3
I'm getting super worried that just like
the simple Bishop to H3 that you know
white just starts to get check baited I
mean if you it you'd think like you
don't Checkmate in an end game but
actually you you do something Checkmate
and then game and for example Bishop to
H1 here no you don't want to do that but
after Rook G5 I think it's like
I mean I'm threatening Checkmate and
whatever yeah and here King F1 Rook F2
and there there is your Checkmate so
white might have to be super precise but
this Rook F1 maybe he's very fortunate
that he's holding it together that way I
think ding has seen this and that's why
he was pausing
with the move Knight to B5 but somehow
Jan took over the initiative fully
amazing yeah Jana keep the Queens in
this position Fabi he's
on to less than six minutes on the clock
and it's really not clear what's the
part of the queen E7 because you are
hitting the queen on D2 you've got ideas
of Bishop H3 Knight F3 in the air I'm
predicting Queen E7 by Yan no trade here
but I I think one of what we have to
consider is the match situation as well
because if this were a one-off game I
think queenie7 makes a lot of sense but
as far is saying there is some risk here
this Rook on H5 is in an odd spot it
doesn't really have too much mobility
and if we can firmly defend our squares
then white can also look at his B6 Pawn
as a Target this Knight can go through
C7 back to D5 at a critical moment and I
know that I have to keep my queen safe
first but I could see that being risky
and John does take on D2 I think the
match situation plays a big role in his
decision making a draw with black is a
good result overall it means he'll have
two whites in the rapid and dingley Wren
will only have one remaining yeah I
think that it's just a practical
decision he sees that from ID3 White's
probably only defenses Rook to F1 and
then at least he has a safety net of the
draw also in with the Queen's on I was
like I just had a flashback game 12. I
mean it's it's obviously a very
different position but the Rook The Rook
was on H6 there uh
with the game which xion was winning but
lost that really crucial game I mean The
Rook was stranded it was an attack
attacking piece which ended up getting
stranded and you can easily see this you
think I have a bunch of pieces
surrounding my opponent's king
but the bishop on G2 usually defends
things really really well so unless you
see something concrete there you don't
want to go for it because I would see
shades of that game 12 where uh you know
things starts to vacuum up the queen
side in this case the queen side is one
Pawn but he plays Queen to E3 he attacks
the B6 Pawn he takes it he gets a
material advantage the attack doesn't
work out you start to wonder why didn't
I go for what was the objectively
correct approach which was Rook D2 I'd
see seven and
now the only question to me is okay yeah
we'll have it drawn hand if he wants it
even that is a very good outcome will he
have more after my D3 rookie one does
does black have a try there I see Rook
to C5 as potentially a try 93 Rook of
one works C5 is coming to mind here
and you receive beyond I mean he is
thinking about this position because he
can hop his Knight in and dingley wren
look at him he's analyzing right now
he's darting from left to right both
sides of the board are under his Focus
because his F2 Pawn that's the pawn that
we expect to be targeted he knows he can
slide his Rook over in the defense of it
but as Fabi is saying that blackwork on
H5 will have a new availability along
the fifth Rank and that could pose white
some problems so we see Yan has made his
move he was Bishop H3 instead and I
honestly think that you know without
shutting this position down that black
could be in some long-term danger with
this Pawn on B6 already under attack
yeah I think that this move I mean it
can contains such a direct threat that I
do like it the threat is to take and
play Knight to G4 and then black uh
crucially not only attacks F2 but also
threads Rook to H2
so he takes and he'll probably play King
G2 I mean you might as well keep that
King back
can he also bring his Knight back
and isn't that threatened to win this
Rook over here oh that does wait so nice
oh my God 95 is a very nice move so wait
in Black play night
I'm trying to calculate Knight G4 Knight
F4
and then Rook H2 let's analyze it very
quickly Knight F4 this Rook H2
somehow this and G5 is very important
F3 G5 is super important the Rooks don't
defend each other yeah that's good news
yeah actually I'm uh on the
hallucinating I mean you can just play
Knight E5 or something like that
yeah but this already doesn't look good
for white so you found Knight G4 here to
give your Rook the H2 square but that
looks like a flimsy configuration even
with like Rook F3 just preemptively
defending trying to kick this Knight out
of here I'm getting worried for young I
know the eval Bar says zeros but
something about this Rook on the H file
you gave us flashbacks to a game 12
Bobby I could see that being a point in
this game as well
yeah it's it's a double-edged position
for sure I because you're really going
your play is kind of one-dimensional as
any you're very often losing your b-pawn
I mean that pawn can no longer be
defended so you're counting on the fact
that white will not be able to capture
it because the king safety is a more
important issue but if at some point
Black's pieces get forced back
as you say I like the Knight D5 move a
lot I wonder if maybe G5 is is an
interesting option there because I want
to create that G4 Knight F3 sort of I
don't really believe it works because
the Rook might get trapped with Knight
F4 but G5 does come into mind as an
interesting idea in some positions I
actually want to show that one very
quickly and Tanya I mean this position
it's one where we're talking about how
black could have been on the attack but
let's say I'm just trying to force this
position somehow if you play G4 I mean I
still have Knight F4 right you're you
know Rook is trapped so that's the big
problem so Tanya we see the game do you
think that dingly Ren might be able to
take this one and do you think uh that
Jan he feels confident about his chances
here
I mean this is getting super tricky now
but I do like how Yan has just focused
on the king side he has this one idea of
either Landing with a knight to G4 or F3
and I'm thinking about these lines that
you and Fabi are looking at Knight D5
Bobby the move G5 makes so much sense
but where's your Rook heading after King
G2 I was struggling to find a safe spot
because suddenly The Rook can't go back
to H5 that Knight on D5 will jump over
to F6 but there's a different approach
that dingler intakes he first hits that
Rook on H3 and after Rook H5 he could
very well be heading to D5 with the
Knight you're still coming to F4 you're
still hitting the pawn on B6 but now
with this King on G2 Knight G4 the
checks become real there's Rook F2 Rook
H2 coming in with the check so now I
like Knight G4 a lot more in this
position oh but what a move Rook B5 he
pins along the fifth Rank and okay
blacks what does that do here Fabi maybe
G6
then there's like Knight E8 to F6
uh 98 Knight G4
I'm keeping we're keeping it together I
think maybe G because how else are you
dealing with this I mean
um oh by the way after g698 there's also
I know there's not work takes up too but
they're almost his work take stuff too
yeah these tactics are gonna be
everywhere yeah G6 is the move here uh
also Knight D5 there was met by Knight
to G4 but you know what I'm looking at
what's that is this a draw G6 Knight D5
Knight to G4 King to F3 Rook takes F2
King G4 Rook G5 and repetition what wow
oh my god king H3 not a king H4 because
uh yeah can you shoot Rook H5 I don't
see them made after King G4 for black
because F5 crucially blunders of like
EF5 gf5 it's not made because King takes
H5
so important point
I know I'm like thrilling all you guys
with with one draw after the other
you are we take this draw this was
fantastic but a different move by Yani
goes Rook D1 and he wants to try to set
up the mate but he's coming in with the
other Rook to H1 and start threatening a
mage on G1 that's what he wants but the
E5 Knight he's got to watch out for that
it's it's a it's not a threat of mate
it's a threat of draw because Rook H1
rookie five Rook H2 is a rapid wait
where so Rook H1 97 King H7 is a draw
right okay that's actually an essential
save at this point because it looks like
you just blundered into a mating at
either Rook to H1 sets up checkmating
ideas but this Rook to go over K2 and
dingley Wren he's down to three minutes
and 21 seconds but he is finding great
defensive resources so I I love Rook B5
Knight D5 also looks valuable because he
has this check to keep that rook in
contact with the Knight and that means
Rook H1 one of these ideas could be a
mistake
well I think Rook dth one is a draw and
it's what we're gonna see yeah nice nice
game
well played and 97 King H7 rookie 5 Rook
uh one to H2 leads to a repetition of
moves and this is going to be seen on
the board
any second
I mean step up to F3 because the Rook on
E5 hangs so he has to stay connected to
that Rook on H1 and there we see what a
draw this has been handshakes the first
game of the rapid playoff ends in a draw
but it was anything but peaceful Robert
oh my goodness we saw fireworks on
display it's only 5 51 am in New York
but I feel like I'm at a festival that
was some exhilarating chess these
players brought their all to game one I
thought the opening Advantage was
dingley wren's but then he misstepped
after playing against 996 so Yanda Palm
she I think he escaped to some extent
with that half point
yeah that was a that was a really really
funny conspiracy rate of this of this
game Fabby if you had to take a guess on
accuracy how much you think this would
be probably like 94 wow
it just felt like the players were
playing the best moves in this game one
what a thrilling finish that was ending
in a Perpetual after sacrificing that
piece and in the tie breaks the players
start with a level game this I just set
the tone for the rest of the three rapid
games remaining it's gonna be fireworks
from the start and now Jana Palmer she
will start with the white pieces Robert
some big moments in this game some huge
moments as early as move four in a
previous game I mentioned that you could
take this Pawn C5 I was curious if
dingler would go for it he does indeed
and after E6 plays the awkward looking
Bishop E3 saving his Pawn so Fabi I mean
the early stage of this game Advantage
dingley Ren yeah I think overall ding
was definitely dictating the result of
the opening and it was a really nice
opening choice for him he was well
prepared the critical moment was
probably after that Rook to H5 move
I know we're we're going through a lot
of really tense and uh unclear positions
but they were just playing perfectly
and then at some point
at some point Jan made a mistake maybe
maybe it was this Rook to d8 move
and maybe he was based on missing that
B6 loses the game because of this B7
move that we we spotted which is really
crucial for white proving an advantage
here not just inventors but the women
and then Jan went for this remarkable
Rook to H5 idea I think it was a
brilliant practical try it was based on
the tactics that we saw in the game
ding had some way to invent it here but
it wasn't easy maybe it was to move F4 I
was going to suggest this would be four
thing played Rook to B1 but who knows
what would have happened they were to be
one allowed Yan to unleash some some
beautiful tactics which we feel like
they're so beautiful they should be
enough for a win but
but they're only enough for a draw turns
out
with this queen sacrifice
beautiful this deserves so many
exclamation points to show you all once
more Rook C7 was met by Knight F3 check
you can avoid Checkmate but you lose
your queen and then your knight black
steals a piece and if you take it's like
I'm up a queen well you're down a
Checkmate Rook H1 would end the game so
dingley Wren was not falling for that he
played his only move Knight to B5 and
after the queens were swapped there were
some chances here The Rook on H3 was
almost trapped some great moves like
Rook B5 but Jan was able to bail out
just in time after Rook to D1 he brought
a rook to H1 and the whole point is that
after The Rook takes 95 if you take back
thank you for your rook in the corner
that still would be equality but let's
just force the draw no risk taken here
so we saw a draw in game one there was a
lot of fight in that one despite only 35
moves the players really were trying to
throw their punches
yeah I really like this game I I think
that they they were really
um Not only was it beautiful for us to
watch but it was also really really well
played I mean we can only really spot to
one moment I think to criticize from
each player maybe Rook to be won by Ding
and Rook T8 D.A by Young I'm not even
sure if we can criticize that move
because it was so complex
but ding ding missed a little bit here
he definitely had some chances to push
for more but it wasn't easy this Rook H5
all right even if the computer says it's
not the best move I still really like it
I think sometimes the best engine move
and the best practical move are
different
I think it's safe to say that we just
saw one of the best games of this world
championship match the second world
champion Emmanuel Oscar said if you find
a good move look for a better one and
that might be great advice for classical
with seeing the players play the best
move one after the other with Bobby
predicting perhaps a 90 accuracy there
this was a phenomenal game one and start
to the playoffs the players are back in
the rest area they will be back in the
Gladiators Arena for game two and we
will be back after this break with all
the action from Astana
[Music]
hi everybody International Master Danny
wrench here chess.com's Chief chess
officer we are here and excited to be
collaborating and partnering with World
Quant as an official partner of the
champions tour in the year 2023 I'm now
speaking with Chief strategy officer for
World Quant natish money the people have
met us and now time for the big
questions jumping right into the basics
tell everybody a little more about world
Quant and what exactly is it that world
quad does thank you for having me Danny
and you already introduced me I'm the
chief strategy officer at World Quant
World Quant is a global asset management
organization it was founded by
igorithulchinski in 2007. World quad
today has over 850 employees who are
working towards designing investment
strategies in multiple asset class
across Global markets World Quant
believes in empowering the ideas of the
talent across the globe and we have 23
offices in 13 countries today amazing
amazing stuff so tell us now a little
bit more about this project called World
Quant brain so worldcoin is built on the
belief that Talent is global but
opportunity is not and we strive to take
this opportunity to everyone around the
globe world Quant brain has been
designed as a tool which empowers us to
take that opportunity to anyone that's
fantastic seriously that's amazing I I
had no idea about that learning about
this along with our viewers and
obviously as a as a website in a company
with a mission to also connect Global
communities and increase the opportunity
for chess that makes it even more of a
natural partnership tell me a little bit
more from World quads perspective why
you guys run the ITC so World Quant has
this mission of democratizing
quantitative finance and international
Quant Championship is one of the tools
we have to spread the message about this
operator opportunity which World point
is offering to everyone to be a Quant in
the world of in the quantitative space
and international Quant Championship
empowers the individuals to utilize
their ideas and show that they can do it
and gives us an opportunity to take this
message to them wherever they are that's
great now you said the finals will be in
person was I write that it'll be in the
Bahamas that sounds like a pretty great
location can I come yeah absolutely
absolutely and I can okay so I don't
know that I'm qualified to be in the iqc
but uh tell everybody a little more so
the finals are going to be in the
Bahamas what will that be like for those
who make it yes so the finals as you
said is planned to be in Bahamas for the
iqc so worldcoin celebrated its 15th
anniversary last year in 2022 to
celebrate that occasion we are getting
the whole world Quant organization
together in Bahamas this year and we
decided that we will organize the finals
of iqc at that event so this will give
an opportunity to our finalists to meet
the world Quant team in person it will
give them an opportunity to watch the
culture and rigor of the organization
and we are very excited that everybody
will be able to get together at that
event in Bahamas well this has been
awesome nitish thank you so much this is
where I remind everybody it's their
chance to get involved in the iqc the
international quad Championship you can
use the command iqc you can visit the
world Quant brain website we encourage
you to do so ASAP registration is open
until May so it's time to jump in and
maybe you'll get to meet the CSO and
others in the Bahamas maybe I'll be
there I don't if I'm lucky I don't know
but it sounds like a great time either
way and the Tish uh the Chess World and
the Champions chess tour thanks World
Quant for their partnership and we're
looking forward to the rest of the year
together thank you Danny and good luck
to the community for participating in
iqc
thank you
World Quant is an official partner of
the chesscom broadcast of the fide World
Championship they are a global firm that
builds complex mathematical models to
identify market inefficiencies now World
fund brain is bringing together its
International Quan championship and the
chess Community to hunt down the next
generation of Quant Finance Specialists
because nobody knows how to analyze a
position better than a chess player
right if you think you have what it
takes register for the international
Quan Championship head to go.chess.com
iqc or use command iqc in chat for all
the details
we are out of a mind-boggling game one
and this one is going down in history
books as an absolute Masterpiece for the
ages we saw an incredible attack a
counter-attack with both players really
having to play accurately with just
minutes and seconds on the clock that
was some fantastic just that we
witnessed in game one Bobby what do you
reckon how are the players feeling after
this phenomenal game one
I think overall ding missed a little bit
more than Jan did there Jan I think can
be very happy that after a Danger's
opening he made a draw he might feel
like he had some chances there because
they were at some point we saw he was
very close thing had to make only moves
but objectively speaking ding found old
moves and uh and the draw was a pretty
natural result but for yawn yeah draw
with the black pieces in the first game
uh avoiding some danger and now he has a
white pieces and he'll be looking to
press definitely a good start
a great start for all of us here loved
every moment of that game Robert we see
ding has arrived he is meticulously
adjusting his pieces on the board now
Jan we've seen him play the one E4 the
king spawn opening to The Classical
games we're expecting him to stick with
that for the rapid
yeah I think there's no reason for them
to change their repertoire their
mindsets uh they played a very
interesting classical 14 games and here
in the rapid that game won I don't think
that means anyone needs to change
anything that was a hard-fought accurate
game great play from these two it's an
exciting start for the fans probably a
bit of a nerve-wracking one for the
players but it wasn't too scary neither
player was under too much danger even if
it was a little bit worse for Yan uh out
of the opening
yeah I think that
that for sure it's
it was a position which was dangerous
for ding at some point
uh and dangerous for young but never to
the point where they thought I'm going
to lose this game or anything so uh I
don't think that they were super super
scared or nervous at any point during
that game although Jan probably realized
when he's played Rook H5 that he is
bluffing a little bit with this it's uh
the good thing with that bluff is that
it was a bluff with a very very clear
concrete idea and it worked out to
perfection
amazing resourcefulness there in that
last game and we've seen just a few
moments the game two will be in
and then leaving his chair for just a
second so maybe we might have a couple
of uh minutes that might be delayed well
and he comes right back smiling it's
good to see a happy ding
always you know and ding has been so
great during the press conferences
leaving his heart out for the world to
see and to enjoy and we see the
handshakes and get involved I know that
in chat the polls were up and who you
think is going to win but look at this
view Jana palmchi playing the Spanish
Berlin
this was to be expected I think that Jan
would continue with his E4 and we're
going to see some anti-martial I think
it makes sense for Yan
I think he's going to play this a39 C3
line again
because that's that's the line he knows
best I think he's a real expert in this
line oh he goes for A4 instead okay so
A4 is an invitation to Bishop D7 or B4
but Bishop D7 is considered
let's say the
H3 is very unusual
H3 okay so this is going to be a
surprise for ding or maybe not Castle
short quickly
surprising not him not one bit he's
playing this instantly and so is Yan so
oh Bishop E3 we saw that idea played an
earlier game when the pawn was on C3 but
still that Bishop develops out in the
evil bar it's not overly impressed just
saying all right both sides you're equal
here so Tanya they're both blitzing it
out what do you make of this opening
is again relatively a fresh position
after Bishop E3 hasn't been explored
that much with some of the top players
have in fact had this position including
a certain Thomas chavesky so there's
definitely something to that we know
that tamashavisky is perhaps potentially
part of Jana pamishi's theme so there
could be a lot of discussion there could
be his idea now in that game after
Bishop E3 was played Black did reply
with Knight to A5 and then the usual
stuff with the c Pawn advancing so we
see ding slowing down a little bit but
these are ideas that he's definitely
familiar with it is a thematic way to
carry on in this position are we
expecting him to go for this plan with
gaining space on the queen side
the funny thing is I I feel like I had a
very very similar position long time ago
with the black pieces against got
akowski I think instead of H3 he was
playing this who Bishop to E3 which is
it's so similar and thing goes for
Knight A5 White's plan was to play
Knight C3 at some moment
whoa and now he captures upon him okay
so we're gonna
so this is kind of typical way to
capture but I can play Knight C3 and try
to slowly get that pawn
or excuse
it's available but it does give the D5
Square I guess that's Jan's major point
he wants this access to the D5 square
that would be a strategic Victory if
black plays C5 pawns two squares apart
leave the square in between vulnerable
to the opponent and then his Knight
would gladly hop in maybe the bishop
would go back to G5 to take this Knight
but
Bobby isn't there some pressure down the
B file won't that be annoying for white
to deal with yeah I see no issue with C5
I'm sure it's a fine move for black I
had a very very similar position with
the white pieces against uh Daniel dubov
and basically he took the pawn day four
at some point we had this where I could
have gained a lot of light squares but
the light squares are not the only
Factor as you mentioned the b-pawn is a
weakness and I like C5 much more than
Knight to C6 because after Knight C6 the
Knight is really in the way of stuff and
white can continue with let's say Bishop
to C4 followed by uh okay well it turns
A4 and also you can continue to put
pressure on that pawn one Knight's a C3
and uh Knight to B7 a key at least it
keeps contact with the a the bishop on
D7 no longer is blocked from the A4 Pawn
Knight C6 he plays maybe I mean it might
be a fine move but it looks unusual to
me too because after Bishop C4 you
you're threatened to lose that part
immediately so how do you respond to
that
no I mean this night I see
through and Tanya you were the one
calling the shots in one of our earlier
games in this match with that Rook B8
there was pressure on the B file but do
you think that Bishop C4 and the a one
Rook is opening too fast for black to
make pressure down the B file work
oh that's a lot of pressure to predict
what is a white idea here but it's clear
what you're saying black will after
doubling up on the a file make the most
of this B file for The Rook we can
quickly expect him to start targeting we
think to start targeting the B2 point
and I was just while you guys were
discussing these opening subtleties I
also want to just point out that that
came by Thomas was against a certain
Eric Hansen played online in a speed
chess game now in that game the move
order was different it did not arrive
exactly the way we saw this one with the
same position with the change up the
switch up from what Eric did was in fact
when they decided to take the pawn on A4
the move of choice in that game was the
move before so keeping a more closed
position on the queen side and
eventually we saw the game develop with
the c Pawn advance but none of this
happened in this one thing Lauren again
choosing the most direct way to play he
does capture on A4 Knight C3 on the
board uh by Jana vomiti so he wants to
get to the iPhone A4 Pawn with his
Knight also defending the B2 pawn and
nothing has to be a little careful
because there is a weakness on A6 and
that's a lifelong weakness for this game
you didn't like this move uh Knight C6
but are you still feeling the same way
that was going to be my question for you
I still don't like the move very much
because I thought C5 was a more natural
way of playing it and more combative
more difficult for white to to round up
the A4 water I mean here here black can
consider A3
the point is probably why it is
obligated to take because you don't want
to play B3 I mean you don't want to
block your Bishop
uh yeah this would be maybe not bad for
white but very very silly to do so B
takes A3 and now we have a symmetrical
structure so at least black is not
dealing with the issues tiny that you
mentioned of the isolated a pawn being a
weakness
what
white has 95 ideas and the Knight on C6
black spent a lot of time playing Knight
bhc685 C6 so that was a waste of time
and I still feel like white is the one
with pressure here although
it has to be said that in all these
positions you have pressure but it's
usually
very very manageable because black
remains so solid I mean the Marshall is
one of the most solid openings even if
it goes a little wrong usually
usually it remains pretty
relatively decent for black we saw that
in in the previous match he on against
Magnus I mean Jan was very often getting
a bit of an advantage from the opening
but usually was neutralized after some
accurate play because just you know
Black's position is quite healthy and
it's you know in its essence
yeah the shell is there for black I mean
it's a solid foundation uh there are no
targets immediately exploitable but this
bishop on A2 clearly better than the
bishop on D7 this bishop on D2 clearly
been the bishop on E7 so that's what I
would highlight for people wondering why
would white be better here it's going to
be even material especially if black
jettison's just Pawn right back and the
then the pawn structure becomes
symmetrical uh the black bishops are
worse than their white counterparts and
that is the problem is that Ding is just
a bit passive now that doesn't mean he's
going to lose the game that doesn't mean
that he might even face pressure but
just is something that's a bit
uncomfortable in the starting position
so Tanya one of the ideas that I was
thinking is can I move this Knight again
I know I've already moved it B8 to C6 to
A5 to C6 but can I move it up to D4 this
time I'm wondering if I can try to be
greedy and keep this Pawn A4 I like it
and that's where we saw ding do in game
one as well right he just snapped up the
C5 pawn and then held on to it with
their life for as long as possible so A3
a really nice way to take care of the
Strategic points that you're mentioning
but because of these Dynamic factors
like the strong bishop and A2 they can
very well try to hold on to that A4 Pawn
uh for a while at least the Moon Knight
D4 comes to mind and if white was to
trade on D4 yes you do kind of leave
your king side a bit weak why it's got
these long-term plans of f4 and maybe a
potential pawn star 92 will hit the D4
Pawn you'd have to make the move C5 and
it's not a great extra Pawn but look at
that B file black can also have trumps
in the position black can start to
create counter play down the B file
while white will aim for a king Side
Pawn Star taking advantage of that
Bishop on A2 Knight D4 especially after
ding's last move Knight to C6 I won't be
surprised to see that on the board
Bobby your turn do you think Knight D4
is available to Black and what would
white do in response do we think that he
would immediately take and play for the
king side pressure like Tanya said or is
there something to worry about on the
queen side I think I would probably
choose id4 because other moves are a
little bit passive and with 94 you're
giving your opponent a difficult
I mean you're giving him some difficult
problems as well so to me it looks most
natural the line that you guys suggested
would take in Knight to E2 C5 and for
example move like Knight to G3 black
plays work to B8 and white deals with
the threats of that pawn with some move
and then it's not like I want to keep
the Rook on the a file though because
after Bishop E6 I want to be able to
take on A4 in the end
and he just made a move and it was Rook
B8 first so yeah that looked at least
active for black he decides to try to
get immediate activity but he does give
back this Pawn on A4 so Knight takes A4
let's it'll be played because it's only
logical move
there's no other I mean why would you
not take a pawn which also defends to be
two Pawn so here's his idea Knight to D4
here I would I would guess it's still
Knight D4 with the idea that uh if you
take on before the Knight on A4 becomes
a little bit out of the game
uh but I can play Bishop C4 here and
be honest the structure is just better
for white that's that's the main thing
and if you're ever worried that your
knight is out of the game you can play
B3 and get it back at some point
so not sure I'm really liking this in
The Rook to B8
but he definitely has some idea in mind
after Knight takes A4
and Tanya Rook B8 it's a move that
dingley rent played in a different game
it got him in trouble I believe that was
back in game nine and so we see the Rook
on B8 once again was that game nine I'm
trying to remember
wasn't that it was a drop but Jan was
better I feel like it was a game game 11
be right before that craziness that we
saw the next time
I could be very wrong
we're struggling to remember all these
games uh seem to blend together but Rook
B8 that was an inaccuracy by doing in
another game and here he goes Rook be it
again this time for the open file in the
other game it was just to protect the
pawn but you know this position I feel
like uh with dingley run on the clock
Young's not even in his chair right now
uh sorry it's Jan's turn but he's not in
his chair but ding is concentrated
I can guarantee you Jan might not be in
his chat but he's definitely in the
resting area looking at this position
and thinking about his next move because
you don't have that kind of time to
waste in the rapid uh games but this
idea of Rook B8 that you're pointing out
and we see Yan arrive I wonder if he's
going to just Blitz out his move right
now as you said 94 makes so much sense
it combines the ideas that we were
talking about right the B file activity
on the B file for black and that jump
with a knight to C6 from C6 to the D4
Square trying to control the center you
don't care about doubling up your pawns
there Yan with his expression slightly
surprised as well with what ding has
chosen Rook p8 he's wondering
why would he do that just jump for the
Knight to D4 already but that's the move
of choice here expecting Jan to go
Knight A4 and in that final position we
saw it's still a lot to play for blacks
Bishop could perhaps come to B5 well
we'll see what is what is Jana pamishi's
decision what is the idea behind Rook V8
they say mistakes come in pairs I guess
inaccuracies often come in pairs as well
Knight takes A4 is Plato Fabi I mean you
have played the Spanish from both colors
your whole life this does look like a
pretty dream situation for white but
something you said earlier that
resonates with me that even when white
has these advantages uh it's like these
small things that you can work on for a
long period of Time Versus some kind of
a media Checkmate so how big of an
advantage do you think white has here
because the eval bar does say about half
upon better for white like if you're
playing what do you think practically
speaking the advantages
I would be actually unless I saw some
problem I would be relatively confident
in my ability to win this position with
white
um maybe it's because that this is like
kind of what I'm pretty good at which is
these types of positions
with the white pieces that is with the
black pieces I don't think I'm very good
at them but with the white pieces on I
I'm usually like
uh my confidence because it might not be
much on the bar but white Smooths are
easier it's you want to play Bishop C4
you want to play B3 you want to get you
just Target the eight Pawn I think Tanya
you mentioned uh this Apon has a really
important factor in the position and if
the pawn was on the B file black is
completely fine just equal uh with the
pawn the a file
it's an open file that stares down on
that pawn it also allows the C4 Square
as an outpost maybe not forever in
Outpost because if I got c65 you would
get control over that square but c65 is
not happening anytime soon so I look at
that square as a bit of an outpost and
then the question is oh like what's
blacks
follow up here and I also don't really
understand why you play Rook V8 and then
after Knight takes A4 he starts to think
about the position because uh obviously
one of the move was there besides Knight
takes A4
and I think okay Knight D4 is critical I
mean what you can play Knight B4 but
after night before I play uh Play Bishop
B3 or Bishop C4 both moves
seem but Bishop C4 I'm a bit worried
that maybe
some moment D5
even though I'm not seeing exactly where
D5 comes but I'm seeing like Bishop C4
C6 some some sort of counter play
which is he needs counter play at this
moment so Knight B4 Bishop to B3
the problem is you can't get default
yeah
we're taking Bishop C4 will probably be
played right and Bobby this reminds me
of that game that Robert brought up
Ash with Rook B8 and then went into a
long think on every move after that we
see Jana abomishi in this game two of
the rapid has already broken away on the
clock he is up by almost six minutes 23
minutes to yarn about 17 minutes there
to dingler in so can Yan keep up
building the pressure on the clock he's
got a very pleasant position out of the
opening the line that you wanted to
check out Fabi we're expecting a trade
on D4 because the Knight on A4 is
hanging right now so after Knight D4
black will pick up that Knight and then
you move the bishop to C4 that's the
idea start targeting the weakness on A6
and I'm just wondering does that give
dingler and the opportunity to not only
defend the pawn on A6 but offer a bishop
trade to move Bishop B5 I really want to
get rid of this very strong monstrous
light squared Bishop that white has
you just play B3 and you just work
around it and leave this Pawn on A6 and
we have seen the move Bishop C4 played
before the exchange of night so he
doesn't uh double blacks Pawns in the
center he said you could take me on F3
that just gets my queen out into the
game over here so Bishop B5 is still an
idea uh but this Knight now we'll be
able to go back to C3 so he says you can
keep your uh Pawn structure undamaged
but my knight gets more activity this
way
yeah important little tactical Point
here Antonia I think your your idea
Bishop B5 is actually really important
for black to even play at this moment uh
but an important point is if black takes
on F3 takes on a four and takes on B2
it might look like black is winning the
pawn with another one attacked but after
Bishop to B3 unfortunately for him his
work gets trapped it's a very typical uh
refutation of these sorts of on grabs
that we sometimes see and hear Bishop C3
next move wins The Rook so I think we'll
see Bishop B5 I like that idea a lot and
I think that's also why Jan didn't
rushwood Knight takes D4
uh because now white can consider him
not taking on D4 and consider
perhaps B3 is a bit better and I think
now Bishop C4 bc4 the reason why it
might be better is because that Knight
on A4 has a path to
uh to a much better square right with
with black spot on D4 that and I would
be restricted it could eventually escape
to B2 but even on B2 it remains a bad
piece and then so y would have to take a
lot of time or play C3 and C3 has its
own downsides but here if I play Knight
C3 I just Target that a pawn
not Bishop B5 we just felt so natural
but he puts the pawn on C6 he's offering
the A6 spawn and I am trying to
understand are there some tactics if
white gets greedy here or is black just
looking for a central break with D5 he's
playing for D5 he heard Fabiano caruanna
speak saying I desperately want some
counter play I don't want to sit
passively and have to defend my weak A6
Pawn have it take this pawn and he will
throw in D5 not immediately because
there are some pawns that are hanging in
the position but if we just analyze this
for a second here that this is a hanging
pawn it can successfully be captured but
I think you can play Rook A8 do not
bring your Bishop into B7 it will not
get out of there you'll lose your piece
so you drop back D5 hits you a la Tempo
and if you start taking on D5 oh watch
out everywhere you've given black the
center and I like the way that Ding is
playing dynamically I think that this is
the way that often top Grandmasters
survive games when they're under
pressure they say you know what I'm not
going going to be under pressure and
you're just going to play freely I am
going to cause problems that you will
have to deal with as well so have that
extra Pawn that's not the main storyline
of this game I am going to control the
center
I see a very interesting idea for what I
don't want to take that pawn and I want
to deal with the Toyota D5 so I want to
take on D4 ed4 and Bishop to F4
and now D5 will lose the rook and let's
say The Rook moves somewhere although
I'm not even sure where it could move to
which is a safe Square
but just to illustrate the idea after
Rook to a
um which renews the thread D5 I want to
play E5 here
and the points of D takes E5 Bishop B5
now c4 is a real Outpost now the bishop
is on that diagonal forever
uh you cannot kick it away with D5 you
can't restrict it with D5 and the
positional Advantage here I think is
borderline overwhelming like this is
already I think territory where we're
talking about Beyond just winning this
game and probably maybe even without big
difficulty
um because it's
the valuation might be similar to the
previous game where black was playing
Rook H5 maybe it was something similar
to that but there's a big difference
between a better position which is based
on some very concrete details and a
better position which is just based on
you playing natural moves and here white
just plays natural moves it's one of
those positions that plays itself you
it might at some point become difficult
to convert this but uh that might
already be when it's like you know
objectively winning position this this I
think that most top players win with the
white pieces so taking Bishop 4 I really
like that for white I really don't see
how black responds to the threat of E5
and it's it could become very difficult
for black maybe Rook to B4 I think
I'm serious like I like that no no it's
funny but I like the move after B3 how
are you dealing with because B3 renews
the threat I'm
I was thinking about it but I was being
instructive first of all that this
Knight is trapped so you can't take the
Rook
Rook giving away material but I was
going to say will we get another Rook H5
like should I mean this is not a matter
of I you know if it's bad or not it's a
matter of okay
uh my position got bad
so now we're threatening D5 we're
threatening I don't know if we're
threatening G5 but
Chief G5 G4 I mean I'm looking at it at
least at least it's counter play
um a D5 if you get D5 and you have
chances I I mean
might still be bad but the bishop at
least would be relegated to somewhere
lousy like A6 squares obviously a lousy
Square even if it doesn't get trapped
there so
Rook to B5 but I was also thinking Rook
to B4 is that a move afterwards you
might be seeing this play out I just
want to let you guys know that Knight D4
is on the board so the action that
you're looking at might happen if Jana
Palmerston does make the move Bishop F4
once the knights recaptured
Rook B5 Robert I sometimes feel like
we're commentating with Patrician and
not Robert Hess with all your exchange
sacrifices so I've always loved the
exchange sacrifice always and Bishop F4
is played so is that Janda Palms she's
seen there or is it Fabiano caruana who
knows because they're playing the same
ideas but I love a good exchange
sacrifice you'll hear me do that even
when it's bad I'll suggest it because
you have to look out for it I think
sometimes we're a bit too materialistic
we think oh that Rook I've been told is
worth Five Points a bishop at night is
worth a little over three let's say and
that I shouldn't give it my Rook what's
up sorry to sorry to interrupt but I I
love your Rook V5 idea and I love it
even more because I saw the response to
B3 okay B3 we insist we played D5
okay we'll show this Rook B5 B3 D5
and if you take the Rook
first yeah but then Knight takes D5 now
you can't take the Rook that was that
was the idea oh and now now you might
because now the bishop on C4 is no
longer like it's restricted now if you
give it up then you gave up an important
part of your position uh-huh but maybe
yeah Bishop takes B5 is critical so I
was excited momentarily because ab5
Knight B2 I thought that we would win
the E4 Pawn uh now I see it's not so
easy
and I take C4 Queen D4 it's just now
that's sad I I was getting excited for a
moment but it doesn't seem to be working
out
all I'm hearing is is that you ruined my
exchange sacrifice that's that's what's
going in this year wait let's let's get
to okay might do Bishop B4 I know that
you know I I messed up
but I'm still I'm still saying the
Knight on B2 is a bad piece so I think
what you're really saying in addition to
that is that for a rapid game of chess
it is very difficult to play with bad
pieces and look at the activity that
black suddenly has it's Bishop on B4 can
come to C3 there's no rookie one that's
gonna be an open file and I want to put
up my Rook on E8 so white is up material
but black does have some of the benefits
in this position I actually could see
not this specific line I really doubt
it's going to happen but I could see
something like this occurring and then
ding saying I don't want to sit
passively I don't want to defend and
he's going to throw caution to the wind
and play in exchange like sacrifice with
Rook to I love Rook B5 I'm hoping we see
it and even if we get Rook H5 come on
ding you're too strong
do you put that Rook on B5 and try
and spy but it wasn't
does offer
and I'm just trying to understand this
move a little bit because now white does
have the option to actually pick up that
pawn on A6 Bishop takes A6 and if black
was to swing with the Rook to eight you
can fall back with the bishop to C4
create on C4 and the D4 Pawn is hanging
it looks like the kind of moment where
in fact yeah she can
be up an extra pawn bishop E6 where is
the compensation for this A6 Pawn now
you don't have D5 ideas again that Rook
on B8 on the fire with that Bishop on F4
I'm I'm shocked if he takes that pawn it
might be the best move I'm just shocked
if he does it
because
uh I mean it feels like the bishop is
just bad there and if forced to retreat
while black will somehow pick up the E4
pawn and maybe it's not the case but
intuitively I I would I wasn't even
looking at that move I mean I know that
it's like it's a free pawn and
everything but I really was not looking
at that option
as even like a legal move uh but that's
probably just because I
um Bobby that hurt you make me feel like
such a bad player right yeah I was going
to really hard because I feel like that
no I was gonna say that it's actually a
good move so this is like uh this is a
case where I should be considering the
move and and I'm actually sure that
you're correct at visual Basics is the
critical move but something in me just
doesn't want to play it I think it's a
stylistic choice right some people want
extra pawns which is fine other people
want the positional uh triumphs in the
position right if you take take I'm
guessing father you still want your E5
idea is that what you're going for yeah
yeah I do and he he is with Fabi super
Grand Master chess doesn't consider
Bishop A6 plays the move rookie one you
were saying it's a stylistic choice
Robert maybe it's a strength Choice
Bishop A6 this intuitively feels like a
move that you don't want to make with
that Bishop on A6 and having to double
up the Pawns in case there's a trade a
future trade on C4 and first Yan decides
to just defend the E4 Pawn but this does
allow the trade anyway this does allow
black to destroy White's Central Pawn
structure
I think he just doesn't care because
he's looking at that pawn in the long
term so he's looking at something like
Bishop C4 DC4 C5
uh yeah you kept all your pawns but I
played B3 the Knight on D3 uh yeah I
think we're already talking about maybe
black why is winning this position
because let's say you play some move um
I don't know Robert uh what what kind of
move here would you make I I don't just
see I don't see it anyway Knight B2 D3
is coming and then A6
uh whether you keep it or not is a
long-term weakness and also white can
play E5 at the right moment and uh the
Knight on D3 is an outpost C5 is weak
long term I think wide wins this wins
this position very uh very often so
I don't think ding will want to take on
C4
no I agree but if you don't take on C4
uh you can't play D5 very easily this
Rook still is hanging on B8 this Rook B5
idea I mean you know it's still there he
plays A4 I think that is a smart play at
this point he does not want to worry
about the A6 Pawn forever because it
wasn't just about being in The Bishop's
site that once this Knight like B3
Knight B2 now at least the queen defends
this Pawn A5 so you have given it some
defense that's a good thing and at some
point D5 may be in the equation I know
this Rook is hanging over here uh but
this Rook is likely to move and then you
have to look out for D5 or we could see
take take an E5 at the right moment but
black will get play of his own that's
the good news for ding if the f file
opens up there will be some activity for
Ding and he's not just going to have to
sit and wonder what am I doing here
what about a preparatory move so you're
not afraid of Bishops before at the
moment D5 is for the moment not a threat
uh because of Bishop takes B8 so maybe
bishop to H2 and my point is I want to
take only six and E5 but I don't want
the bishop to be uh potentially attacked
with Knight to D5 so I play Bishop H2
and uh my idea is to take an E5 can I
just tell you how much of a super grand
mass you are let's ask the chat be
honest with us how many of you were
thinking about this calm retreating move
Bishop H2 and I want your full honesty
because all of you found it of course
but Fabi finds this great idea saying
that let's say I make a waiting with
like H6 then I take an HX maybe
particularly a Troublesome and I play E5
I'm trying to crack open the position
and I didn't want my Bishop in that Rook
sight so if you take I could take with
the rook and hit E6 and put more
pressure on A5 I could take with the
bishop to attack D4 and attack the B8
Rook but I'm not giving black that much
needed activity I'm not giving a sort of
tempo shot so yeah great idea by Fabi
and by Olive chat I know you sub Bishop
H2 as well
isn't it kind of amazing in that final
position that you were showing that
black wasn't doing too terribly maybe
it's a lot about peace activity and
Black's pieces are getting active in
those positions the structure is a mess
I mean you don't have to
um
you don't have to be on the promise you
to see
that black structure is is pretty lousy
but maybe the peace activity is
he plays Queen to F3 I was gonna say
maybe the peace activity is compensating
for the structural problems in that
position
so Queen F3 also makes sense he's
preparing E5 in some cases
I like this approach Maybe
he also wants to say that Knight D7
could be by Queen to G3 but then Bishop
H4 so what's wrong with Knight D7 here
I want to make that move because I want
to potentially use the E5 Square for
example Bishop c495 ideas things like
that not sure if that's really what
black wants but id7 feels like a
harmonious move here so how are you
responding to that move
uh well E5 is no longer available and it
looks like ding you know he's on the
clock here but this looks like a very
good try because E5 doesn't have the
same Force to it and you see the
evaluation bar drops here D5 is
disastrous your Bishop gets in trouble
exactly so Rook B7 plate instead that's
a very ding move and I mean that in a
complimentary way Tanya Fabi plays
Bishop H2 I would never have thought
about that Rook B7 also wasn't thinking
in that direction but he is threatening
D5 and he's taking advantage of the fact
that the queen stepped in the line of
this Rook
Rook B7 another one of those
prophylactic moves similar to the
concepts of just moving the back from
age to right just clear up and make sure
that your pieces are safe and ding is
returning the favor with keeping his own
pieces safe he wants to get D5 in The
Rook on B it was a Target he moves one
square up and says D5 is in the air but
will he have enough time because with
that Queen on F3 I also see a thunder
spot on C6 and maybe this could be the
moment for yarn I promise you to
actually strike in the center the move
that we've been looking at in different
lines with different ideas E5 is the
first move that I think we should Deep
dive into you hit not only the Knight
not only the pawn on D6 with a potential
picking up of an extra Pawn on C6 and as
we dive into that I just want to give
YouTube Chad a quick shout out because
you were honest most of you said you did
not see Bishop H2 that Fabiano was
pointing out in the previous variation
so thank you for your honesty we
appreciate it and hope you're enjoying
the show but back to your regularly
scheduled programming Fabi so we're
talking about E5 here is now the time
yeah I like this move Tanya and he plays
it Everyone likes this move it's uh it
just looks good and I think Knight T5 is
the response for black I think you
should play Knight D5 here
because the Knight on D5 is an excellent
piece it's compensating for a lot of
Black's potential problems by result
restricting the bishop on C4 attacking
the bishop on F4 and also maybe Knight
to B4 someday
and White's only issue is the Knight on
A4 is a misplaced piece
if the Knight was anywhere else
basically white just is dominating this
position
even even here maybe the structural
problems aren't too big to ignore after
let's say take everything on D6
and yeah we see that black structure is
damaged because the A5 Pawn is not on
the B file and
for sure White's better here but the
question is how much better
I think in an end game this could be
really unpleasant but as long as white
can't get Knight C5 in maybe I'm going
to show what you're saying just because
I think it's very instructive for
everyone to understand why an end game
you get access to the C5 square but we
do have a move and the move was Knight
D5 so this is relevant stuff what we
were just looking at that if we see
these trades well Bobby was saying white
wants to trade Queens get that Queen D5
black will not want to trade Queen so
that line that we're just looking at
just one more time that in the event of
a queen trade white takes the upper hand
Knight C5 is very very dangerous A5 is a
weakness and white just is in control
the Knight can't really move The
Bishop's here the Knight can't move it
also because the Pawn's under attack
white has all the fun so okay Knight D5
if we get all these trades Tanya do we
think that Jan or ding will feel more
comfortable we know that Jan has the
advantage both players are aware of that
but whose style does that resulting
position a better suit
and that's the big question right
because he does have the option to go
for these trades and get this simplified
position or once again Jan could just
keep the tension with falling back with
the bishop and it will be a very
difficult position in the center for
both these players to play out and the
clock has got something to say on that
as well because Jan currently is up two
minutes he does return on the board and
Robert you hit the nail on the head that
it is stylistic and Yan does go for the
option of actually trading I was
thinking he would end up keeping the
tension but we saw him do that with the
queen trade in the last game and now we
see him repeat that he's going for these
more simplified positions in the rapid
yeah but Fabi you've said this before
that instead of simplifying sometimes
you actually give yourself the best
chances even if objectively you've made
the best move by simplifying sometimes
by a practical perspective that if you
keep more peace on the board you keep
the tension when your opponent's moves
are more difficult to find now the next
few moves for ding they actually do feel
easier because his pieces can breathe
yeah well I think that this bishop G3
was probably an excellent option but it
might have been based on some
calculations after Knight to B4 because
black had that counter play with the
threat and Knight takes C2 and it's
understandable I think that Jan didn't
want to go there I mean I was trying to
like consider that position a bit
uh but uh since we've had so much happen
on the board
so the question is okay you play Queen
E4
and can black play Knight to B4 or is
that too much you allow the destruction
of your constructure but you get some
counter play in return
it's possible although I would be very
hesitant to make that move
and it's also like to have sex here but
let's look at this because Knight before
is the first one that came to my mind as
well and the point that fabi's making is
you are sacrificing upon her so it seems
on E6 you take back and let's maybe
trade take the queen just to force them
out but the end game is terrible after
rookie too
say that but I was gonna say instead of
taking a pawn that looks like it's
hanging you stop you defend your hanging
pawn and this Knight comes to C5 and
every Pawn in Black's position is very
weak so yes Bobby I I learn from you all
the time that's why I was able to stop
on E2 I wasn't impulsive
yeah I mean rookie two rookie two is an
excellent move and
we see what Black's Pawn structure there
you need to keep the Queens on
for example after rookie 2 now Rook to
F4 might come and we see that White's
Queen becomes a little bit of a
liability Queen takes C6 Queen E6 Rook
E6 and now yeah I'd rather have work on
a fade in this position but at least I'm
grabbing the C2 Pawn coming back to B4
attacking D3
it's still a tough fight white side can
at some point go to C5 which is a very
nice place for that night too but black
is getting counter player so
the thing is thinking about two moves
after Queen E4
one is the night before that we
looked at a little bit
one is Knight to F6
uh but Knight F6 I think he'll probably
reject it because after Queen E5 we
enter some end games that are not
looking super fun or black
yeah so probably I mean there's also
Knight to F4 here but I don't know if
Knight's F4
does anything in particular
and I think what you're getting at is
that he plays next on the board you
saved the best for Less you should move
here but Tanya as we look at this in
fabi's point that it's someone with
Queen E5 is offering the queen trade it
looks like Jana palmchi will be playing
for two results
and that's the thing right with this
move Knight F4 and I think Fabi the
point you were also perhaps going to
make was that after Queen E5 it just
forces black to trade on E5 your Queens
are attacked you can't really sidestep
the trade because the Knight on F4 will
be hanging and you enter this end game
where you don't have the most ideal Pawn
structure if after Queen E5 we can
imagine visualize the queen trade The
Rook lands on E5 you're immediately
hitting on that pawn on A5 E6 could be a
weakness and if white was to trade
Bishop C4 D take C4 the D4 Pawn could be
hanging in many cases so Yan has got a
very pleasant Choice here simply to
offer the trade in the center and I'm
just wondering the kind of Chess that
we've seen by Yan today right in game
one he did go for Rook D2 trading off
the Queens going into that end game we
saw that end into a draw he could have
kept the tension on the port today as
well well he not to David's second game
as well he does pick up on D6 goes for
these trades and we might be seeing
another end game Bobby what are the
chances of yan having a very clear
strategy that if the opportunity
presents itself he's happy to go into
Blitz
I think that he he doesn't mind it for
sure
but he also
um of course will try to take his
chances
and I think that he went for this line
only because he saw something that he
likes after the move D3 which is for
sure Black's idea in this position
is to play D3 I think probably right now
and I was kind of calculating this D3 G3
stuff I'm not sure what's going on
exactly
uh G3 gives black a lot of options but
maybe not a lot of good options
because let's say D3 G3 where are you
showing that night I have to show this
because this you know it's one of these
moves G3 you're attacking the Knight but
giving up a past pawn and if you go 92
check your whole point is that the king
F1 well unfortunately the d-pawn how is
this I thought this was going to be a
bad decision but King G2 maybe because
you you can't take anyway
right
and so the king's just like a little bit
safer on G2 but I think Knight G6 is
critical
you can kind of sack a piece but I'm not
sure if it and now Rook takes A5
so ec2 and Rook C1 that was the the idea
that you get it back pretty quickly but
black might actually get a lot of
activity
um
because at night if it gets active it
could get really really active like if
it could get to E5 then
maybe the activity would be
enough to draw but you're so not sure
that this is that you'll be able to do
this because night end games Pawn down
very often are much worse than just Rook
end games right the the presence of
knights are can make the defensive task
much more difficult or impossible and
I'm not seeing Black's good move here
like I see the bar is not saying it's a
disaster for black I just don't see why
it wouldn't be a disaster could it be F6
just to get that Knight in like you're
saying and just bring the Knight around
here yeah Rook c295 but I didn't really
believe in this
like let's say I play
Knight to C5 here I just don't see it
like the Knight on C5 is so powerful
yeah but the thing is black at some
point will be able to go after the pawn
and we did just see the capture so if we
go back to the live position d64 has
played it now that I said that go after
the pawn can blacks start with Rook
before because I want to induce B3 in
many other positions I did not but then
I'll play D3 and I'll crack your Pawn
structure
I think excellent excellent idea to
include Rook before to make V Pawn
weaker because on B2 it's defended on B3
and D3 it potentially won't be defended
anymore
so Rook D4 Rook before it also allows
I mean it allows a lot of stuff
a lot of stuff which is a bit better for
white but nothing which is like clearly
clearly better I mean even like Rook
before Rook takes A5
Rook takes C4 Rook C5 is a pleasant end
game but then you're feeling like you
probably hold that right so
also Rook before G3 why can
consider
but then you have to consider Knight
takes H3 too so I like Rook before I
think that this is a movie you should go
for D3 didn't look
like the best option
yeah go for Rook before
and Tanya I mean we're talking about all
these moves these variations with ding
now he's about seven minutes remaining
on the clock John is 12. that time
Advantage for yond that could play a big
role in an end game that remains tricky
he's been up on the clock throughout the
game right from the opening so it's been
a quite a bit of a success this game so
far for Yan and ding's the one who's
dealing with weaknesses he can't just
sit he can't just go on the passive
defense and expect to hold on this kind
of an end game he has to go for these
ideas of hitting on the C4 Pawn with a
move like before or an immediate move
like D3 I don't think it's possible to
just start defending the A5 Pawn with
passive moves like rookate and indeed
ding does provoke the move B3 because
once that happens D3 that blow that
you're talking about will be so much
more powerful because the B3 Pawn will
be weak Rook B4 on the board Rook C4
ideas and I'm just wondering can a white
throw in G3 here Bobby you mentioned
that H3 Pawn is weak but after Knight H3
King G2 I'm hitting the Knight not so
many squares is F6 Knight G5 the Escape
Route but that doesn't that create a lot
of weaknesses on the king side
yeah this was my idea but it's
white can start to capture some Queen
side pawns which might be more relevant
than the H Pawn
so it's it's a good question I mean G3
looks like a very critical move
and then black can decide where to put
the Knight it can go to E6 that's kind
of the most natural Square I think for
it to go to it can go to H3 but yeah
that comes with a lot of risks as you
said and G6 I don't like because that
root just works in C5 and I think white
gains control haven't stopped the D3
threat
and we'll slowly be able to make
progress oh Rook C5 played
these three immediately blitzed out
he knows he has this and that's the
thing about dingley Wren right now is if
the pawn takes it's all forcing now your
rook's under attack and if you take on
C6 I take on B2 we start trading pawns
we liquidate I mean black does need to
be a bit careful because this Rook on A1
is staring at this A5 Pawn just to
quickly show a forcing variation that
could happen if black goes for it that a
pawn takes Knight takes Rook C6 Knight
B2 Knight B2 Rook B2 Rook takes A5 you
see the advantage go up for white
because your Healthy Pawn ahead there is
no back rank Checkmate as the king as
the H2 Square so I don't think in the
event of CD Knight D Rook C6 that black
is going to take on B2 because there
isn't a rush here maybe you can make
left for your king perhaps 95. 95 is a
nice move wow didn't see the backward
Night Moves hardest to find a chest so
they say
and white will have a small edge here
but nothing dramatic I mean uh black is
pretty much just holding on here so
after D3 Yan has to find something else
that just leads to
what looks to me to be quite close to a
draw you can
you can play G3 because a knight to E6
comes and that's I can just take on C2
and your Knights hanging right oh that
as well that as well
but although I mean it6 is already
playing for an advantage so that's why
maybe maybe you can start to get a bit
ambitious there
but yeah definitely um I want to show a
crazy line I mean I don't know if it
works or not but check this out after G3
what if black actually dc2 great idea
but what if you actually start with Rook
K4 Rook A4 I push my Pawn to D2 and I
don't see a way for you to defend it
because you can fall back with your Rook
to A1 but I might have an idea to check
and Knight C1 stopping that and then I
queen with my knee Pawn that is
beautiful the Knight blocks the rook and
you get a queen all sorts of Tactics
still available in end games I think
sometimes uh people they you know think
all end games they're boring was that
manual they talk about it's like 7 000
Pages you should read DeVries endgame
manual if you're an improving player or
although many online courses that you
can do but still these end games still
have Rich tactics available and so even
fabi's 19 and then retreating your
knight that's a hard move to process
especially when you can take pawns I
know I just made that mistake I'm
willing to admit it in front of all of
you so there's a lot that's still
happening in this end game with many
pawns under attack but if you are you on
the palm machine I think Now's the Time
to just admit that the game should be a
draw don't do anything funny you know G3
is here none of that stuff just
liquidate make this draw it'd be one to
one you both get one more white game
remaining and that's okay for the
players but what great defense from
dingley run he's always playing these
accurate moves
I think Rook C5 was yeah it wasn't a
great decision by you on because D3
um I mean yeah it's it's a good move but
it's also kind of comes to mind as like
the only move so I
yeah he's going for it I don't know what
exactly um maybe he thought he can play
Rook C6 here and thought he's getting a
rook end game with the c Pawn with the
two Rooks which is quite nice to play in
Rapid and he missed the Knight E5 that's
possible but I think Rook C5 was
definitely a careless decision for me on
great news that's our level as well and
and that would explain a lot actually
because Robert as you pointed out Knight
backward moves are indeed the hardest
spot and that also from far away Rook C6
would look like a stable Advantage with
an extra Pawn at 95 that's not
completely neutralize the White's Edge
if Jan was to take on C6 yeah that
leaves him with no winning chances
whatsoever and other moves looked
interesting for black I mentioned just
creating Loft so there's no background
checkmates Rook to E8 just to activate
your Rook because it feels like White's
pawns aren't the healthiest they will be
under threat so 95 just says why am I
going to be down a pawn I don't have to
come up with compensation I will restore
material equality and the game will
result in a drawing you look at young
diplomacy he knows that this game is
about to Peter out great find by dingley
Wren he's been making these moves
quickly I think that this match deserves
to be level and it's super exciting
because if they draw it's not guaranteed
just yet we'll be at one to one only two
games remaining in the rapid portion of
this world championship match
yeah so far it's looking like a balance
we've been calling uh the whole game
Sorry go on no it's yeah you're
absolutely right that uh
that 95 is kind of securing the quality
and I'm sure y'all will be disappointed
with this because he really had a nice
opening
he works his 70s plane I think
we can play Knight C4 why not
we can also play Rook C4 but I think
Knight C4 is a bit more direct
yeah I don't think I would be playing
Rook C4 because this Rook is very active
and yeah Knight Knight takes before just
keeps this B2 Pawn threatened and we may
just see that move happen next and B2 is
lost but so is A5 and that's clearly a
draw
yeah once Knight takes B2 happens the
trade on B2 followed by Rook takes A5
this game will end
I mean Jan can invite that by playing
something like G3 or some neutral move
you can also play B3 Knight D2 and
Knight C5 to force it
starts tonight has Knight to C5 he
starts with Knight c5s they're still
keeping all the pieces on the board if
black was to pick up the B2 Pawn with
the Knight A5 hangs if you pick up the
B2 Pawn With The Rook I think you end up
losing that Knight on C4 with the knight
jump on D7 that would be a bad idea
oh oh there's a uh the the back rank is
for some reason I thought you know when
you said H6 I I like started visualizing
the position with the pawn H6
5 today you've blundered a back rank
Checkmate it's okay we'll work on those
later buddy we'll work on checkmates on
the back rank when you don't wait what
was it what was the first time when
there was Knight takes D4 and the queen
The Rook was hanging on E8
yeah in the first game with Queen A4 and
then Knight to D4 and you said Knight
takes D5 oh oh I forgot that moment
you're right see you've already
forgotten we need to work on this we
need to work on this but Avi needs his
puzzle Rush fix well Knight V2 ding is
finding all the tactics Knight D7 on the
board now no loose pieces drop off here
because there is no night on C4 but it's
always so important to keep every piece
defended and Knight D7 played The Rook
will move and then again the these ideas
if Rook goes to A8 you can actually pick
up a pawn regardless because of the back
rank threats and black will be unable to
recapture The Rook on A5 so despite
these active moves by Yan it does look a
little scary Fabi the Knight on D7 The
Rook on C7 but with such a few pawns
left you can white create anything on
the seventh rank
I think that's really unlikely then I
can come back from Lex I can come back
to D6 for example
and it will cover any sort of threats
and why would meet quite a few moves to
even create the threat to F7
so yeah he can play Knight to C4 here
pretty safely I'll try not to plunder
any more back rank that checkmates
you know you can always always deal with
that issue with playing H6 at some
moment but I like Knight C4 to to just
get the knife back as quickly as
possible because H6 I'm thinking maybe
Knights you know maybe 95 is inducing
some weaknesses
and we see ding the Run he goes Knight
D3 so he's actually creating a thread of
his own Rook B1 check followed by Knight
takes F2 so ding says I am not just
going to defend by uh you know bringing
my knight backwards I'm gonna defend
actively by creating a threat of my own
and well I think that these players
especially Jan at this point I think Jan
now should make a draw when it becomes
available because his Knight even though
it looks active it's kind of strangely
placed and this night on D3 is hitting
this Pawn F2 and there could be some
issues if Jan's not careful
yeah it's it's a good moment to shut it
down
but it's hard to imagine either side
ever taking
because even if you take that F2 Pawn
probably white will get a lot of capital
as well
but yeah you might as well just shut the
game down
I mean
Jan would want to do
start being a little active with the
move Rook F5 you defend the F2 you're
also eyeing the F7 pawn and then the
shutdown that you were talking about the
Knight jumps back to C5 once the knights
are off the board you know that is
heading towards a draw Rook F5 looks
like an option and yeah reaching out to
make his move I see him reaching out for
the Rook we might see it on the board
trick there yeah he's setting up a
pinned Pawn on G7 so he can Fork the
king Ajit and The Rook on E8 I think
ding Loren he'll spot that but it is you
know something is threatened and it's
just a funny thing don't just go Rook B1
check and take this Pawn you will lose
material uh so this Rook at some point
can try to slide to F4 that seems to put
pressure on F2 and cover the F6 Square
uh but yeah this is an interesting Try
by Yan because Knight F6 check it's not
the easiest move to me like there aren't
that many options available to Black
I like Rook F4
I mean you can you play Rook F4 and H6
next move
I also think King HH should be
completely fun
uh you don't really want to play King h8
but I don't see the issue with it isn't
blender a pawn so just to show a very
quick variation King h8 do I have Knight
E5 because I take C5 Rook takes 65 I
mean yeah don't do it don't do it Bobby
don't take it
you got three against two but uh and
hey yeah
looks like an easy option
F3 H6 Rook D5
I mean
it's
it's equal with probably any move
but yeah I guess Jan is not risking
anything by continuing to play this on a
bit
yeah and well I guess it's kind of a
question Tanya for these two players
you've asked like who wants to get to
Blitz do you think at this point they're
starting to think about that I know
there are two games of Rapid remaining
their focus has to be there first but in
the back of their minds I mean Blitz is
getting closer
to me it really does feel like that Ian
would be the happier one to get to Blitz
and I'm and I'm saying that based on the
graphic what we saw when the
head-to-head we saw Jan he leads with a
big margin we know majority of those
games have indeed been playing have been
played online but simply dingler and has
been so inactive in Blitz he hasn't
played for over a year which is why we
don't find him in the free day ratings
because he hasn't played a blitz event
and I feel that Yan today comes into
this match knowing that comparing rapid
and Blitz his best chance today in Rapid
it's extremely close with blitz I would
give Yan to be your favorite by at least
60 40. and he's happy to draw as many
games as it takes to get there we see F3
the move that you suggested Fabi on the
board so keeping all the pawns defended
jumps back with night before it's just a
matter of moves withdrawal will
definitely be the outcome but I still
want to make that point that with the
kind of play that we've been seeing by
Yan how quickly he's been taking the
decision to simplify in certain
positions I think Jan's happy to get
this to Blitz and ding knows that
this is my feeling that Ding knows that
his best chance should be to try to wrap
the match up in Rapid
I'm not I'm not sure that that's how
ding is feeling
um
like also I'm not even sure he remembers
his score and Blitz against John
Stephanie doesn't doesn't care about it
yeah in that case I don't see why he
would feel like an underdog at all
yeah that could be I I mean no for for
sure that's it's better to to maintain
that activity but
uh he also hadn't been active in
classical chess for a long time right I
mean he during like 2020 period he
played uh half of the Kansas and that
was it then 2021 he played the other
half of the candidates and then in 2022
he played the Kansas and those were
um those were all his events for the
years 20 20 21 and 2022 and in 2023 he
played Vikings a so he's played
basically like three events in the last
four years
um besides online events of course
online there's been a lot of Chess right
but
but it doesn't seem like he uh he Minds
the fact that yeah he's he's not playing
as much as other guys but for sure he's
practicing in terms of training games uh
you know General chess preparation
and so on and I'm sure that he's had
plenty during his range training
sessions plenty of opportunity to play
Blitz with with the guys he's been
swearing with and we know one of those
guys is Richard reports and obviously
he's a top player so he's very good very
good training partner but there's
probably also been other
opportunities to to play practice
training games obviously this was uh
potential outcome of the match that they
get to wrap it uh that they potentially
even get to the blitz so for sure it's
been on their minds
Dion is still trying here he's not it's
not a draw yet
chatting this down he
is following that night on B4 and not so
many squares for that night with the
Rook on D6 and the rook and B7 speaking
of shutdowns well it it looks like
ding's the one who's trying to get that
in offers a drip trade it's been denied
by Yan he doubles up on the B file not
only threatening the Knight but a
potential Rook B8 coming up next
yeah he's gonna get the moral Victory
because after Knight D3 Rook B8 it
forces
Rook takes B8 oh he plays Rook d8 no
moral victory for
freon
John kind of looked up there and there
is a little moral Victory you could play
Knight F6 check black has to take and
only then you take this Knight you say
your Pawn structure is worse than mine
we know that should still be a draw
without much effort is three on three on
the same side of the board but yeah we
take our moral victories here and there
well we it's funny we saw that exact end
game without the H Pawn that could have
occurred in their Marathon game which
was a game nine
right where uh White has the three pawns
it was a night in game but at some point
they was trying to trade the knights on
F5 and enter a rook and two against rook
and three where black has a double death
bonds but here like even has that h-bomb
so
it's uh it's a door either way but it's
very nice to have the h-bomb to
eliminate any doubt
will yawn try Knight to B8 just it's
funny you know if White's King on it was
on H2 I think Knight to B would actually
potentially be a winning move
because like you need that check on D1
to
uh to be able to play Knight D5 like
let's say Knight B8 you play Knight D3
you lose after Knight C6 I think that's
like I'm gonna show that ever so quickly
nightbeat is a hilarious move Knight D3
Knight c60.4 hitting this broken forking
here but the moves are being played so
quickly let's let them play out we see a
trade of knights in a funny fashion that
we predicted and now we see the Rooks
are being offered but that idea by Fabi
Knight B8 to C6 uh clever try wait look
at Yan he knows that there's absolutely
nothing here it may look like a bad Pawn
structure you just can't attack it if
you bring a rook to B6 The Rook comes
back to D6 let's trade a pair of Rooks
then there are no chances
that happens on the board I think it is
just about me meeting the move control
that you can offer or draw people the
both both players will probably just
find a way to repeat it rotate to the
Rooks will start shuffling and we see
that happen uh they are just moving the
Rooks around and a three-fold repetition
and that's a draw agreed the second game
of the rapid playoff ends peacefully but
once again quite a bit of a fight very
different from what we saw in game one
but not an easy draw we saw some
interesting Dynamics and tries in the
opening by uh janapamnishi in the
Spanish the dingler held his own it will
come down to this game three where ding
starts with white how much risk is he
wanting to take and the conversations
that we're having about whether the
players where they consider their
chances best chat get involved and tell
us what you think these are the best
players in the world it is world number
two versus World number three it is a
close fight regardless of the format
that it is in what the time control is
so we've been seeing fantastic chess and
perhaps one of them feels more confident
in a certain time control or not well
time will tell and with this draw wow
the match is still Level Robert what
were the big moments in this one and
what did you make of it
yeah it's one to one in the tie bricks
after two draws neither side can defeat
the other but if we look at this game it
was an opening Advantage for yawn the
palmgi so what we've seen in games one
and two of tie break has been an edge
for the player with the white pieces and
we saw Yan he goes back to his tried and
true Spanish from the white side and
let's speed up a bit let's get to some
critical moments because around here
this is where ding decides to take this
Pawn on A4 it's a pretty big decision
and Fabi his next couple of moves it
felt like he was on the back foot after
taking this big choice
yeah I think that Jan was prepared for
this and he played bishop td2 and we saw
maybe an accuracy at around this moment
I mean especially his Rook to B8 which
had Jan looking at him like are you
crazy why are you playing root to B8 uh
we we were also I think correctly
critical of this move because after
Knight takes a four white definitely
secured advantage and maybe the move uh
that Tanya suggested with knights D4 was
a better option than this for to be
eight and here ding started to suffer
uh
you found this nice idea with C6
and Bishop B6 I think ding started to
play really really well defending this
unpleasant position with a lousy
structure
and it was Perhaps Perhaps ed6 was a
moment where Jan could have maybe bishop
G3 would have been much better chances
or an advantage because the end game it
looked like thing was holding it uh
quite well
right and Bishop G3 keeping the tension
it's something that we've been advising
for many of you out there but he didn't
he released it and then there was this
really nice find by doing the Run
playing Rook before inducing the move B3
and if not it was Rook C5 but that led
to Quick liquidation all the pawns were
traded off on the queen side and this
resulted in a pretty easy draw for the
players it was rook and three against
rook in three it is now one to one here
in the tie breaks of the world
championship match
this is getting very intense and I know
I bought out this conversation at the
start of the show Robert that what are
the chances of us actually getting a
blitz and we've got a one-to-one tie and
just two rapid games remaining and I
think for ding the next one with white
is so critical we've seen him come up
with a fantastic opening idea in that
first game of the rapid has team ding
with a Richard rapper prepared something
for game two as well that might might
just work this time but yeah has been so
solid so confident this is truly the
match between the best in the world and
we will be back in in just a few minutes
with Games reaction
introducing World quad the partner of
the Champions chess tour and chess.com
[Music]
World Quant is a global firm in the
field of quantitative Asset Management
if you don't know what that is it's the
job of building complex mathematical
models that seek to identify Market
inefficiency
for 2023 World Quant brain is bringing
together its International Quant
championship and the award-winning
Champions chess tour to hunt down the
next generation of Quant Finance
Specialists that sounds very exciting
you put your skills in practice in a
case competition where you get a real
Challenge and I signed up
worldquant is seeking new talent and new
energy and it's looking at the world of
Chess to help because nobody knows how
to analyze a position better than a
chess player right no Quan experience no
problem
so do you think you have what it takes
to compete in the international Quant
championship
sign up and be the next Quant champion
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
dominance move after move again and
again and again we have a recitation we
have history he is the five-time fide
World chess champion
but a chess Dynasty can also be cruel it
forces most to defer their dreams until
next time if there is a next time oh my
God he just blocked yeah he did I'm
Blown Away the game is over
as the Chess World Turns to Kazakhstan
the Magnus Carlson Dynasty is set to
close
the feed a world championship is finally
up for grabs
for two chess Superstars lying in weight
until next time is now
has methodically done what he needed to
do to get another shot at the title the
pressure to seize the moment this time
rests heavily upon Him Yan is running
out of resources he's built every single
threat that's possible and things just
counted it there's no way to make
progress home
dingley Ren knows firsthand what the end
of this dynasty means an unexpected
chance to make history
can China's best turn his Good Fortune
into Eternal Fame it's a drop what an
amazing defense by ding the 2023 world
champion will be decided in speed test
the legacy of this Championship spans
across centuries it reads from the names
of Chess Giants
for the first time in a decade a new
name will raise the trophy and be etched
into chess history
it's the 2023 b-day World Championship
whose name will next be called champion
[Music]
history is being written in Astana as
Jana Pharmacy and dingler and welcome
back to this classroom to play Let's
heard a rapid game we are down to the
playoffs welcome everyone to our
coverage of the video world championship
match and if you missed the action so
far you have missed out on two
remarkable games so make sure you don't
go anywhere get the popcorn because
we're just getting started two more
rapid games coming up the score is level
and to remember and I can't and I can't
I can't remember a world championship
which actually came down to a blitz
playoff and was decided in Blitz we are
one one and we spoke about this at the
start of the show I'm gonna throw this
question out one more time what are the
chances that changes today what are the
chances that does happen today and we go
into a blitz playoff I'll start with
Robert
oh I mean you're putting me on the spot
of course I expected at this point
that's the one thing I can expect in
this match because everything else is
just chaos but I I have to say the first
two games of the rapid here have been
very high quality I want to give my
praise to these players they have found
great ideas some really nice defensive
resources yawning giving up his Queen in
that first game and then ding in game
two he was able to stabilize from an
iffy position uh so whether or not we go
to Blitz doesn't matter to me I just
love the chest that we're seeing and
both players are giving it their all and
I think they're actually showing their
best stuff at the end of the match
Bobby in 2016 2018 we did see playoffs
happen but the matches were decided in
the rapid portion and you've been saying
this from the start that there is a big
likelihood of seeing a big fight in
Rapid but getting a final decisive
result in Blitz simply seeing the way
the players have been playing are you
sticking to that prediction
yeah I'm sticking to it I think it's a
very high chance that we're seeing a
blitz
uh Blitz playoff
and of course Anything Could Happen
these guys have played pretty pretty
well I mean the first game was I think
excellent second game being defended a
really uh unpleasant position out of the
opening and I think Eon missed a few
chances overall in these two games it
feels like they've been able to pose
problems with the white pieces
it looks like they've been getting under
a bit of pressure both of them playing
with the black pieces and we'll see if
that Trend continues
I love this View and we see Knight F3
and is it gonna transpose into some kind
of Catalan or will he keep the Deep on
on D2 wow ready
very classical approach from Beyond
Bishop to E7 invitation to the catalog
castle and here D4 wood transpose but B3
he played like this against Anish in the
uh in Vikings eye thing got a really big
Advantage winning Advantage but lost the
game
and that was with D4 and
C5
yeah so we're seeing a totally different
approach that game uh that didn't play
with Anish was a wild one uh
if anyone watching wants to see a crazy
game that thing recently played that was
one of them this is going to be a more
quiet approach where I play as Bishop to
B2 followed by D4 this is a lot of
theory here Knight C6 and D4
but Jan looks completely unbothered by
what's happening on the chessboard so he
says a lot of theory Jan he's been
preparing for the canvas in 2020-21 he
played a world championship match
against Magnus he played the Cannons
again and won those he's playing this
match he seems like he knows his theory
yeah for sure he knows this line I'm
sure very very well and he prepared it
for the match we didn't see it in any of
the classical games what Young wants to
play against Knight F3 because Knight F3
G3 G and G3 is an invitation to
basically like at least a dozen viable
systems for black you know so it's
really a question of preference which
one you choose and now we found out that
this is what Young wanted to play it's
very logical because it's also but
transposed to a line he likes to play
gets a catalog which he defended
successfully in the candidates and in
the world championship match against
Magnus we also saw a drawing that along
with the bishop to E7 so it makes sense
from a from let's say a repertoire point
of view for young
and now dig is thinking Queen D4 or
Bishop D4 I think Bishop D4 is supposed
to be the move
um
too far and queen D4 almost was equally
popular here Queen D4 has been played by
Vladimir kramnik by Hikaru Nakamura so
definitely a move that is uh that thing
is considering right now by the way this
position that we have after night before
super popular with the top players so
many super Grand Masters above 2700 have
employed this opening the likes of
Hikaru the likes of artemia you got
Vladimir vladislavartamia Gwen Jones
with the black pieces chakra mamajaro
has played this position Wesley so has
played this position so it's definitely
something both players are very familiar
with and we do see the recapture with
the queen to D4 and Fabi you were
mentioning the move Bishop to F6 hitting
that Queen it is the most popular
response here and the only Square the
queen has you've got to fall back to D2
you've got to stay connected to that
Bishop on B2 yeah you it forces Queen D2
also the threat of Queen G7 was so
unpleasant that this is the most natural
way to and uh to meet it and I'll I'll
mention a funny move here I I don't
think it loses I think actually two
really funny moves don't lose one is
Knight to C3
and one is Knight to E3 and I think that
they're both very
um like they don't tactically lose
it looks like it's losing a piece but
probably it's like just not very
positional positionally desirable I'll
just show very quickly that Queen takes
uh Knight E2 check Intermezzo and if you
take this Knight on C3 with the bishop
there's Queen takes D2 and unfortunately
you can't take with the bishop The Rook
is hanging the corner and if you take
with the Knight Bishop takes C3 wins
back the piece and it's just an equal
game according to the evil bar so after
Knight C3 white can play let's say queen
to C2
Knight takes B1
maybe you take first on F6
we have six Rook a b one and probably
this would be completely equal it looks
like a sterile position but the bishop
on C8 is not yet developed so
like we won't see this but it's just a
funny
uh please reaching out for the night I
saw him you can also go to F4 with the
Knight that's the other thing I was
going to mention but it has similar
ideas
back well he's gonna move his Knight but
he goes Knight of four but but I was
wondering about this too and Fabi I knew
that was going to be your second uh stop
and your night's tour but if you just
take this Knight the point for everybody
watching is that their Queen takes that
Queen is the only piece defending the
bishop so after Pawn takes Knight Queen
takes Queen Knight takes Queen this
bishop is hanging on B2 now this is
important to work on your visualization
and tactical awareness so we can see or
hopefully you can remember that black
gives up a knight and a queen white
gives up a queen and a bishop so we're
trading equal material but the resulting
Position will leave white with a knight
is Knight on B1 or will be on D2 and
we'll leave black with a bishop but I
think Contours remain the same the
bishop on G2 outclasses the bishop just
to quickly put that on the board for
everybody give me this free night on F4
you're gonna take my queen I'll take
back you'll take on B2 and then after
some Rook move yeah white will probably
be slightly better despite black having
the pair of Bishops and I know how much
we harp on the bishop pair being so
great but it's because that this bishop
on G2 is so much stronger than the
bishop wants C8 and white will try to
get to the C file and cause some
pressure down the open Queen side
you know white definitely has pressure
here and I think that thing is kind of
obligated to go for this he doesn't have
anything else which makes any sense
so we will probably see this and if Jan
was on his prep I would say yeah you
think has a nice pleasant position to
press for win but beyond being in his
prep knowing the position well I don't
think that he'll be facing significant
problems
so we will likely see that black
equalizes with an accurate series of
moves after work to be won I don't know
where the bishop goes it looks like C3
is a natural Square
and Black's idea is probably to play
Rook to B8 followed by B5 just freed the
queen side
so you want to get B5 you want to get A5
and so on you just want to free that
Bishop on Sk8 by moving the queen side
pawns that makes perfect sense to me but
Tanya you just took us through some of
the history of this position and you
mentioned some of the best of Chess I
heard some huge names among the list of
players who have assayed this opening so
are you surprised that dinks seems to
not know these ideas given that it's
been played at such a high level before
you know it could be that usual stuff
and the moment you say it he does make
the move I think he's just trying to
remember how it really goes what is his
approach going to be where does he
create his chances and speaking of what
you just said Robert that you know the
big names that have actually played this
line well there is one game just from a
couple of months ago two months ago from
the Athens Masters versus Wesley so
again two of the best players playing
this opening and we did see this exact
position being reached and here Wesley
decided to trade the Queens we see Yan
do the same Knight to D2 will happen the
bishop will be picked up in that game
White's Knight found its way to D6 and
that's what I'm expecting for from ding
as well here the path is as you're
pointing out with the arrows you want to
go Knight C4 you want to get that Knight
to D6 so far we are still in Hikaru
Wesley territory and we're also being
updated by some very fascinating fun
stats by our team that the only other
p-day world championship tiebreak that
started with two draws was Magnus versus
karyakin back in 2016. the first two
games were a draw and then Magnus took
the match winning game three and game
four we haven't yet seen a world
championship match go into the blitz to
be decided and when we asked our chat
about that only 29 actually expected
this match to go all the way down to the
wire to the blitz to decide who the
world champion will be it'll take me
some time to get my head around that a
classical world champion being decided
in Blitz one thing's for sure it's gonna
be super entertaining once again Robert
this is a position that we have seen
before we are still in super GM
territory in this one
yeah and actually I'm going to ask
Fabiano speaking of super GM's so Jan
decides to play this line he plays
Knight F4 now that we're here sometimes
people you know they know their
preparation thoroughly but they get to a
position that they may not be thoroughly
comfortable in so this type of position
to my eyes would be more ding style than
John style so are you surprised at all
that Jan chose this variation or do you
think that he's going to confidently
play the next bunch of moves and be able
to hold this position
I think that this is sort of Beyond's
modern approach to openings which is
just to shut the game down and this is
definitely a way to try to do so it
because you if you analyze a position
and know well then yeah we we can safely
assume that the position is objectively
going to turn into equality without your
play now there's also the Practical side
to it
um what you were speaking to which is
that it might not be so easy to play and
it might also not be so fun for yawn to
try to defend this position uh
but
from like a modern opening approach it's
a it's a very standard and very viable
way of doing so
um also I think black's next moves are
pretty logical they involve Rook to B8
E5 and and these types of moves A5 E4
Bishop A6 developing the bishop another
way because it can't go to D7 without
dropping the pawn
um so you want to play that Rook to B8
and
for white the question is yeah do you
want to play Knight to E4 here
you want to play Knight C4 so after
Knight C4 I'm really thinking to move
Rook to B8 is a very very logical one
and I wasn't seeing the follow-up for
white that's very clear well you're not
going to play B5 right not not anymore
because the Knight will go into A5 so
just to analyze something a little
quickly here is Rook B8 uh I was gonna
make a throwaway movement before you're
not gonna play B5 because then the
Knight sinks its teeth into this square
and it's a C6 and that's Bishop is very
bad so I guess you could put B6 instead
but like even if we get this type of
position maybe Knight D6 is very strong
here as well but I'm just wondering Fabi
like if you probably played Bishop B7 I
always have Rook D7 so I feel like just
black is passive and not couldn't have
the easiest time to defend these kind of
end games
it could be unpleasant they would come
down to concrete factors even in this
position Bishop G2 King G2 and one of
those Rooks to C8
uh let's say we're
BC it for some reason I don't know why
it feels a bit better I have Knight D6
Rook F to d8
or CTA yeah we don't have to be fancy so
96 is probably not the way
doesn't mean Rook C1 is the way then or
yeah you can drop the Knight back but
Knight back
doesn't feel like
um
it's disaster for black but yeah Rook C5
A4 and the pawn on A7 is tough to defend
A4 maybe Rook to A8 is still holding it
together
but I think as we go back to the live
board just what we're looking at that is
clearly nice for white and he goes to E5
so I'm a bit surprised because I thought
you tend to keep this Knight against the
bishop because that dark Square Bishop
couldn't attack anything but he believes
the pure Rook end game should be
beneficial because Rooks love what
everybody in chat I know I can hear your
answer open files whose Rook is on an
open file it's white and if this bishop
ever does fianchetto then that Rook
Slams on D7 so it's a safe plus for
dingley Ren and Tanya I mean you're a D4
player you like these slight advantage
in positions I feel like for on one hand
what Fabi is saying is true concrete a
calculation will be required maybe young
could work his way out but dingley red
has nothing to complain about in this
position he can just play for a win with
zero risk
yeah and the question is how much is it
to actually play for the win it's
definite that if anyone's got the upper
hand you mentioned the open files the
Monstrous bishop and G2 are really
actively placed Knight on E5 now the one
thing that black definitely doesn't want
to do is trade that monstrous night yes
you want to get rid of it but taking
that Knight on E5 would be a disaster
you simply compare the pieces that
you're left with and you see that the
black Rooks will find it very difficult
to connect that bishop and C8 will be
bad for a long time and white will get a
lot of activity down on the seventh rank
if that bishop ever moves so Bishop B5
would be shocking to see on the board I
don't expect the players to go for this
direction
the trump in Black's position is that
yes the C8 Bishop isn't that great but
the fact is that there's still a bishop
pair in the position at any point we can
see an opposite color Bishop happening
uh I think black here has to neutralize
this open file advantage that you're
talking about try and trade as many
pieces as possible and kick out that
knight from E5 with a move like F6 the
bishop on F6 is the one that's the piece
on route that you need to get that out
of the way Rook d8 is the move that
comes to mind here trade that Rook if
white was to swap those Rooks take it
with your Bishop get that move F6 in
stop pushing the Knight out try and get
the B6 Bishop B7 ideas that you're
looking at Robert in different lines and
I also just want to point out that we're
seeing a different position from the
game earlier that we were mentioning in
that game Hikaru had decided to plant
the Knight to D6 in this one ding has a
different approach he plants the Knight
to E5 instead and uh yeah a newish
position but not one that hasn't been
played before I'm gonna point it out
again we've got another big game that
actually has happened here and that's
between artemium and yantrys.duda so I'm
pretty sure both these players are
definitely aware of this uh Fabi do you
think
do you think they are actually because
the more time they may they take I kind
of start doubting that
I don't think they remember the details
of this position
they they probably know the position in
some sort of vague sense like the ideas
but it's hard to analyze this in so much
detail because uh both sides probably
have quite a bit of moves and even if
let's say you analyze it you probably
don't remember every uh every line of it
and Rook T8 d8 looks like a good move I
was thinking like Bishop takes E5
does come to mind as a possible move I
wouldn't be surprised what he plays
works at d8 instead so that was probably
the best move that you mentioned
uh that Black's idea is if the bishop
comes off after F6 then then I can push
the pawn to F6 keep the Knight away
bring the king into the game bring the
bishop to D7 potentially if that square
frees up and
from a pure like
like not even looking at the concrete
factors of the position black is doing
well his Bishop pair structure is nearly
symmetrical in fact maybe even a bit
favorable for black if we conserve the F
model is a bit of a
structural weakness but black has no
development compared to white White's
pieces are much more active so the only
problem for black will be getting the
bishop out from C8 if the bishop on C8
was on E8 I think like never be worse
like just impossible to imagine black
being worse if the bishop somehow was
not on that very passive Square starting
Square
yeah and that is why it increased the
pressure here that's a good question and
father I just want to let you know that
the results are in and 53 of over 20 000
votes so that you will not learn
background Checkmate so I just want to
point that out and that actually is
important in a position like this where
black does not have left for the king
and you ask how to increase the pressure
I'm just wondering if we just analyze
very quickly if we just start swapping
pieces and I go Rook D1 and you go
Bishop to C7 and I play E3 you can't
take and that's why I brought up that
hole because that is a back rank check
made and if you play F6 like we've been
talking about I'm wondering how
difficult this would be because now the
rook's on the seventh rank B7 is hanging
this bishop can also slide to H3 at some
moment to go after the E6 Pawn this is a
situation that could be difficult for
black
so Robert just to clarify you couldn't
take on E5 because it was positionally
bad to allow F takes C5 right I just
want to like make sure that I'm
understanding this yes because it's it's
definitely because of f take Z5 here and
white has a clear positional Advantage
right well you see the evaluation bar is
pretty much as high as had you played
Rook da checkman in one so you're spot
on there but yeah I think just in
general even
you know being a little more serious for
a second this doesn't look that easy for
black because in all likelihood you'll
lose B7 we are seeing Rook takes d8 so
we might just see this on the board but
maybe there's a position that Tanya
called for where we might see a bishops
of opposite color end game where even if
you're down one Pawn you can still make
that draw
so that's the whole point how much of an
advantage would this really are not to
be and we are we see the bishop bear
fight in these end games even down upon
simply because of the option of having
the opposite color Bishop possibility we
see the Rooks have been traded and
dingler and can put his other Rook on
the open D line the line that you were
mentioning I don't expect a background
Checkmate after Bishop C7 or the
Strategic problems if bite was simply to
capture an E5 but Bishop C7 does make a
lot of sense here it's the move you want
to make it's the move you want to get in
you want to play F6 and the line that
you were looking up looking at Robert I
think that's the big question Bishop C7
even if you were to give away the B7
Pawn after the trades on D7 you simply
move your Bishop to B6 snacks let's say
Bishop C7 Knight D7 happens after E3 F6
well let's play Let's Play instead of F6
and move King to f8 so I really don't
want to weaken the E6 Pawn
I think that this might be an important
detail
and now Fabi I'm gonna throw this to you
that
doesn't Rook B7 is a draw for here right
if the Rooks are off the board there's
nothing to play for Bishop B7 rook d8
and the moment I mention it I understand
fabi's detail it's insane how he sees
this stuff and the simple point is that
that King on f8 actually controls the E7
Square so in fact this forces the Rooks
off the board and it all comes down to
that milking f8 you suggested super hard
to see for me back when I suggested F6
it makes a lot of sense a really nice
detail there Fabi
yeah I think we were we were definitely
thinking the same direction which is
that the B7 Pawn is likely to fall but
it's not the end of the world and not
only that it's it's probably very likely
to we don't see Yan go for that instead
to E7 and then that's a different
diagonal the nice idea of this is after
Knight to D7 Rook to A8
uh White no longer has a move Knight to
C5 which might have been a possibility
if the bishop was not on E7 so after 97
I don't think he is any more in the
intro and interested in capturing you
might actually capturing King to f8 with
the same
I don't think so because I don't think
black is trading Rooks there potentially
so after 97 maybe just route to eight
asking why yes I'm fully passive but you
put your knight on D7 and if I play F6
King F7
could potentially be trapped you might
not want to leave there it doesn't
actually do anything in the position
right so maybe that's a dead end for
white and with that in mind maybe this
is an easy way for black to equalize
with the F6 move coming on the board for
example E3 is met by F6 right and I just
want to show a few things that you're
saying there because it's very
instructive for everybody that why at
what change in the position so Knight D7
that looks like the move we've been
talking about why not play it and why
not take but to your point that now
after Bishop takes B7 Rook d8 this Rook
escapes to the C7 square that Bishop had
previously been on B6 now whites up a
pawn we'll put our Bishop on C4 maybe
we'll throw in an F5 and go after the F7
Pawn the engine says yeah whatever it's
a draw but practically speaking these
end games can be difficult Jennifer you
she won a really nice game against Team
India at uh the 2018 Olympiad where she
had an end game up a pawn similar to
this where she was able to win in the
long run so this is not advisable but
Fabi and if you play Rook A8 that just
looks like the saddest move ever because
you don't really have a Next Movement
what if I just throw my Pawn up the
board and take advantage of your Rook
being on a
yeah A4 might be really really
unpleasant
and um that's actually a great idea yeah
we see 97.
4 and I think he's going to be up
as soon as you're talking rookie A4 look
starts to look very scary for black the
a pawns marching down the board that
bishop and see it not doing anything now
you're never imagining taking on D7 once
you put your Rook on it that's a bad
idea so it does look like it will be an
opposite color Bishop end game we're
gonna be seeing the line with the trade
on D7 Rook D7 and the Eternal question
how much is it is it still going to be
enough yes you managed to not trade the
Rooks you keep the rook and the bishop
on the board but Fabi is that still
closer to a draw
yeah definitely uh close to draw even if
white is safely keeping that pawn and
keeping Rooks on the board but it
doesn't look super Pleasant to defend it
so let's see if black can try to trade
or somehow
after Bishop D7 Rook D7 I think King f8
is Supernatural although
like certainly can move the bishop
somewhere as well
funny just first step is dingo is kind
of smiling when he left the board and
now Jana's thinking so I'm maybe just
settling down getting back into uh
concentration mode but he is down a few
minutes on the clock so I know he sells
plenty of time remaining there is the
increment but I'm starting to think
about these things because as you said
it's not going to be a pleasant hold he
will be down upon and if he doesn't take
on D7 which his only other option is
Rook 8 the threat of A4 A5 A6 is now
becoming increasingly clear and that
looks terrible as well
yeah Rook A8 I mean I I really thought
this was an idea what Bishop B7
it seemed to follow logical change which
is how you stop Knight C5 so that the
Knight remains crapped on D7 but why it
is in time it's a game of Tempe I have
to Rook to A8 A4 black it wasn't time
for F6 King f8 King F7 King E8 then it
would be fine but after A5 King F7 if
the King was on E8 A6 would not uh would
not treble black in fact King a would
win the piece but A6 here black is just
one tempo too slow and King to E8
either Bishop B7 or ab7 either one works
but ab7 is pretty
uh convincing and you win the piece
so young
avoids that of course and it was for
upon down position
and that's the big question that you
were bringing up right rookie it wasn't
a possibility Yan navigated through that
danger and Fabi after Rook D7 King f8 if
white was to pick up the B7 Pawn I just
want to point out that it looks like
the king can start chasing the white
rookie it King day and white Rook will
not have enough squares but there is a
nice resource that white has in that
position and we're seeing all this being
played out Rook D7 on the board King f8
has been blitzed out now Rook B7 is a
draw for it's not gonna happen ding will
try to play this position with the Rooks
on and Bishop B7 the point I wanted to
make Robert was that after King here
there is the move Bishop to C6 and that
just keeps everything defended you
defend your Rook you've saved your
bishop and you're much better because
you end up picking up the A7 Pawn as
well so we see the move Bishop B7 and
now after Rook d8 very importantly the
move Rook C7 is available and Yan with a
shake of head there he's not happy
defending this position and he shouldn't
be I actually think this is extremely
dangerous for him the evaluation bar can
be misleading and let's not forget who
he's playing he is playing ding lyren
what did ding do in the candidates uh
let's let me think about that he beat
yanchist of Duda in an end game that
didn't look very winnable he beat it
karunakamura in an end game that look
everyone look at the evaluation person
yeah that should be equal but no it's
not an easy position to play Black is
down a pawn and what would be your
defensive setup you need to get your
Bishop in contact with your Pawn so keep
it defended white has the more active
Rook white has extra material white has
some outside threats and bring this
bishop around to Target's F7 Pawn Jan
doesn't look happy I wouldn't be happy
either he does play A5 which I think is
heading in the right direction to put
his Bishop on B4 next but I think it's
going to be a long defensive battle for
him
think that it's
when I'm starting to look at the
position like black setup will be you
put the bishop on B4 you get the king to
a nice Square by playing G6 King G7
and white needs to advance the Pawns in
some way but the only way to arrange A3
you actually can't really arrange it
because you don't want to put your Rook
back on A1 to push that uh and the only
other way to arrange it is to play Rook
to A7 at some moment and play A3 but I'm
also looking at the F2 Pawn as a
weakness so for example after A5 let's
play White makes move like
Bishop to F3 or King G2
um a move which doesn't change a whole
lot and black plays Bishop dv4
and
maybe white should put the bishop on D3
just to avoid the possibility after G6
black will get Rook D2 and not only
attacking the a pawn
but also
attacking um potentially E2 and F2 right
so at least this keeps The Rook out but
how are you going to make progress here
I'll play G6
uh you play King G2 King G7
but I think you made a good point that
the F4 Pawn is just loose yeah also Rook
D4 at some moment will maybe force root
to C4
because at some point we're wrote to C4
because you will continue to pile up on
that problem with Bishop D6 and
I don't see this as being super
difficult I mean yeah I think white will
at some point be forced to trade Rooks
and
yeah most likely
the ideas that white has is you need to
keep it's on about the objective
evaluation it's about can like can you
continue to pose practical problems for
your opponent and in this position I
don't see those practical problems
yeah I'm with you the more you talk
about the position the more we analyze I
see your point the F4 Pawn that's an
unfortunate one if you ever play E3 then
you won't be able to block the D file
and your F2 Pawn becomes the next Target
so uh if the Rooks stay on the board
that will give ding chances and he's
about to try to use the clock as a
weapon at some point I don't know how he
can do that but establishing the bishop
on D3 looked like a normal starting
point uh maybe start with Bishop E4 and
try to get F5 in that could be something
to consider just you want to create a
weakness in Black's position and it has
to be the F7 Square well G6 will be
played Black will be super happy to get
that pawn there sometimes we say don't
put ons on the like squares where you're
where your post Bishop can attack them
but more often it's the case that you
need to put pawns on squares of your
opponent's Bishop so that that Bishop
gets restricted and here if for example
after Bishop before let's say black for
some reason played H6
just to illustrate like what not to do
in these positions uh it might be
let's say white plays E3
and from let's say a purely logical
point of view you might think I want to
put my pawns on dark squares so that the
bishop and I'll attack them but you play
F6 here and you're already probably just
on the verge of losing after Bishop G6
or something like that uh just because
that Bishop now has a lot of squares it
can access because your oppon's on dark
squares they don't control the light
squares and as your Bishop also doesn't
do so your light squares have become a
terminal weakness so you keep the pawns
on the light squares uh E6 F7 G6 H7 the
only
um
exception to this rule is a pardon A5
because that pawn is can be defended by
the bishop
so
yeah this is it's sort of a tricky
positional thing uh it's it's definitely
one of those things that becomes more
clear with practice and with experience
in these types of positions
and part of the reason is that Bobby
you're mentioning the move G6 fighting
against this F5 advance and I want to
ask you about this because from a
practical perspective trying to find a
setup where you've got a good chance I'm
envisioning the white Bishop on C4 The
Rook on C7 and Black's E6 Pawn gone
why to use this opportunity where juice
can happen and just go F5 immediately
say yes I'm sacrificing the pawn but in
return you double up your Pawn when I
had my Bishop from A6 to C4 start
putting pressure on F7 I know F5 is the
kind of move that perhaps the engine
will hit and say it not happening
doesn't work out you're giving a pawn
for free it doesn't make any sense from
a practical perspective because I feel
in a game this would definitely come to
my mind
yeah I have a strong feeling the engine
would like this move
uh not in terms of like let's say giving
white an advantage but it would say that
it's a decent move along with
uh with some others and yeah it's it's a
good idea because
it's more about the activity yeah
F5 is a fun move
why won't keep a small veterans so F5
probably black will take otherwise
you can also include Bishop D6 in fact
maybe you should
you get that Rook off of 70. yeah maybe
F5 Bishop D6 let's let's do that to make
life easier for ourselves
and
your point is that it just I think we
just show what happens if e takes a five
first uh Tanya was saying let's get this
bishop around and then this bishop 187
will have to sit passively it has to
stay there so that Rook doesn't get
access to F7 so what Bobby's point is
let's include Bishop D6 your Rook has
nowhere safe to go in the seventh Rank
and only then will we take on F5 yeah
and then white won't be able to arrange
this um pressure on the F7 point because
let's say Rook C6 e takes F5 and Bishop
to A6 black will I don't think it's
necessary to play Rook D7 at the moment
but at some point I could do it
immediately or let's say G6 followed by
Rook D7 black gets the seven the rank
Bishop C4 Rook D7 safely covered and
then the bishop goes to B4 everything is
defended A5 you're not passive your
Bishop isn't passive it's able to defend
that A5 Pawn
and evaluation hasn't really changed
it's remained pretty much that the
position is objectively a draw
but it's that's why you need to be
accurate at these moments like F5 is a
very good tricky try and I think against
a lot of players it would lead to
um
to you know getting some Chances with
the white pieces to potentially pressure
but I think that Dion wouldn't
miss this moment to play Bishop D6 super
accurate and make an easy draw there
isn't really panning out because as you
said Bishop B6 such a nice inclusion
you don't want to be so forceful you
don't want to give Yan the obvious can
we just like put a rook on A4 I know
it's awkward but that's the only way I
see us starting to push these pawns Rook
C4 Bishop B4
oh so you're not even let me there to
begin with you're I thought you're my
friend
well not today
we might be seeing this idea by the way
Rook C4 played great call Robert
you know there's there's no friends on
the chess board is that is that a saying
or I'm not sure if that's actually the
same
something like that we'll let it slide
and quickly Bishop B4 so Rook D2
suddenly gives black some double attack
possibilities and yeah Tanya your F5
move we have to keep that in our mind
and black in many positions plays G6 his
father was saying to stop F5 but I like
it it's just instructive to think about
when you're up material where the
position is balanced maybe you can
restore material equality but then you
have some other advantages in your
position namely a potential Target in
Black's Camp so Rook C4 Bishop to B4 ice
no I was the one who was thinking has
some legitimate chances to win now I'm
looking at this like wait a second can
what can you even do here it just seems
like too big of a fortress
yeah this is a confident really
confident hold free on and I don't see
this going any other way except for a
draw
and that's that's really good outcome
for you on his openings are holding up
well in the first game he was struggling
a bit in the opening but this one is
showed up with good preparation
very professional draw we can I think
that's the right word to use for this
uh you you draw with the black pieces
and then start to put pressure with
white I think we'll be under pressure in
that last game
one gets the feeling as if team Yan has
looked at every single possible opening
idea because ding comes up with these
new moves these new Concepts out of the
opening we saw that with the white
pieces in both games by ding but yeah
I'm just confidently blitzing out moves
plays accurately keeps things under
control this amazing prep that by Damian
and he keeps that pressure on the clock
as well staying behind by five minutes
but he's up upon so I don't see the
clock being a factor in this one it is
whether it is Advantage enough or not
and we're looking at a pawn sacrifice on
F5 it would make a lot of sense if white
was able to put pressure double down on
that pawn on F7 that that won't be
possible the very uh very soon Yan can
just stop that idea forever with the
move G6 keep everything under control we
see Yan has indeed left the board and
Fabi I want to ask you at this moment
while ding is in a bit of a thing and we
know that the position is pretty calm
right now that
for both these players they know it's
today right today is the day there is no
tomorrow for them at least in terms of
the world championship match and one of
them will be Crown World Champion and
yesterday after game 14 a very difficult
one where ding was on the defense for a
very long time ding was asked if he
thought about becoming world champion
and he responded saying that the only
thing he thought about was not becoming
world champion and that of course comes
from the game 14 Action and him being
and him struggling with white in that
one what's the pressure like for these
two right now they can see the trophy
the stunning trophy is just a couple of
feet away from them it hasn't been there
before and look at that uh you know you
know you're sort of edging towards every
passing game you're reaching that Finish
Line what's the pressure like in this
moment
I feel like
it's it's a lot of pressure but it
really depends on the games as well like
I don't think Gian is feeling any
pressure at the moment because his
position he doesn't have to solve huge
issues he doesn't have to solve like
real let's say intellectual problems
over the chessboard I mean he he kind of
knows that it's a draw and his moves
play themselves
but yeah these players definitely know
that today is a day
as
I don't know if you're familiar with the
great artist big Shaq he also said today
is the day
I think that was before his second big
single man man don't dance
but whoever's winning this match is
definitely going to be dancing tonight
and no one's winning this game because
take a look at what
a dingler and saying that I know in this
opposite color Bishop ending I don't
have enough resources and Fabi nothing
to play for here there it looks like
this should be heading for a draw any
moment now
yeah I think we'll try to get the king
to the queen side and and play on a bit
but usually you're not able to get your
king active because the uh the bishop
and King they somehow control those
words and also if you ever get your king
active you start to hit your king side
pawns attacked
so I think
this is one of those positions where you
can start to put pawns on dark squares
too because here without Rooks uh
Bishop can't can't attack the pawns on
darkspurs and having a weakness on the
light Square complex usually doesn't
really mean anything
so he can he can play H6 here he can
play King to D6 if White's King goes
forward probably Bishop D1 at some
moment will start to attack
uh the white pawns and even if white
gets a pass b-pawn for example which
might be possible to arrange that it's
usually covered by the bishop very
handily in fact Bishop is and is so good
at covering pawns along with the King
and very often even two pawns uh
struggle to advance depending on which
color complex they're on but very often
like we have these end games we feel
like we sweep the queen side pawns off
the board and we're left with two pawns
and upseller Bishops very often the
bishop can hold the um the two connected
pass Pawns
although those positions those positions
do remain rather tricky but there are a
lot of instances where even that is not
enough to win this is just an easy draw
and I don't think yeah moves yeah
arm game by both players uh playing this
inkins pictures opening
handling it to Perfection going into
this position down upon but a confident
hole in an opposite color Bishop sees
the two players drawing and we're still
level in this rapid playoff getting
closer to that potential Blitz tiebreak
deciding this world championship the
trophy is in front of us and Fabi you
were talking about the pressure and the
players being very focused and just
thinking about their next move
especially given the kind of position
that they have there's so much on the
line today going into this final rapid
games we rapid game we are at one and a
half a piece for these two players
Robert out of all the action that we've
seen safe to say this one was the
calmest
it was and com was not good for dingly
Ren usually he's very calm uh he's stoic
at the board but he got nothing we
thought that he might have a little bit
of an edge it was the third draw in a
row kind of a wasted white pieces in a
way and this is the final position
they're honest honestly wasn't that much
meat in this game if we go back to the
beginning like I look at this game and
we go through it there was a tactical
shot by black at this point coming up
where he went Knight to F4 and Bobby
this was slight Edge for white but
dingley Wren was not able to capitalize
in the slightest it felt like John just
forced everything off the board yeah we
saw what black is going for with this
line which is that you accept a slightly
worse end game but you know that with
accurate play you should be able to hold
it and that's exactly what we saw it
wasn't even about the concrete moves
because at some point white used the
pressure the initiative that he has
based on better piece activity to win a
pawn but that was the best that it got
him the winner of a pawn was was not
enough because we saw a big trade of
pieces and even though white has won
material in you would think this is a
big success for white
there's no ideas for white here the
obstaclear Bishops black super sturdy
King side structure are the reasons why
white cannot make progress in this
position
yeah and then the draw was agreed in the
near future it didn't even feel like
they impressed him very much from this
point so for dingley Ren this has to be
a wasted opportunity with the white
pieces for Yonder Palm she had confident
hold he just played a normal opening he
played all very natural moves and he was
in no danger so this really wasn't as
much content as the first two games as
the Rooks eventually came off the board
right here and the players did agree to
a drop by repeating with the King and
Bishop dance
well energy is such an important factor
and I think ding just feeling like he
doesn't have enough decided to shut this
down because he's going to need all of
that energy and more going into this
final fourth game of Rapid we speak we
keep talking about the blitz playoff but
there is a big final fourth game coming
where Jana Palmer she will start with
the white pieces the margin for error in
this one is zero because there is no way
home if you go wrong in this one thing
Lauren has to have a confident hold with
the black pieces he needs to do
everything to survive this one Jana
publishing won three classical games
with the white pieces in two classical
games in the white with the white pieces
can he strike in this final fourth game
which will be decisive whoever wins this
is world champion or will we see Blitz
we'll find out on the other side of this
break
all right
[Music]
I do recommend Meetup to a lot of my
friends that are looking for different
things wine tasting movies book club
meet a lot of new people a lot of new
friends and it make you more social
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
Baron are fighting for the ultimate
Glory the ultimate dream of winning that
Trophy this is the final game of the
rapid playoff for the 2023 p-day World
Championship the players will step into
for this final game in just a few
moments and today we're a new world
champion will not be called thanks
Carlson it will be the end of the Magnus
era well at least as the classical world
champion Jana pamushi in his second shot
at the world championship the first one
in 2021 ended in game 11 with a
convincing crushing Magnus Victory and
this one is going down to the wire in
the sports game Jan will start with the
white pieces how much risk is he willing
to take he hasn't lost a single game
with white to dengleren in this match so
far and as we see there is so much to
fight for Bobby you're on that list as
the 2018 Challenger with all your
experience how much risk Will Leon take
in this final game
I don't think you'll take too much the
weight is just too high that you know if
you lose it's all over it's uh not like
previous games where you might have a
chance to fight back it's just the end
of the entire match and you will
definitely want to press I'm sure he'll
be feeling ambitious he can look to the
second game uh for confidence in terms
of you know getting chances out of the
opening and putting pressure on ding but
you definitely don't want to be in a
situation where you start to
I think this is also why it's better to
start with black because when you have
white in the last game
you uh you start to feel like
well actually maybe that doesn't make a
whole lot of sense what I just said so
I'm going to to amend what I just said
um but yeah my feeling is is that
you can play for a win but you want to
maybe take a bit more safety because
you're worried that if you get to that
moment where you're starting to risk
that like things aren't entirely going
your way then you it just gets in your
head like I'm gonna lose this game and I
could have just made like an easy draw
and you don't want to get those thoughts
in your head so I think he'll try to
play for win from a position of uh of
general safety of General stability and
if he gets chances from that and I think
he can do so in some various
anti-martial lines that we already saw
in this rapid playoff
then he will play for a win if not he'll
be happy to take it to Blitz
yeah I think John napomchi has been able
to get a stable it might be small but a
stable Advantage most of the time he's
had the white pieces in the smash he has
not lost the game with the white pieces
to dingly Wren and I think stylistically
it has been a decent matchup when you're
in a situation where a draw is okay that
he can just get a little Advantage he
can play for pressure in the queen side
like we just saw in game two and unlike
dingley rent who does take some serious
risks with the white pieces I think that
young he's got nothing to worry about if
he makes a draw we do head to that Blitz
Tanya I know that would make you happy
play off while either
it's going to be an exciting one I'm
gonna stick to what I said earlier I
think for Yan it does also make a lot of
sense to get that let's play off in
these are the words to two of the
world's best players there's no doubt
about that and it will be very close in
Blitz but in my head I would think that
Ian would perhaps find his chances to be
slightly more in the blitz than in the
rapid I do expect a safety first
approach as you're saying by Yan not
over pushing it because the risk if it
backfires once again no margin for any
of that there is no other game if you
lose this you lose the match and that is
match over so definitely expecting a
more cautious approach by Yan I think if
he has the opportunity unless unless an
opportunity is right in in his face
I feel the ambitious approach we might
not see that much from him I think a
blitz playoff will be something that
perhaps both will be happy about but
yeah especially at least in my head and
we see ding is the first one to arrive
with the black pieces his task is
straight up he needs to make sure
nothing goes to out of hand he needs to
make sure that Ian doesn't get that big
opportunity today we see him adjusting
his pieces Yan who's been confident
throughout today comes he starts the
final game with the white pieces
expecting him to start with the
kingspawn opening one E4 that's what he
stuck throughout that's been his
preparation for this match and I think
Lauren a big question does he stick to
one E5 does he stick to that King spawn
opening or will we see perhaps another
Richie surprise
I think we're going to see him at Nancy
Marshall again
I would love to see a surprise but
hate to be the bearer of bad news these
these guys don't want to start
experimenting on the last decisive rapid
game where if everything goes wrong then
all of their previous three weeks of
work were basically in vain
I don't know if it's really time to
experiment it might not be a bad
decision but
it's pretty risky too anyway we'll
quickly see what these guys have planned
we're gonna find out out E4 on the board
as you said E5 is it gonna be a Berlin
will after Knight C6 Bishop B5 yeah she
sticks to his move and we are going to
see an anti-martial as you mentioned or
maybe not
might even see a marshall no no Marshall
no Marshall but the more it's good
because the Marshall these days it you
you think like oh uh upon sacrifice in
the opening exciting the Marshall is is
the most boring uh it just all worked
out to a draw just like
too much Theory it's it's it no longer
has a reputation of being an exciting
variation
they're going for the same line right
yeah they are the same line
if there's no more Marshall could we
just get Shady come on let's get this
Real Slim Shady the players need to
stand up right here Knight A5 it's a
repeating so they're repeating the game
they saw we saw earlier and I wonder
what preparation has gone into this and
Jan he deviates by bringing his Knight
to C3 earlier we saw the bishop come
back to D2 in this game he brings his
Knight up to C3 and well now ding has to
figure out the nuances here what has
changed in the position
repeating is because Robert they're not
afraid
laughs
that was that was a good one Tanya it's
um I I think that
usually we don't see a repeat in in the
classical games because they have time
to analyze stuff but they had no time in
between games and they don't have access
to engines so they have no time to
analyze that means that Jan is not
worried that thing is going to come to
the board with some sort of uh computer
prep he knows that Ding will be on his
own
this
is sorry
it is not for the bishop that square is
for no peace at all please can you
explain this to us what is this move
yeah I think the move is so if black
tries to hold on to the a pawn with
Queen E8 then B3 comes and you can't
take on B3 we should show that B3 you
can't take because the Knight is loose
on A5 really nice instructor there okay
so so normally you think in that case I
take on B2 with the Rook so at least you
get my a pawn but I got coupon return I
remain up on Sunday takes a four and if
Rooks B8 because you don't maybe you
don't want to give the bishop here the
Knight to C5 I think is the only
tactical justification of this and why
it gets the bishop pair
it's probably only enough for a slight
Advantage yeah Knight C6 97 Queen D7
Rook takes A6
tiny to edge for whites but beyond
thinks in Rapid and Rapid game Bishop
pair is a long-term advantage and it
might not be a whole lot but it's
something something to work with it
looks like Fisher random chess like if
you showed me this position with a
bishop run B1 I thought it just started
there but it's a very interesting idea
and the lines we were just looking at we
took the vacuum cleaner out we took on
B2 A4 A6 went away this Knight traded
for this bishop down here yeah white has
the slight hole because this bishop will
see the light of day back to A2 at some
point uh but black doesn't have too many
weaknesses either so dingley red is
doing the right thing Bishop B1 comes a
surprise but it's not a surprise where
you're on your own he knew that this was
coming so now he just has to patiently
calculate and try to work it out Rook
takes B2 is by no means forced that does
force those lines liquidation but black
can also consider things we've been
talking about with C5 and other options
in the position
yeah you can well I think C5 is likely
to transpose if C5 Knight A4 you can
take and then take on B2 so it could
come either way from either of those
move orders
it also looks like a very viable
strategy we saw a hesitation by day in
the previous game with the black pieces
to
play C5 because it could weaken the
light squares long term especially if
you give up your blood Square Bishop
so I think rugby two like you can't
really go wrong with this move except
exactly that line that we were looking
at
black just wants to equalize the
position even if it's not super exciting
or black in the final position you know
Bishop pair symmetrical structure slide
Edge for white you know that your
position is still uh inherently healthy
and solid and you shouldn't be a whole
lot worse
and Tonya seems like Jan would be
answering your question in how much risk
is he willing to take so Tanya opening
success thus far for young
I'm still taking in this last move
Bishop to P1 I mean it's just visually
so shocking to see this move on the
board it's something that doesn't come
to your mind at all and dingler and
really slowing down because he's taken
aback as well or at least trying to
figure out the complications with Rook
B2 once again absolutely agree with you
Robert feels like a Fisher random game
being set up with that Bishop landing on
that night Square on B1 some amazing
stuff makes me
is of course an idea that team Yan had
in mind for this game for it's not an
over the boat preparation it's not over
the board inspiration you don't just
show up for game four and make the move
Bishop E1 on the board in seconds so
this is part of the bigger plan and the
big critical questions now but thing to
answer is what happens after Rook B2 and
all these trades that we're seeing he is
taking his time once again he doesn't
have that much time he's down on the
clock by four minutes and it could start
counting because there might be still
some more critical decisions ahead and
Bishop E1 from a practical perspective
great choice by Yan
I think it's it's a smart way to
approach the rapid games which is that
you prepare some positional line and
then you you don't mix it up you play it
twice so that you don't have to keep too
much in your head in terms of you know
positions that you have to remember or
positions that you have to try to you
know understand well or
you know all the things that come with
preparation
so instead of Queen a display we
mentioned this move B3 looks like The
Logical response otherwise I don't think
whites play makes any sense without B3
and after B3
the question is
yeah just like simply loud Knight takes
A4 play some C5 Knight C6
the idea there being that the bishop D1
is a poor piece so white gained a
structural Advantage but the cost of it
was the visual B1 being at least
temporarily rather poor or is there some
kind of sharp Rook to before stuff which
I don't believe at all but
yeah right before Bishop D2 I don't
think it makes any sense for black so
this we can discard I think E3 C5 Knight
A4 Knight C6 followed by Knight to D4
ideas
is what thing you might have in mind and
now C3 is so ugly so C3 is necessary but
Bobby are you believing in this I mean
both sides of structural damage I prefer
White's position just because White's
play is is more clear-cut Bishop C2 and
I'd be two Knight C4
uh black has two like I wouldn't mind
black position very much because black
only has one real weakness
and even that a pawn it's not like a
huge weakness like you can play A5 and
support on A5 there but still I slightly
prefer wise position
and he did play B3 so we've seen that
and Tanya we hear Fabi he would prefer
to play that uh with white I'm thinking
maybe black isn't so bad there do you
think that Ding will he Surprises with
Queen e you think he'll surprise us with
something else in this move
well this is a Absolutely Fresh position
and Bishop B1 is a new idea in this
position that has been found by team Yan
perhaps in some other similar setups
there should be one with followed up by
B3 is an option but not in this
particular setup and this particular
move order so definitely something that
is a great practical Choice B3 I think
given the clock situation the fact that
this is the final game and these lines
that we're looking at which are slow
Improvement of that bishop and B1 would
definitely pick white here any day of
the week especially if things starts to
burn the clock even more it feels like
every move is going to be a question
that they need to answer starting from
right now how does he continue There is
pressure on A4 why it's got simple moves
right Knight A4 coming up big decision
what do you do with the c Pawn do you go
all the way to C5 if you try to get the
D5 break in at some point where is
Black's activity and all these questions
the answers to them it's going to cost
ding time Robert it's gonna cost him a
lot of time and this could turn to
pretty nasty so definitely picking white
right now very impressive little idea
there with Bishop B1
I'm with you I mean time is important
especially in Rapid chess when you don't
start with that much but Jan has more
time than he began with ding is the one
who spent about five minutes and as Fabi
is saying that there are gonna be a
long-term issue for black on the A6
Square The Rook on A1 is developed in
place so for everybody you know who's
tuning in watching uh this action unfold
I mean this could be a situation where
dink finds himself in trouble so Fabi
let's actually dive in let's do what
ding is doing let's calculate what moves
is he thinking about right here he can
bring his Knight back to C6 we talked
about C5 as well what do you think he's
gonna go for
I think C5 should be played
I mean yeah it's it's just I mean it's
not really about calculating you just
put your opponent C5 and the reason you
do so is because afterward plays Knight
A4 and potentially C3 you want to make
sure that it's not easy for white to
achieve D4 or B4
so you're kind of fixing the B Pawn as a
bit of a weakness uh you're making sure
white can't expand in the center without
allowing a lot of Trades and potentially
Mutual weaknesses in case of that
Knight A4 is is going to be the move
sometimes like you you
see a bunch of moves are just gonna be
played and then
um I think we kind of saw this line up
to C3 and here is the question this is
where the real um decision for black is
I guess you can still plague and move
like Bishop to E6 like you can make a
few more kind of natural moves without
and does black want to achieve some kind
of F5 you can maybe play Knight to D7
here try to follow it up with F5
uh then the issue is you might be in
time but you might
you have to worry about that a pawn
right Knight to P2 followed by Knight C4
is coming so you have to deal with the
weakness of the a pawn which might cost
you a bit of time that could potentially
be relevant if you're trying to play
some very concrete F5 stuff but F5 is
really coming to mind as a viable idea
for black and then the queen on E8 is
actually beautifully placed because it
comes to G6
potentially attacks the H3 Pawn with the
bishop takes H3 idea
that's where I would be thinking if I
was
in dangerous shoes that's the direction
I'll be looking at
so Tanya you asked the question Fabi
just answered it for us where is ding's
play going to come from maybe a
potential F5 strike and that does make
sense given the current Pawn structure
where black has these pawns on dark
squares giving up control over D5 at
least you can't control it with a pawn
but F5 striking this way that could be
in the card so Tony what do you think
how ambitious might ding become in this
game
he does continue to play pretty fast he
takes on A4 and ding falls back with
that Knight to C6 so also eyeing a
potential jump to D4 now Robert you gave
a shout out to everyone who was joining
us and I think everyone who is just
joining us the first question on their
mind would be one second they're gonna
do a double take what is that Bishop
doing on B1 and let's just when arrows
just just bring out the little Bishop
dance that we've seen with this light
Squad Bishop it first arrived on B5 all
the way from F1 A4 on its way back to B3
did a little shuffle dance to A2 and
then finally finding itself back on B1
all done voluntarily by Jana palmnessi
this is a fantastic idea and once again
ding he doesn't immediately go for the
plans that we were looking at well the
bishop is still on D7 Bishop E6 Knight
t7 F5 definitely in the air especially
when you how multi-purpose it is it
suddenly makes a lot of sense to have
that Queen on E8 the ding first takes
care of the queen side weakness he makes
the movie A5 and as long as the Knight
is on C6 that pawn is safe meanwhile
white hasn't managed to push C3 yet and
Robert to answer your question I was
thinking c3d4 will be the kind of stuff
that Yan wants to get into this position
you want to try to find a way to open up
your B1 Bishop with that Knight on C3
not going to be easy to achieve that
maybe bishop G5 try to get control of
the D5 Square
maybe but Bobby this bishop on B1 like
C3 was a multi-purpose move he's playing
without a piece and if I'm remembering
correctly there was a vidit Gujarati
game at some point with like a similar
Bishop it just it was buried it never
got out and this bishop was terrible
like it is behind your own wall of Pawns
I don't like the way Jan is playing this
do you see something that maybe I don't
I know the game you're talking about it
was from an archangel
variation it was from the World Cup in
2021 I think yeah so is there a barely
maybe yeah that's right yeah I I didn't
like think of that game but because it's
a completely different opening the
bishop on C5 it's like a knight takes E5
line but uh but yeah that's that's a
really nice spot because uh I think this
is a classic case of Beyond not taking
care of his Bishop I mean he's he's left
his Bishop Behind Bars
and he could have freed it immediately
with C3 and Knight to B2 but now it's
like you're going to have to take
another few moves to potentially get
that Bishop out
all I can say is take care of your
Bishop don't
leave it stuck there
and yeah
and it's after Bishop to E6 I think
I think we might see Knight to C4 here
and why would be happy to see it in
exchange there you know get some light
Square control
but after an ic4 black is certainly not
obligated to capture that and it's not
even it's not even a threat right just
to put this on the board Knight C4 if I
make sum of like H6 and you take on A5
can I play Rook 8 and
you down the a file yeah it's not you're
not even threading and I take I thought
you were but you're not even threatening
Knight takes A5
so I will okay why what's the long term
get Knight e2c3 and I think
I think that's the only idea like you
need to get this bishop out
Knight c492 C3 Bishop C2 yeah that's not
that's a plan at least
you could have done that before so he
does play Knight C4 and I'm curious how
ding will continue so if Knight takes A5
isn't a threat we may see this F5
variation and Tanya this type of
position normally I would say it's in
yon Style
ding just decided to strike with D5 got
a quick question right they're playing
too quickly for me to even finish my
question but now I will ask you Black's
Pawn structure is ugly but that Bishop
B1 is even uglier oh a big mistake
apparently wow um wait couldn't you have
taken on D5 and I know we said you
couldn't take that pawn but could you
have taken that pawn I'm just
I learned I learned from you Tanya we if
you can take a pond just take it I think
that's actually a good strategy for for
most well I don't want to give bad
advice to the to the viewers but what
was wrong with 95 and Knight takes A5 I
don't get it well this is a question
mark so let's look into that and and
Tanya well taking a Pawn on A5 there
might still be this Rook 8 issue now
yeah but I thought Bishop to D2 how do
you keep up the pressure on this
[Music]
Knight takes A5
and if I don't think say five take take
Queen to A8
man Fabi doesn't let me ask any
questions because he's seen two I love
everything of tactics because he saves
me from answering those questions Robert
that is the ultimate motive
for that
once again I think this game
still stuck there with absolutely no
future inside and that Bishop is crying
for help and Yan needs to find a way to
actually get that c Pawn moving to find
itself on an open Diagon otherwise the
bishop will be asking Yan and darling
Yan that what was this plan Love the Way
You Lie Ian
I'm sorry I was thinking about that for
a while had to get that in we will move
on immediately because Bishop D2 has
been branded as with a question mark on
the board why is this so bad is what I'm
trying to understand because the knight
from C3 wants to land on e4 and now
you're threatening to pick up the A5
Pawn so why is this a bad move
I just think the A5 Pawn Isn't So
relevant and Fabi coming up with amazing
tactical sequences and Knight takes C3
played by ding Bishop takes back hitting
two different pawns and Dink takes that
Knight look at this this is a decision
he wouldn't normally make giving up his
Bishop for a night but is that really a
bishop I can't call it a pawn because
you can't have a pawn the first rank
Bobby do you like this decision from
ding just now I was thinking about it it
looked really natural to me because you
yeah you're basically leaving the bishop
on B1 at least temporarily as just a
very bad piece so the more pieces that
are exchanged you simplified position
but also structurally this is this is a
good outcome right whichever way white
takes I think probably DC4 is the way to
take so that you have
he takes BC I'm I'm a bit surprised but
okay
maybe DC maybe it's the right decision
to take BC but
he wants to play Bishop D2 followed by
C3 followed by Bishop C2
it's a terrible Bishop but if it gets
free then Black's position
is worse so
now we'll see ding's idea here he
probably just intuitively thought that
black was okay here which is true but
maybe black was already getting better
at some point after Bishop D2
and it wasn't an easy moment to see like
how it's such a strategically complex
position that
it wasn't easy for black to find the
right way there
but they hear like root A8 is very
logical right Rook to a it can't be a
bad move
Bishop Bishop d8 I was going to ask you
can you start throwing your pawns
forward that is exactly what I was gonna
ask you because you mentioned the idea
of F5 before there's not even a pawn in
E4 so why not gain space on the king
side
he probably wants to
to engineer some Pawn pushes but under
safer circumstances so I'm seeing some
Bishop C7 followed by E4 ideas in the
air the bishop will I the king side
it'll it'll create some tactical
possibilities involving E4
Bishop G2 has played Bishop C7 super
logical and then C3
and yeah White's Bishop even if it gets
out it's kind of it's always a bad piece
isn't it at this point even if it gets
to A4 then it Still Remains a bad piece
there
well the bishop is not good but let me
tell you a big question right now is is
John playing too quickly it seems like
the evaluation bar has settled back in
the center which means that the last
couple moves have favored him but he's
playing really quickly and I feel like
the position is quite tricky considering
there's a bishop still on B1
still on D3 uh Bishop landing on A4 will
be a reverse dance with Bishop A2 Bishop
B3 Bishop A4 don't believe that that's
gonna happen not so many moves with this
light Squad Bishop Bobby the plan that
you're mentioning with this E4 break
lining up on the B8 H2 diagonal with the
queen and a bishop battery that could
actually potentially be super dangerous
for white and white has to counter it
now either you do that with the move C3
to make sure that when the queen comes
on E5 the A1 Rook is an attack or a move
like rookie one but there are definitely
ideas in the air and ding does set it up
immediately responds with the move C3 so
now after E4 are you gonna capture the
pawn or will you build the pressure with
Rook to E1
I'd probably capture just the general
principle that uh if you don't capture
it now you might regret it when you
can't capture it later
and E4 rookie one invites you know Queen
to E5 then you can maybe play F4 that
follow up with taking but E4 rookie one
also invites F5 ideas
um and even Pawn stocks are not out of
the question but
what's wrong with DTX E4 because I was
considering this Palm suck and I'm not
seeing exactly why it's so beneficial
for black after d take C4 here
you want to put your knight on E5 that
is what I had in mind earlier but I see
the eval Bar says White's doing fine but
maybe Knight E5 is their compensation
here yeah certainly there's compensation
but after Queen to E2
if you get Kickback with F4 then the
compensation might start to evaporate
he first prepares it he makes a move F5
yeah E4 is an idea for sure it's it's
definitely on the cards
If This Were A Blitz game I would say
black wins this position a high
percentage of the time but it is rapid
despite the fact that John is playing so
quickly but we have so many ideas in
this E4 maybe even F4 at some moment
because F3 would be a big threat to open
up your king I know that gives white the
light Square so you have to time it well
but there could be a position where you
play F4 and E4 and Knight E5 and then
you just take control over the king side
this is a bad piece and I actually want
to put this on the board just to show
everybody what that could look like is
let's say it makes them move like here
and I play E4 and I go F4 and I'm just
going to make a few random moves when
you yes F3 is crushing but even without
F3 if I put a knight on E5 this bishop
is terrible and I may have F3 and if you
just stop it with F3 of your own at some
point the dark squares are vulnerable
there could be a rook lift swinging to
the king side this would be a serious
attack that white may not be prepared to
withstand so I'm just looking at E4 and
F4 a thematic type of Pawn sacrifice to
free up that E5 Square Tanya that was
one of your ideas
I love it I love of seeing F5 on the
board what you're pointing out not just
the E4 Bond sacrifice but coupled with
that F Pawn advancing down the board to
create more weaknesses on the king side
you asked this question would you rather
be white or black a couple of moves ago
and while at that point I think the
answer was white now anyone any day of
the week any day of the year would pick
black in this situation even though ding
is down by four minutes just compare the
pieces the flexibility the space the
control in the center and the attacking
possibilities it just feels like a
position that is easier for ding to play
and there are critical problems and
practical problems that Yan has to deal
with
before
yeah I think that we shouldn't
underestimate though the Strategic risk
that black might
might have in these positions if White's
Bishop gets active there is a lot of
weak squares and a lot of weak Pawns
and yeah we can imagine Bishop on D5
probably white has a huge advantage or
sufficient one would be one is very far
from
uh the sort of animal it would be on D5
and
I think that Black's play will be based
on some concrete stuff involving E4 and
White's play will be based on countering
that and also trying to get the bishop
active so I like to move Bishop C2 here
I think the variation that you uh
demonstrated with the E4 D takes E4 F4
is a is quite interesting and important
because maybe white can play E5 here and
this is why like the position is more
about the activity of the bishop I think
I would consider this move at least even
if it's not uh let's say 100 the best
one
the positions about the activity of the
bishop more so than the material but
something like this is really really
logical for both sides you know this on
sacrifice is very thematic E4 and F4 and
something like E5 is also very thematic
trying to get the bishop active but
maybe bishop to A4 was was a better
choice
it's a complex position the bar didn't
really react to E5 which means it's a
great practical try at the very least
because Bishop A4 it works as well but I
feel like allowing F3 can be really
scary with this queen coming over here I
would be too scared to play I like E5
getting activity of your own so that's
fabi's Instinct there and we keep
talking about this these super strong
players they would rather be if they're
up a pawn they'd rather give it back
then sit passively they want to get
activity of their own so oh sorry I
clicked the wrong spot but after F5 E4
is a threat but maybe it's not a
game-ending threat and that could give
Yan the time to play Bishop to C2 and if
he can Bishop out to A4
I think he's considering these lines
and it's very sharp uh really sharp
stuff because you take risks with white
if if black could
please Rook to E1
okay so he's preparing against E4
um
still consider it although it looks like
a much worse version
but black can also play Queen to G6
maybe comes to mind as a
as a possible move
and then like there's some tactics for
example Queen G6
I just just play the move Queen to F3 I
want to demonstrate a little tactic you
see it right E4 he takes E4 okay
probably 95 is crushing but there's also
Queen to D6 ideas I'm not even sure I
think 95 is the real reason here
okay Queen D6 is also
um
for sure white does not want to put the
queen on the vulnerable square like F3
but there's some Queen G6 Queen D6 ideas
which is what I was hoping to highlight
that's what I wanted to highlight as
well so when you ask me the question I
was very well prepared this queen on D6
lined with the bishop could be
devastating and he plays Rook d8 first
and can hardly fault him for that move
because it does stare down at a
vulnerable Pawn that will need The
Bishop's defense so it preemptively
stops the bishop coming to A4 because
you will need to protect this pawn and
this Rook can join the party at some
point with a rook lift black has quite a
deal of flexibility and this a pawn it's
well defended so black pieces can start
all of them focusing on the king side
Tanya that white King on G1 doesn't have
too many Defenders I'm starting to be
very concerned for Yonder promise with
E4 on the horizon
E4 just has so much more fuel because
you can imagine that D file opening up
with the queen on D1 being x-rayed so
move like Bishop E3 will definitely be
met by E4 you don't care about that C5
Pawn you're creating your central
activity and I'm just thinking these
ideas that you were talking about
getting that Bishop back to A4 Bishop C2
Bishop A4 you need to include that
Bishop you need to find a way to get it
back into the game is it psychologically
difficult for Yan I mean we saw the
parts that the bishop took to get to B1
is there something from a human
perspective that stops you from making
this move Bishop C2 and all the way back
to A4 when you've done this little
Bishop Dance Yourself is that a
difficult Factor here Fabi
I don't think he likes his position for
sure and a large in large part because
that Bishop
on B1 is so terrible and just not
getting into the game
we saw there was some strategic risk
with putting your Bishop there right it
has a very clear point or it had a very
clear point to count on the structural
advantage and positional long-term
strategic factors that white might have
but right now it's not looking like
those factors are as important as the
very concrete nature of you know black
just has better pieces I mean
um that Bishop on D5 we we would be
talking about you know why taking over
this position the bishop on B1 is just
not performing much of a duty and I'm
also struggling to see a move for white
here uh because things like
I'm wondering if you can play Bishop to
E3 I'm terrified to do it
and Rook A2
also it's also logical to get the Rook
considered offense
because Italian's point that at E4 The
Rook on d8 was going to barrel down the
D file so you're preemptively defending
this bishop but I mean Fabi I have to
ask you this feels like a classical
chess opening but we're playing rapid
and the position just seems so much
easier for black to play this bishop on
B1 it's just a defensive piece this Rook
a defensive piece white has no control
over most of the board and black is
storming forward
yeah I like Black's position a lot I'm
still thinking about Queen G6 E4 is also
very tempting at this particular moment
but after D4 I'm not really I mean black
and sack of the Palm with F4 but I think
white is really going to go for that E5
idea
and that's a critical position to check
because if black gets time for 95 here I
just think that it it turns like really
really bad for white
uh and you just can't allow that so E5
and still black plays Knight takes C5
here
I'm not seeing like a huge downside to
this I think yeah white can get Bishop
before D5 in
but instead didn't goes for Queen G6
which we mentioned also very natural
idea
now though E4 and queen D6 is no longer
really a threat because bish1 D2 is
defended by The Rook
so white can
has some Freedom let's say queen to E2
is a very natural move here
I think to prepare like maybe F3
but F3 is so scary because you weaken
your dark squares so what is White's
idea
let's see he went Queen E2 so he did
step up with his Queen it was really
natural to do this but I don't know if I
like to move
can we just do this and play E4 how are
you gonna stop me
good good question uh Queen D6
um G3 I mean not thrilled to thrilled
about that but
then E4 is met by Bishop F4 okay we're
getting somewhere with white there so
maybe G3 is not the end of the world
Tanya you're gonna have to help me out
here Queen D6 G3 could you ever imagine
it's a great move apparently but could
you ever imagine playing a position like
this as white
well I think you might be forced to go
G3 right the threat that you pointed out
with E4 and the queen coming to H2
that's a Checkmate Into You Gotta block
that diagonal so even though it's not a
happy decision it might be the only way
to go now E4 Bishop F4 solves all your
problems but the thing that would really
terrify me playing white this position
if G3 was on the board is the other Pawn
advancing done what happens after F4 I'm
targeting your G3 Pawn are you ever
gonna pick up that pawn on F4 and open
up the G5 happy to go into that are you
going to just let me pass back with F3
or perhaps even take the G3 pawn and
strike in the center with E4 so many
ideas I feel that after a move like G3
F4 would be something that would be very
worrying and again we keep pointing it
out white is well practically playing
down a piece and all of Black's pieces
are ideally placed for the attack all of
Black's forces are developed they're in
the center there's a lot of coordination
and once again the Strategic points that
you mentioned if the bishop wasn't E5 he
would be singing a completely different
tune with that bishop and B1 and a
potential attack we see the clock
situation as well about a two minute
deficit I still think that a stingler
and in driving seat and queen D6 would
be a nice choice and it has been made
Queen D6 E4 is a big idea again G3 is
that really the only move and if yes
what happens after F4 that's a great
question I think G3 is forced at this
point you cannot allow the queen and
Bishop to stare at H2 for a moment
longer and G3 F4 I'm wondering Bobby so
I am gonna ask you this because F4 is
very committal you give up the light
squares permanently and guess what white
does have a light Square Bishop so later
in the game this could be an idea that
backfires so is black better off
pressing immediately or slowing down
with some kind of Rook doubling on the f
file or something of that nature
F4 is not the move I would think of
because after Queen E4 there's a D4
threat but maybe Queen to H6 there is
the idea
uh but F4
it just doesn't really look very natural
after Queen E4 like you you're not
getting E4 anytime soon
D4 is a big threat you can play Queen H6
that's true
but uh
I mean white has white definitely has a
quite a big Choice here I mean you can
you can even play King G2
I mean if you just want like a simple
simple way of playing so I I don't
really see this as I don't see Black's
next move especially
um
you can maybe maneuver the knight from
E7 to F5 to try to it's very committal
this whole thing with black like super
super committal and super risky for
black to go for this but maybe you can
get the Knight to F5 and start to
to play there might be some concrete
sacrifices at some point I wouldn't play
at four
um
yeah that I would I would not play for
it you know who agreed with you I think
agrees with you it goes rookie eight
English this is what I like he wants to
play E4
seems pretty natural not immediately but
at some point at some point you also
have F4 in your back pocket so you
haven't lost your ability to push either
of your pawns or keeping maximum
flexibility and what about these pieces
Tony we've been harping on this bishop I
know it's a really bad piece The Rook on
A2 it's protecting along the second rank
I guess how do we activate those Queen
side pieces they're really not helping
that much and White's pieces just look
uncoordinated
and now Bishop C2 would definitely be
met by E4 right because you're not only
targeting the D3 Pawn you're not only
eyeing that Queen on E2 but also it's so
hard to imagine why it actually picking
up that E4 Pawn so Bishop C2 E4 are
ideas that black is looking into with
the attack following up but Bishop C2 E4
I do see the still Bishop F4 so maybe
it's possible Robert the only way to get
that Bishop into the game feels like A4
is the square and now that black has
stepped away from the d-line and no
pressure on D2 rookie had played is this
the moment that you've got to get Bishop
C2 in it looks like playing with fire
he doesn't care if he doesn't care about
that Bishop he plays Queen to F3
Ayan is Jan is a provocative provocative
player okay he's he's really provoking
E4 but he just wants to take
and he's saying that
let's say E4 detect C4 f f takes C4
because now F4 is no longer an option my
queen will move
um let's say to G4 if I'm not blundering
uh no I'm blundering 95 there so
so let's put it back on E2
or wait can I actually can I go to G2
maybe that's maybe that's the point
um uh that's that's very harmonious the
G3 and queen G2 and Bishop takes E4
comes and he's saying for all your
activity all you did was give me on and
the bishop becomes alive on B1 right no
longer about it it's happening though
so ding okay so Knight to E5 here must
be the idea for black yeah you simply
have to include this Intermezzo you're
not taking back as we showed you Queen
G2 white will regain this pawn and the
bishop is alive but after Knight E5 what
happens if Queen G2 then
probably Knight takes C4 capture
it's messy but it's clear white is
better after Bishop F4 I mean the only
question is how much better but why no
longer has any risk because the position
opened up the once poor Bishop on B1 it
was activated by Lex uh fans
so why didn't really have to do anything
to maneuver it
so after 95 Queen G2
is their Knight to D3 I want now I want
to get rid of that Bishop
wow Fabi is saying let's just ignore all
the pawn captures go in like this and
all the evil Bar says that Black's not
doing too badly right to take here
doesn't seem like White's in any real
Danger
no you can even take on F5 I think
I don't see the Tactical problem like
rookie one Bishop B1 Queen B1 is met by
rookie two this is kind of a
semi-important line you can even throw a
queen D5 check and if you deem it
necessary but
okay still there's some danger like long
term the a pawn is a really dangerous
Pawn because
your points while taking it okay D1
that's much better in the check yeah
yeah but the so the thing is the the A5
Pawn is very dangerous if white C3 and
C4 Pawn stay on the board because the C3
Pawn actually limits White's Bishop from
being able to Aid in the defense of that
pawn into men games for example if all
the queens and Rooks were traded off the
board
and obviously this is super far from the
current position on the board so
um but something like that could long
term become a factor that the a pawn is
an asset I like this 95 Knight D3
as
like the best try that black
will have in a position
pandemonium that's what this position is
and diggingly right down on the clock so
a ton of we haven't focused so much on
the clock in this game just because it
has been so many tactics available to
this decides but suddenly I'm worried
about ding yeah he had a better position
he decided to strike with E4 but after
sacrificing a pawn he hasn't delivered
the follow-up
I'm just amazed how now we're talking
about trying to get rid of that B1
Bishop because potentially it could get
so strong and suddenly that move Rook A2
starts making sense because in so many
lines not only does it defend that D2
Bishop but it can easily transfer to the
center of the board come to E2 all the
way from A2 just finding so much Harmony
so just this position practically
perhaps ding just rushed with the
central break E4 he did everything right
right before that he brings the Rooks to
the right spot the queen and the bishop
lined up and I think the tension was
just so high he decided to go for E4 if
he would have recaptured the pawn the
queen G2 idea looked really strong he
goes for the other one with Knight E5
still expecting the queen to fall back
to G2 and now I just want to point out
that in that position if you take on C4
the earlier option that you were looking
at I think that could lead to a lot of
problem for black after Knight C4 Bishop
F4 white trades the dark Squad Bishop
slides that Rook from A2 to E2 and we
can just do this with arrows Robert we
don't even need to show it the point
that I want to make is that suddenly the
A2 diagonal opens up and black doesn't
have a light squared Bishop to challenge
it so Knight C4 would be a bad idea by
the way Queen G2 on the board so we're
going to see if ding does find the way
forward with Knight D3 and realizes that
it's time in fact to now neutralize the
B1 bishop and Fabi is this all because I
think perhaps rushed just a little bit
with the move E4
yeah maybe but it's such a complex
position it's really hard to say I I'm
looking at this 93 and I'm thinking Rook
E3 is also an option
and it's a mess I can't really
calculate it fully
um or actually no I think I see the
answer so 93 rookie three maybe we can
see one
I I don't think it's like I mean 901
might like work no it doesn't work like
this queen have fun yeah
yeah it doesn't work but F takes E4
Rook takes E4 and I was thinking this
might be good but I think Rook takes up
two is the end oh no it's not no
no it's not because there's Queen D5
check after rookie 8 King F7
rookie king of seven I think Queen D5 is
actually important otherwise maybe it's
really good
saving the year on King by trading off
the Queens at the end of this white is
in good shape because the Knight is
loose on D3 well that is a crazy
variation I was joking with Knight C1
sorry Fabi to suggest bad moves to make
you a worse chess player but these lines
there's so many sharp ones and I
wouldn't be surprised if ding looks at
all this oh my position is rough let me
just slide my king into the corner
because so many of White's ideas rely on
the fact that this king gets in check so
is King h8 an additional option here
engage it I wouldn't consider this move
but
but if Bishop F4 what did you
achieve like it's really high
responsibility black could just be
losing I mean just you know you're down
material and two Bishops in open
position if you don't find something
concrete I I think he's gonna go for a
concrete approach no no
um waiting moves in this position
yeah maybe you can get changed as a
brilliant seat I know I forgot about
Bishop before I was thinking you would
take on F5 and then I would take on C4
and finally the black pieces are flowing
but Bishop F4 seems to stop uh black in
his tracks and it won't work out
like I'm just so interested in this
Knight D3 Rook E3 fv4 variation I know
it might never happen
but I'm like
Knight D3 comes to mind and rookie three
is definitely a critical move it might
be not a good move but it's it's
definitely a critical move
so how should black respond here I think
fe4 should be the move right
Rook takes E4 and
uh
how are you how are you answering this
like if you take Knight takes F2 rookie
a white seems to be winning a piece
Rook takes up two loses rookie Four
Queens four Knight takes up two allows
Queen H7 with devastating attack most
likely
uh Bishop G6 Bishop G5 some something
bad happens to you here
there's a miracle saved somewhere in
this position
if it's that simple
um
not quite
it looks Rook B8 and put pressure on the
B1 bishop and also F2 is hanging forcing
you to trade on D3 to trade you're happy
with yes
yeah
that's just the right way
wow that is a really difficult move you
know we exhausted all possibilities and
Rook B8 there but Knight D3 is played so
that variation could be extremely
important and Tanya with the full board
awareness we are so concentrated on this
side of the board with attacking
possibilities uh we're looking at ways
for white to go after this black king
maybe this queen checking on D5 but in
this event of Rook E3 you can just take
on e4 and bring that Rook to ba that's a
really excellent find if diggling around
spots that he may be out of the woods
it's definitely a findable move although
it's a difficult one because you're
really concentrated on something
involving F2
but rookie 3 is not forced I mean white
Beyond has a choice here it's not an
easy choice I think Bishop takes C3 is
the obvious move right you could play
that and you know it's probably not a
bad one and you take on F5 and looks uh
like probably white has some pressure
but I think he would actually be loath
to give up the D3 the bishop on D3
um rather the official V1 and traded on
D3 because end games become dangerous
just the a pawn like that Bishop is a
very important controller of that a pawn
in in some variations down the road
and I know that it sounds far away but I
really think it could be an important
factor in the position
and the bishop white starts with Bishop
that being said he he plays it so
there goes everything I said but I think
I think what you said it's those
marriage just because he decided to take
your point still stands it if the Rooks
come off the board especially that a
pawn is a password even with Brooks on
the board it could be a decoy of sorts
so we see a rook trade Queen takes C4
give me that c Pawn F5 may be able to be
captured later so are we seeing a
position that with all these trades
liquidation are the chances most likely
that this game ends in a dare I say draw
well dry isn't bad because then we get
to see Blitz right
I'm surprised that I the bar is even
like a little bit of White's favorite
must be for some concrete reason because
physically speaking black has a past
apron black is getting Rook takes F5 and
the bishop 21 remains a pretty poor
piece and I don't see the downside of
Rook takes a five there is some kind of
queen C6 maybe but I think Rook F7
covers all the threats from what I
of I think it does
so why is white even like why is white
not worse here is my question because
the a pawn is a more important one than
White's F1 right if we're talking about
which extra Pawn each side has in the
position in the end game you know
potentially white could be in danger
it would really depend if the bishop on
E1 becomes active
so Rook F5 I don't see the downside of
this move I also don't see why you would
not take it
although I guess you're not forced to
you might have for example Bishop Bishop
E5 or something like this might be an
option but I would say unless you
see a problem take the pawn
another Rook F5 on the board and as
you're pointing out the a pawn
definitely stronger than the F2 pawn and
we were talking about the light Squad
Bishop being a problem in Yan's position
now it's the dark Squad Bishop he still
needs a couple of moves to make it
active and if you just compare each of
the pieces on the board it's clear that
suddenly ding feels like the one who is
who has more activity the queen on C4
The Rook on F5 the bishop on C7 the one
idea that I do see for an active piece
for white is the queen on G2 can that
start jumping into B7 to create some
direct threats against that bishop and
C7
well there might be tactics there right
because there might be look at that
Bishop G3 yeah I was looking at those
two wow but I think Bishop G3 white can
play Rook takes A5
maybe maybe no
yeah
that's so scary for white to get into
especially three rookies you could also
take on G3 it might just be a drop Rook
F1 or queen F1 oh sorry I think I was
gonna show that the queen gets back to
G2 otherwise it's Checkmate but the
queen can't come back on the yoyo string
so that wouldn't work but Rook F1 check
Rook takes E1 and black is temporarily
up upon but
yeah why what will win the even coupons
but will it'll be a Perpetual check in
the end Queen D5 King to f8 yeah I can
start taking pawns if you want to just
give all the checks as you're saying you
see I learned I learned not to play
kingage
I'm getting better as a player
throughout this commentary no back rank
check man okay I see you I didn't put it
together but you did avoid a background
Checkmate Bishop B2 I think that's a
great decision uh by Jan he's just
trying to stabilize at this point and
black still has this outside pass Pawn
so ding is down the clock but he has
that outside passer although white king
is safer there are three Pawns in front
of the white king and only two in front
of black so Tanya do we think that this
is going to be a drawer is there some
life left in the position
I like what a ding has done he just
created a lift for his own King so that
the king can feel itself safe on eight
seven away from any ideas of a potential
Perpetual in similar lines that we saw
and still there is a C3 weakness so the
Bishop from D2 can't really go to E3
can't start getting active uh and what
you pointed out after a queen B7
potential move Bishop G3 sacrifices but
now with that Rook on A1 which is the
other sneaky stuff that I'm seeing the
F1 square is under control so Bishop
takes G3 just doesn't work because F1
is very well guarded he doesn't go Queen
B7 he starts with the move Queen C6 but
there is some activity for white now
so Rook to F7 or or you can play yeah
everything Rook F7 looks
you can also play
you know seven but
you can also play Queen D5 right that's
that's another option as well
that seems to be actually the easiest
way to liquid I don't think so because
Queen C7 Queen D2 Queen C8 after Rook of
Fate you take on C5 you actually collect
a super important Pawn just to quickly
show Queen C8 you're attacking the rook
and the king the only way to save The
Rook is rook f8 and queen takes C5 and
yet the eval bar is on phased despite
the fact that white just stole a pawn A4
is the draw I guess
ah you can't take because Queen D1 check
and they play Queen C4 trying to pick up
this Pawn you can't do that very easily
with F2 under attack so black has enough
compensation in the form of that pass
Pawn it's a decoy it distracts White's
Pieces away from the squares that needs
to defend but
that's cutting it a little bit close and
I think that at this point both players
they're not gonna be too unhappy about
making a draw because ding was much
better after that Bishop was buried on
B1 then things start to get a little
shaky you could tell when he paused he
wasn't sure about the dynamic play and
he is now in a position where it is
equal though he is only four minutes
left I just want him uh you know if
you're a fan of dingley run you'd want
him to play this quickly you want him to
avoid too much time travel despite the
fact they have a 10 second increment
yeah I think I underestimated a little
bit uh White's position
because it feels like yeah your king is
just a bit more safe and once that
Bishop gets to E3 it's actually a really
really nice piece
so somehow Black's Bishop being a little
bit loose not having
um like a perfectly
safe Square to go to feels like white is
definitely pressing this I mean we saw
Queen D5 as objectively a draw but
but yeah Rook F7 was the most natural
move and
your white can play Rook to E1 very
logical
maybe just like you can play it
automatically because how bad how can
this move be bad
can't yeah white is pressing a bit
King safety it's Paramount so this Rook
coming to E1 over the E8 the a pawn
isn't fast enough if you allow this Rook
to get up to E8 you could see your king
in some pretty big dangers the queen
will join in on the action so Yanni's
about to grab that Rook Tanya I feel
like for Jan he should play these moves
relatively quickly to try to put more
pressure on the clock considering ding
has under four minutes remaining
when I was a six minute Edge and that's
a huge Competitive Edge in a rapid game
even with 10 second increment it it is
something that is enough in a normal
simple standard position where the
pieces have been traded off and there
are no attacks against the king but here
it's still far to be far from there so I
completely agree with you but Yan also
has to watch out there are threats that
Ding has as well sacrifices on G3 a
potential queen move from C4 to D3
putting pressure on the bishop Jan's
Bond structure pieces do feel a bit
loose so he perhaps can't rush with
moves rookie won great suggestion great
call there by Fabi just centralizing the
room the funding threatening rookie and
he plays King 287 so sidestepping and he
checks for now yeah very logical I
thought also Queen D3 was maybe a decent
move
but perhaps black has
yeah just a very solid position after
King H7 followed by Queen D3 you want to
get that Bishop off D2 so that you can
take C3
white can enter an end game
I know I said end games are
are bad but I think in this case the
like Queen E4 trade and then put the
Rook on one of those squares and white
actually controls the apron very very
comfortably
and it's certainly but it's probably a
draw I mean
I'd I'd maybe slightly prefer white but
it's almost certainly a draw there
and we were looking at rookie eight
check but it's no longer check so do not
play this move we saw ideas Bishop takes
G3 now it would really work so you need
your Rook on the first rank do not lift
that rook and blunder Bishop takes G3
that would not be the way you would want
to end this world championship because
the reminder to everybody this is the
fourth and final game of the first
tiebreaker four games of Rapid so if
somebody wins right now the match is
over we will have a new world champion
so the players they're trying to keep
the equality they do not want to lose
now and neither player wants to lose
ever but if this game is a drug we will
head on over to Blitz tie breaks
we're heading to Blitz cyborgs I don't
see uh ding losing this one it looks
like he has a pretty stable position
and
Jan could make any number of moves here
you could play King G2 for example I
mean like you have a wide Choice it's on
a position where things are happening
super fast but he might not head for the
end game too I would really consider
Queen E4 here
with the knowledge that it's almost
certainly a very drawish end game but
still
could be a strength could be weakness
it's hard to tell and black white king
is a bit closer to getting to Center
potentially getting to some very
influential squares like D3 and so on
but Jan is considering
senses that he knows he's up on the
clock and if he can find a way to keep
the Queens on the board try to create
some ideas he's definitely going to try
and push it is the final rapid game but
I think a draw as you said is the most
likely result because just simply the
position that Ding has a potential
attack on F2 but potential sacrifices on
G3 enough counter play so shouldn't be
that hard for ding to hold guys it looks
like we will be heading to a blitz
playoff but they're still still time for
that Jana publishing now with a
three-minute advantage on the clock
Abby you were mentioning a queen trade
and that goes into a level balanced end
game but with the a passer he decides to
keep the Queens on the board makes the
move Bishop to E3 so he's threatening
the C5 Pawn
and potentially if white if black was to
take on C3 we might even see a Perpetual
check on the board
yeah I think this move is almost almost
a draw for intake C3 let's say queen E4
check
King to G8
Rook to C1 at some moment where I can
play or the black has Queen B4
uh or queen E5 I mean yeah it's very
very likely that we see a lot of Trades
even if white gets three against two
would still draw
Bishop D5 maybe it's like super precise
to play Bishop B5
If You're Gonna Take It on C3 just says
no I'll take it later that makes sense
to me all the trades that happen are
going to be good for black in terms of
you'll never lose and maybe if you trade
the queens and this Pawn survives black
could even be better
yeah I like this move it's saying I I
want to make it draw when I'm a little
bit better green takes C5 Queen C5
Bishop CI Bishop C3 for sure it's a
drone position
but if given a choice you'd probably
take black because black still has the
past a pawn and yeah white just has a
three against two which is not enough to
win even on its own
oh Queen to E8
okay so Bishop to F6 looks because
Bishop C3 Rook C1 a little bit scary
there a bunch of
hanging pieces and pins and stuff that
um I see a lot of tactics like Rook F3
Rook C3 you know you you could easily
lose this one
oh I'm gonna shut it real quick Queen
takes and queen E4 check his father's
idea check to the king check to The Rook
you are going to lose material and black
is in trouble so poof still tactics left
and that's what Yan is doing he is
playing for the clock right now he knows
the position should be balanced but the
black king is less safe than the white
king
so black and play Bishop F6 here very
logical
um one option or I think Bishop C3 Rook
C1 Rook F6 I didn't see the exact
refutation
as Bishop D2 there's a lot of like Queen
D4 ideas he goes for Bishop C3
no I think he saw that like Bishop D2 is
can be met by Queen D4
and uh and white probably can't afford
that
so that that might actually maybe it's a
Perpetual check there does black have
more or is it just a draw Bishop Z2
Queen D4 Bishop C3 Queen F2 King H1
Queen F3 King H2
I think
yeah
chess is a draw
sometimes when people are playing Super
accurately that happens to be the case
but if not for Bishop D2 which allows
the draw could we see a possibility that
John gets in a worse position he did
just give a pawn there is this outside
passer The Rook on F6 Queen on C4 very
active pieces so yance about to grab his
Queen he has Queen D7 so it looks like
he's trying to win this game but he
could be almost trying to lose to some
extent
yeah he's messing around a little bit
it's it's actually a very interesting
move because you don't allow Black's
Queen and Bishop to get free
oh but Queenie two you actually do he
probably didn't see that one it's a
brilliant move and actually that means
it's the
that allowed black to survive this game
I wasn't looking in that direction the
bishop is now under attack but he
defends it tactically that was a really
nice find so Tanya Queen E2 played ding
now down under two and a half minutes a
brilliancy but he's in some time trouble
extra Pawn whose chances do you like
right now
this is anyone's game it's so hard to
pick simply because of ding's clock
situation Queenie do a really nice
tactical find getting out of that pin
because of the check that you just
mentioned and at any point that black
wants to bail out in this game you can
just go Bishop D4 trade off those dark
Squad bishop and you're absolutely safe
in those positions because you'll always
have pressure on the F2 Pawn so Danger's
got this safe exit idea and maybe he can
start thinking about looking for more
now Yan is down well two pawns on the
queen side one pound one Pawn on the
board and that a pawn is definitely one
to watch out for it can start marching
down the board but first Jan needs to
come up with a move and there is a
direct tactic you just keep everything
centralized you just simply move your
queen or queen D5 King G2 and just say
show me the money
yeah I think Queen D5 is the right move
because you
I think crucially after Bishop D1 you
have some kind of queen takes C5
ideas to defend everything
especially one becomes a thread you you
maybe also just have we need four but
I'm not sure if White
oh yeah Queen C5 is super safe there so
we could just see
could see Bishop D4 here
a bit of a draw for there for sure black
decides to go for that
safest right Bishop E1 your pieces are
getting a little bit loose at the queen
takes C5 so if you don't want to risk
anything and at this point ding probably
doesn't have much in the way of winning
chances so Play Bishop D4 trade the
Bishops now the attack is uh gone before
it's parried before it could even get
going so I think Bishop D4 would be the
right choice and it looks like we are
heading to a draw so for the over 235
000 of you watching across the different
platforms we are likely to see a draw in
this game heading to Blitz tie breaks
for the world championship title
yeah I think I think it things shouldn't
get super ambitious here I mean maybe he
was feeling like Queen E2 he's already
better but after Queen E5 I think if you
don't play Bishop D4 you're going to be
risking
potentially especially with one minute
on your clock so
he's going for Bishop to B4 he got
ambitious
but do you have the option of just
giving a Perpetual now can you exit out
with Queen E4 and Queenie it
yeah I guess I guess what it's not
really risking right
I mean also
I guess Bishop C5 is
oh wait Bishop C5 Bishop E1 okay that's
that's actually no that would be really
dangerous for white so let's not do that
but that's a brilliant point that Bishop
takes C5 Bishop E1 you filled the square
that's a different type of tactic but
the C5 square is filled by the bishop
because the queen wanted to be there if
the bishop had gone E1 right away Queen
takes D5 would have been played so and
that's really nasty trap set up by
dingley run here yeah so maybe Queen E4
is the right response King to G8
uh
you can go back Queen D5 I mean it looks
like a draw yeah
but Jana hasn't been making the draw so
now he doesn't I think it would have
been very dangerous Tanya if he had not
decided on Queen E4 it was time it was
time for Yan to go for this idea and now
of course is the big question will he
repeat with either Queenie or queen D5
or at least offer a repetition for ding
I don't see a way for black to hide you
can go back with your Rook to f8 in case
there's a check on it then you will also
have a check on E6 yeah Anton three goes
Queen D5 so not even allowing that
option guys we're gonna see a a draw
here this will be a Perpetual you got
Blitz coming up that's what's gonna
happen this match is absolutely insane
and Bobby you were the one to call it
out first we will have a blitz playoff
yeah yep draw
that's what this rapid playoff has been
it's been super close and four draws
these players didn't really there
weren't even like huge chances right
they exchanged some slightly better
slightly worse positions maybe even
clearly better in a game or two but more
or less only under balance I don't think
we had a single uh position where it was
even close to objectively winning
and this last game I think was was quite
excellently played overall I mean maybe
some inaccuracies in the middle game but
it was super super complex so that's to
be expected and
overall just like really really balanced
I mean imbalance but also balanced in
terms of evaluation game
and Jana is considering but it looks
like he's going for it we need four
thing has nothing really to think about
here he shouldn't be avoiding the
repetition there's no reason to
guys down on the clock
we are expecting a repetition at this
point we're doing falling back with the
King to G8 Rook G6 is not a move that
you consider here right it's the only
move that I feel with black keeps the
game going but it looks like more like a
losing move than a winning attempt if
Rook G6 is not better for what I'd be
shocked but it's not definitely oh my
God what
playing for a win is
Ren trying to win this game because this
is a big moment the bishop on E3 is
pinned the Queens are looking at each
other through that Bishop so if you
can't take on C5 black is up a pawn and
dingley Wren I keep using this Hemingway
uh expression you know he said courage
is Grace Under Pressure he's courageous
and queen of five use black the upper
hand apparently
yeah is he just pushing but but wait why
would white black be better here
uh you push it C for you that's
actually C4 C4 is
on the board why it's got to go H4 H5
right that's the plan but black stops it
with H5
or queen G4 as well you could try to
trade Queens you are up two queen side
passers and we keep talking about Blitz
this is about to be a Blitz game where
Janda palmchi is currently up almost a
minute but he is down a pawn and those
are some scary pawns to be down I'm an
absolute shock that Ding actually
decided to continue the game with just a
minute on the clock he's refused a
repetition going into Blitz
yeah this is a pretty wild decision
Maybe
it actually looks like a brilliant
decision but probably because this queen
F5 was was a mistake
um and maybe he just missed C4 he
thought he's picking up that pawn but
he's not picking up that pawn
so what does he do Bishop
D4
I just want to stop C3 there
Queen D3 yeah
yeah Queen D3
oh my gosh this is a position where Jan
might have only one move to survive I I
see the eval bar saying 0.3 but that is
completely misleading everybody there
are two separate pass pawns most
importantly there's Advanced C pawn and
you want to rush upon H5 you do not get
that the queen steps to G4 after Pawn HR
offering a queen trade and then the pawn
goes up to C3 Bobby Tanya this is
worrisome territory for janapamshi who's
dipping to just about a minute and that
was a mistake
oh Queen D3 not even Queen G4 Queen D3
that's the best way
yeah that that's really really bad for
white
oh my goodness the C3 is happening move
Rook G6 we were thinking that's not even
a possibility and such a brave decision
and it's paying off ding Loren with the
reval bar it shows that he's clearly
better better here but practically Fabi
how easy is this in um with a minute on
the clock and Jan there keeps the Queens
on the board which is absolutely crucial
for any play with white he has to get H5
in Rook D1 God is just pushing well like
what does the H5 matter because you
don't give checks on that diagonal
anymore
like
oh
um okay
C3 F6
it doesn't seem to change a huge amount
yeah what are you doing here as white
because the queen on D3 is so well
positioned and he goes Rook D1 he wants
to chase the Queen off the diagonal I
think that's a good choice but can't
that Queen just slide back to F5
and then Queen C4 he has to to engineer
some sort of Rook d8 Rook D5 like
something with activity oh but I like
this because the queen C4 this Rook C6
now the queen and Rook along the sixth
rank helps to push the pawn
that's a good move so wait does a queen
have to go to E2
but that's not what you want to do
because that works C6 anyway with the
threat of C2 Bishop to A3 and he's also
has no time
oh wow so yeah this is very very close
oh my goodness we're stunned into
silence maybe you need to play Queen E2
quickly and just pray
I mean obviously your position is bad
uh but at least keep some time on the
clock he's down to 35 seconds ding's the
one with the time Advantage Fabi
yeah well white has to keep some time on
the clock just in case it turns into a
mess at some point wait now Rook C6 what
is even the idea is he gonna try to
sacrifice a piece and go for an attack
against this King that should not pan
out but maybe this Kings have tried to
hide on H2 and in a scramble if it gets
into real time trouble for black when
you're under attack that's where
mistakes happen
yeah maybe a good practical shot I mean
for sure this psac is his idea uh it
doesn't work like all these things are
definitely true but
but
he wants to avoid it so
we're now Rook to C1 at least
or wait can you trade maybe you could
trade
oh and it's giving a question mark you
can trade and then try to get your queen
back to E4 at some point try to make it
just try to like hold a move by move
yeah Queen E4 Queen C4 and it's not an
it's not a midi drawer but you're saying
black cannot easily progress because the
and he finds it here we need four Queen
G6 Queen C4 good good try
and not only C2 a good practice try
sorry Fabi but look at the eval bar it
says minus 1.4 or is it nearly minus
four so Jan may be fighting back in this
game just when it looked like dingley
Wren would be crowned world champion
well it's very difficult to advance that
pawn because C2 is allowing H5 ideas
and if not C2 then maybe you play H5
with black here maybe you really need to
get those light squares under control
okay you can give a check it probably
doesn't change a whole lot
pushing the a pawn maybe maybe but then
Bishop to somewhere Bishop D4 will get
some counter play Maybe King goes to H2
not too loud Queen E4 check although
probably doesn't change much
oh my goodness King H2 is played and
look at the eval bar it's going near
level this could be dangerous for for a
ding if he's all In For the Win he could
find himself under pressure with his G7
Pawn targeted by the bishop on D4 as
well
yeah I mean like Bishop D4 C2 maybe you
lose because of Queen uh to F7 yeah
something like that obviously you never
you never want to allow but generally
speaking black does not risk here but
Bishop D4 the point of the King on H2
Queen E4 was not checked because Queen
takes B4 wins a piece 17 seconds
and that was correct one wait A3 and
oh is he going back queen of seven Queen
B3
or is it a queen of Southern Queen C4
yeah uh Queen G6 is available I think
that's what you we're indicating that
pawns protected he goes Queen C7 which
is a mistake a huge mistake in time
travel from Beyond the Pomchi the queen
has to go back to G6 that's the good
news for dingley red he has only one
move here and Jan is the one down to 20
seconds and counting down
wait Bishop C3
oh which is A2 and queen B1 then there's
no checks yeah yeah that's
yeah I think this is over
oh my God Queen C4 back it's the only
only move
will he find it the only way to keep the
game going is Queen back to C4 going
after the bishop he plays just that so
good find C2 now yeah this is
so close to disaster
what he's holding on right now is Bishop
C5 oh no it's not I was trying to get
too clever Bishop D6 this H4 Pawn may be
hanging in some positions he goes King
G2 which keeps it in minus three so
that's obviously an advantage for black
but maybe it's time Fabi for your H5
move just because you don't want this
King to be checked uh left and right oh
you know non-stop so maybe H5 helps that
King
just to stop white because white is
there any H5 now it white has a threat
of H5 H5 queen of 5 G4 and the queen has
to lose contact with C2 Pawn H5
uh might not be an easy decision because
you feel like if my Queen ever gets
active then white will Target that H
Pawn definitely a difficult decision but
might be the right move
if he plays H5 why we'll play Queen to
D5
H5 Queen D5 oh I was gonna say A2 but
you can just take my Pawn yeah it
doesn't work that works because Queen E4
take this bishop
oh yeah he can actually play A2
immediately
although you'd be very careful here
let's see King F1 oh I don't think the
king in the belongs the first rank that
means a pawn might promote with check at
some point
wait now King E2 Queen G4 so you can't
move your king but he was avoiding this
A2 Queen E4 Queen E3 because he saw that
option he was avoiding it with King F1
boy now Bishop to B2 is coming this is
just game over I mean there's no more
hope here the bishop on b2y doesn't even
have counter play
he's going for just just desperation
with a H5 Queen F5 yeah this is
desperation is not working out ding is
going to win this match unbelievable
the resilience from dingley Ren he
brings his Queen up now it's on F5
there's a pass Pawn C2 that's defended
you can't distract the queen anymore
dingley run who is down a point in this
match is he about to become a world
champion
um
black can do anything here
I mean he doesn't have to panic but he
can play A2 uh
Queen D3 probably wins G3 probably wins
yeah
and now A2 A2 is super super winning
not even hope he's left we're just
seconds away from ding becoming the
world champion if he just plays the next
few accurate moves it's all over
I just want to move A2 and it's over
and it's on the board
oh my goodness
he sits up in his chair but he knows
this might be the last few moves of his
world championship oh my God
oh you see it
he knows it
yeah Bishop takes F4 is easy
heartbreaking
it's over dingler and is the world just
champion
wow he has made history as the first
Chinese player to win the World
Championship we see handshakes that Ding
is overtaken by emotions he isn't able
to leave the board and for yeah a
heartbreaking moment there he leaves the
hall this has been a fight of Courage of
grit and determination and all of that
has paid off for dingler and take a
moment and admire ding right now what a
match this has been and a deserving
victory for dingler in yes 2023 world
champion
shouldn't even have been here right to
get to the candidates he had someone had
to be removed he then entered the frame
by playing 30 games in a month then he
goes the candidates he gets second place
Magnus Carlson has to step aside has to
abdicate the throne and then he gets
into this match we see the final score
two and a half one half and tie breaks
but he was trailing in the match until
game 12. I cannot believe it but dingley
ran a deserving world champion
yeah he got so justly rewarded by
playing Rook to G6 uh not many people
would have played Rook G6 there I think
that's really the critical moment in the
game I mean there's only one who that we
have to talk about when we talk about
this last game Victory and it almost
feels unfair that Jan uh you know when
it was such an eagle match he just
doesn't have any chances at the end I'm
sure he feels like uh I was so close and
uh and just like one you know one move
away from winning this match but ding
Rook G6 it's a brilliant brilliant move
brilliant uh courage to play that move
ment with just a minute and 23 seconds
on the clock dingling has not won a game
with black against Jana palmistry and he
does it in the most important moment of
his life Rook G6 was truly a moment of
bravery and courage and it really did he
really did get rewarded with this
playing it on a minute when he had the
repetition when he had the option to get
into Blitz this was amazing fantastic
chest that we saw
I'm still getting over what we've just
witnessed the turnaround and Robert as
you pointed out for the majority of this
match thing was the one who was trailing
until game 12.
yeah he was trailing right he lost game
two with the white pieces and when that
happened everyone's looking at this
match like what's going on here is
dingly rent going to be able to handle
the pressure both on and off the board
and then he was able to bounce back by
winning game four then he lost game five
then he won game six then he lost game
seven in just tragic fashion where he
couldn't move he was stuck in the mud
and then he gave me he almost wins but
he doesn't take a rook when he can and
then finally in Game 12 when he was
losing he was in bad shape he was able
to fight back and you saw the emotion I
mean this move Rook G6 I think that is a
move that you look at the eval bar to
the side of the screen here it says
zeros what did it say before Rook G6 it
says zeros so easy to gloss over a game
and say the eval bar didn't change but
this is why we play the game this is why
dingley red is the world champion he
makes this move Rook G6 and Fabi what a
move it was because white was not in
time to put pressure on the pin piece
and black has an extra Pawn
yeah when you think about the position
before you think Rook G6 is crazy to pin
my Rook when you start to calculate what
white might have here and we see that
probably why this is equalizing maybe in
more than one way but all of Weiss
Equalization attempts like Rook to C2 I
see that they don't actually like treble
black like black always has a safety now
to bringing the queen back Queen D1
followed by Queen D6 followed by Queen
C6 and
so dink absolutely correctly uh saw that
he's he's not really taking a huge risk
with this whole
um Rook G6 idea and then it was just a
brilliant decision I mean he
went to F5 was the first was taken the
wrong direction I think he just missed
C4 probably on didn't believe over G6 or
he thought h4s is coming and he missed
this move Queen to D3 maybe even Queen
G4 was also good with Queen D3 as the
best move and somehow Jan still had
some really good drawing chances at some
moments later on but it was a time
scramble and very often these time
scrambles if you get like one drawing
chance you don't seize it because it's
just you know one drawing chance out of
like 20 moves it's it's uh too difficult
to spot exactly when your chances it was
after he found like this bishop D4 ended
it was quite miraculous of what I was
getting counter play but
he had to find one last move probably to
make a draw
in this position
and maybe the move was H5 I'm starting
to think
if you want to stop Queen G6
and the queen can't leave without
dropping the B4 the visual B4
uh of course black is not risking here
although
it's not easy to find a move either so
Bobby could you imagine someone playing
this move with like 20 seconds on their
clock H5 when they're two separate pass
pawns you can hardly blame yonda palmchi
for once The Bishop's on D4 for playing
Queen C7 he's threatening Checkmate in
one move and with the queen coming to G6
if the queen were on F7 well that would
offer the queen trade so I can't blame
him for missing it no time left but I
think it it's earlier in the game where
if there's a decision he would like to
take back forcing the draw when he had a
chance he didn't do it and Rook G6 was
that courageous Choice by ding Loren but
Jan he's gonna be kicking himself for
not forcing the draw
yeah he definitely definitely had a lot
of moments where he was he had complete
safety and he was still feeling
ambitious
uh what can you say yeah these last
second decisions I mean they they can
sometimes come back to haunt you it's
not even like we can criticize that you
play on because okay it's you know Jan
played on and it was courageous and ding
played on it and it was courageous but
one of those was rewarded it's sometimes
you take a courageous decision and it
gets punished as it was in this game he
probably thought he's operating in a
position without much risk earlier on in
the game
um then again if he had played H5 at the
moment and it had been some other result
we would have
you know we would have said yeah sure
it's just another game but
uh it turned out to be such a pivotal
game I mean this game decided the world
champion
and
that's that's also what happens when you
let it get down to the last game right
like it's a four game match and uh tied
anything can happen after you know
that's why uh sometimes you want an
accident happen to happen earlier right
like you you lose the first game then
you have plenty of opportunities to get
back
uh Jan unfortunately for him has no
opportunity to get back because this is
the final game and that's why I said
like maybe it feels unfair to him
because sometimes you want like I want
that extra chance I still want to fight
in this match but it's all over Tanya I
mean we're giving Rook G6 a lot of
credit but this Queenie Two Fine double
the slim I mean that was also brilliant
by dingley Wren getting out of the pin
and because the bishop can't be captured
Queenie one check so many good decisions
by ding when he was the one down the
clock
adiron excellent player there by dingler
and it definitely comes down to that
courageous decision of going Rook G6
declining a repetition forcing a blitz
playoff we expected it Jan perhaps
expected it for that repetition and was
completely thrown off by the move Rook
G6 and we saw ding on second under a
minute play one good move after the
other and that's exactly what you need
to become world champion and finally in
game four ding does take the crown two
and a half to one and a half he saw
three fighting draws we saw 14 in Tan's
classical games and finally it was the
fourth rapid gradient that crowns thing
Lauren as the world champion but also
one has to feel for his his competitor
yeah what a match he played kept his
lead took his chances fought in every
single game till the very end those long
Marathon end games it was incredible to
see his resourcefulness out of the
openings and just the way he kept things
under control and this move Rook G6 it
was it was too much it was unbelievable
what happened
this hat this was his second chance at
the world championship and take a moment
because it has been a tough one thing
Lauren well he's the king of the world
right now
yeah Jan needed to finish it off in
classical I mean he had his big chance
game 12.
that was he was winning he was up in the
match if he had won that game I mean it
wouldn't have been over yet but it would
have been like let's say 99 the job is
done
and that was that was his big moment uh
after that
we said it's 50 50 going into the final
two games going into the rapid we said
also it's as close as you can expect
these two guys are really evenly matched
but the odd had a huge chance in game
12. and thing today I mean like it's
been kind of an amazing day I mean he
barely made mistakes today I have to say
he had a few slightly worse positions he
made a few inaccuracies but to have four
rapid games where you barely make
mistakes is really really impressive uh
I can only think of
game one he made one mistake uh
yeah that's all I can think of I don't
know maybe you guys remember some more
mistakes but I can't really think of
many in this entire final four rapid
games I think it's a really good point
that Ding played Super precise chess in
that first game he had an advantage he
did let Jan back in the game but it
wasn't major I can't really think of
moments where we were super worried
about ding's position that he might lose
and Fabi just to add on to what you were
saying Game 12 of course is one that
John de palmistry is going to regret in
game 14. you play that E5 move when he
knew that he was a borderline winning
and then ding found that B6 idea that
was some brilliant stuff so Jan had the
world championship in his hands and you
have to feel for him because it's his
second time playing in the world
championship against Magnus Carlson he
knew that was an uphill battle Magnus
was the heavy favorite much higher rated
against England they were even by rating
Jan was leading throughout many parts of
this match as early as game two and as
late as going into Game 12 and then in
Rapid I just think the the proper
summary is dingly Ren just gave the
world amount master class that was such
great technique it was such fine
Precision when he needed to find
accurate moves he did I think that
dingley run you could see everything
just coming at him he was so emotional
there but he also left everything on the
chessboard today all of these brilliant
ideas in that last game Rook G6 to play
on there when many people would just
make a draw head into Blitz I think he
really deserves so much credit and he
has a world championship title but that
was amazing stuff
when I had that interview with ding in
the last championship Star Event right
before he took his journey to Astana he
spoke about how his dream was that his
photograph would hang in all these chess
clubs across the world and that would
mean so much to him well he's achieved
an ultimate dream for every single
player and it's not pin easy well it
never is but this match has been so up
and down full of unexpected surprises
and today when it mattered the most at
every step it felt like ding but are the
best in him on the day that it mattered
the most starting from the opening
preparations the ideas that we saw with
the white pieces he wasn't afraid to go
into complications to go into Dynamics
and Jana Palmer she really held his own
but it came down to those few seconds
that minute and it just was dings day
and today is is a big day for him as he
becomes world champion wow guys this has
been a match that's down for the ages
and as you mentioned winning two
candidates back to back Bobby that is
not easy that just shows what a
world-class player Yan is I'm trying to
Rack my brains for the last time a
player won two consecutive candidates
and
struggling
I also can't can't think of it um
I guess fortunately has a
uh we're really going back in time I
mean we're going back to
1981 yeah but it's uh obviously it says
a lot of we have to go back 50 almost 50
years in history to find a second
example of doing something like that the
candidates tournament is almost like a
world championship in itself because you
have to play against all the best
players in the world
besides obviously the world champion and
so even if you're let's say a player
like Magnus or a player who wins a huge
amount of events winning the candidates
is such a such a tremendously difficult
and impressive feat and doing it twice
in a row
yeah we can count on one hand the amount
of people have done it but
at the final moment Ian uh Beyond wasn't
able to bring it home
Robert it's been such an intense day of
action we were so ready to see the blitz
happen and do you think today it all
came down to that Split Second decision
at the end of it it is this move Rook to
G6 I remember in the 2016 World
Championship match it was the move Rook
to 8-6 by Magnus Carlson that won the
World Championship is it fair to say
that today the star move was Rook to G6
absolutely I mean it was just a
brilliant attempt from dingley Wren the
way he played this final game at first
it looked good for him then it started
to look iffy but he held on he did great
and we see Magnus Carlsen self-pinning
for immortality congrats Ding and yeah
ding deserves all the congratulations I
think finally he'll be able to relax a
little bit he has seemed quite stressed
throughout the match but as you said
Tanya I was there when you interviewed
him and it was a great heartfelt
interview where he said you know he
wants his photo to be hanging in chess
clubs he's earned that and he's earned
so much more I think he's gained so many
fans that haven't seen him play in a
long time because he was in China and
during covet he just couldn't get access
to tournaments so to see him become the
world champion I think for many people
who are newer to the game this is one of
the stars of the game no matter if Magus
Carlsen plays or not you see the pin
tweet he's congratulating dingler as the
world champion
with this win I think Lauren puts
himself in the history books forever as
the 17th World a chess champion and
what's been also amazing to see is the
glimpses that we've gotten into ding's
personality throughout the match he's
been so candid you've seen those
emotional moments you've seen his
interaction with Richard raffle after
the games it's all been very
heartwarming and then to see ding bring
out the best in him the absolute best in
him in this critical moment it has paid
off what a day it is and he is the first
Chinese player ever to become world
champion it's definitely a moment for
national pride as well Abby
yeah absolutely uh
I mean I can't imagine how over the moon
thing is
I'm sure I mean he said as much that
it's always been a dream of his
to be in the books as a world champion
he joins a list of some of the greatest
players uh well not some of I mean all
of the greatest players in in history
and yeah I mean his name is definitely
in the books now
oh and there we see thing learned with
his fans and Richard raffle there who's
been such a big part of the success of
things we've seen these amazing Clips
with both of them their interaction
after the game he's been a big support
to dingler in this match he owes so much
of these big opening ideas that we saw
and we see dingler in there celebrate
with his core team in Astana these are
some heartwarming oh these are some
heartwarming moments that I think we
will remember forever
we will indeed I mean China has won
numerous olympiads there have been many
women's world champions from China the
current women's world champion and her
Challenger are from China and the
candidates finalists also from China so
they have such a successful team of
players uh they love the game they've
been working really hard dingling right
now with Rich's report that was a really
uh nice photo session there you see the
people clapping uh but yeah this is
going to be a tough press conference for
Jana Pomchi but a moment of a lifetime
for dingley Wren and he really did earn
it they worked so hard and Richard to
report as the second he gets a lot of
credit as well he came up with many good
ideas
and we see Yonder a very difficult
moment for Ian and dinglerun as well
is there let's hear it from the new
world chess champion we are going over
to Astana
no press conference we do have 17th
world champion this is Tim clearen
[Applause]
congratulations to to think it has been
terrific match with so many decisive
results and amazing chess games what are
your thoughts right now as you are the
world champion
well quite relieved
and resigned the game it was
a very emotional moment
I cannot control my moods on my my
feelings and
yes I know myself I will
cry Arrow
burst into tears yes and
it's a quite a
pop tournament for me yeah I would like
to thanks to my friends
would you ask my baby how do you feel
right now
no
credit release
um it must be very difficult to from
both players to to talk right now I
appreciate that all of us are
appreciating that you are both here
thank you very much Jan for for coming
up here
um it must be very difficult for you
right now to me here and it has been
really close much uh please share share
with us your thoughts about so much in
general
[Music]
well I guess I had every chance
so
um
I mean I had so many promising positions
and
probably should have
to try to finish everything in a
classical portion
because once again it was
uh I guess a measure of one or two
precise news
both in around
12 and draw 14 as well
uh but yeah once it went
once it
it was a Time Break of course it's
uh you know
it's always some sort of a luxury
especially after 14 games much and yeah
so
uh probably my opponent is made the an
ultimate mistake so that's it
all right thank you
thank you for right away to Chris I'm
sure you have a lot of questions to
players
um I just don't see all of you so let's
go from this side
a question to Loren how do you feel
about staying in Astana and especially
the weather conditions was quite tough
in the beginning what can you say about
this did you have your walking from the
beginning when it was cold or no how was
it for you
yeah I enjoy my stay here actually
because I like to walk also there's a
river near the hotel also uh there's a
park so I spent some time I spend many
rest days just to sit sit down on the
ground of the park and sometimes I bring
a
uh yeah just to spend some time
here and
so you know one day it was a heavy snow
and
well it's
the snow is quite Steep and it's quiet
so I take a lot of photos here I really
enjoy my stay here
thank you next question
yes please
the question is
I understand it is very difficult to
describe everything to explain but
talking about today's game talking about
Library what was the decisive the key
moment in the game
oh no
okay
foreign
production
s
[Music]
well actually
the key moment I think in the second
game
uh I had more chance to win but I didn't
realize it but then in the fourth game
uh the blacks they had some I had to
play more accurately but after they move
for C4 and then the situation changed
and the time was very little and it was
very difficult to change myself to
change the game
and I made a pin and the white were
close to to win and it was hard to
imagine that I could lose but things
happen and
it happened how it happened
thank you next question
participating that please
first of all congratulations to both of
you for reaching here a question today
in the fourth game in the rapid you went
for the win when nepo was like holding
the position how did you get the
strength to play Rook G6 and go for the
win and make this game the last game of
a very long tournament
well it's uh one of the two ways to play
or win the other one was to play Lucas 7
after 25 bucks I guess obviously in room
is better
and looking mostly from H7
so I decided
to pray for win it was because uh at
when I previously before I realized that
I could pray for a win because if we
take on C5 I can Bishop E1 and did not
exchange the bishop
yeah
yeah if you got the chance I think you
need to save it or say this
absolutely we saw you going and being
with your team hugging them could you
please tell us that who are you going to
dedicate this event to
um dedicate yes
my friends my my mother
and also my grandfather Yeah
thank you congratulations once again
thank you very much next question please
capital
[Music]
my question is
actually before the tie break bookmakers
they were
they were making a mistake for young
before
because he has more experience in fast
chess and what about you Dean how did
you think
before I break yourself
well we both have many experience we are
very we are established the Grandmasters
we have played a lot of type rates in
recent years
so it doesn't mean anything
as I said having a white pieces and not
always the advantage
you at some point you will be too
optimistic about your chances
then it will sometimes go
backwards
um
this is
the question is
could you please tell the names of the
people who help you in your preparation
maybe here also in Astana
um
foreign
who helped me in my preparation and
among them there is Nikita and there is
a Dar Maxim and I also make consultation
with the Redeemer chronic
so these are some of the people in my
team
next question
uh congratulations to both players and
thank you for this wonderful month of
tremendous chess
congratulations to the new world
champion ding I have a question for you
in a recent interview with Cena
Sports in China news I hope the
translation is accurate you said the
meaning of life should be in those
special those sparkling moments not in
the daily life of those generally base
but in living for those unique moments
I hope it's accurate and can you say if
this moment is unique and special moment
yeah it was an interview uh I guess I
remember it was
take place in 2019.
yeah
you know I
because I started to learn chess from
four years old
and I spent
26 years
playing analyzing
so
try to improve my accessibility with
many different ways with different
changing methods with I think many new
ways to training maybe it's not so well
known among the LA players so I think
I did nearly
everything
yes I sometimes I thought I would
education to test
uh
and because sometimes
time without the tournaments there are
not so happy
I
sometimes I struggle to find the
another hobbies to make me happy
so
also I would influence expired by many
sayings
to
to achieve to
uh
climbing the mountains or to
drive to the best or to run from the
best to
uh
I think this was
the match is reflects the deepest of
myself
thank you
um thank you very much for the answer do
we have more questions yes please
foreign
so in general how do you assess the game
situation organizational and domestic
situation how is the organized
everything how can you assess it this is
the question to First players I think we
will go first with you I'm sorry how's
the organizing things here for you how
do you feel
yeah
the the same routines everything so I
feel very comfortable here
yeah
it is
normal
question
from advice
first of all thanks a lot
Jan for being here now and answering our
questions so well my question today is
for leaving
why are you now the world champion I
mean what are the
points the key reasons for you
to explain why you are the champion
right now
well if if I try to find a reason inside
of Chess I think
it might be some changing ways
yeah maybe this was makes me
pray a little bit different than the
other grandmothers
thank you like it thank you
next question please
from prison times congratulations to
both players I'm sure I speak with
everyone when I say that was an absolute
spectacle and you should both be
absolutely wrapped this is a question of
Dean given that you've been through such
adversity you get here you know you the
games you play in China to qualify for
the candidates coming second of the
candidates and getting a call up now
that the well I wouldn't say the dust is
necessarily settled but uh the fact that
you're now the world's chess world
champion some of you've worked so hard
for like you just said for the past 26
years
what what's something special that's uh
you're looking forward to doing with
your boy Richard report who was clearly
in the corner from uh from day one
what are you looking forward to doing
now with your world champion given that
you were Richard have been in Adventures
for the past month
I think we need second time if it's slow
please I don't really get it what are
you looking forward to doing now that
you've won what are you looking forward
to do now as world champion
no no I'm the answer is the question
yeah
um
assuming uh what am I going to plan to
do later
with the family
well that's really I may go to travel if
I have some spare time
thank you uh I wanted to ask this
question as you as you mentioned though
earlier uh about reading the winning the
prize he said that you want to travel
what is your ideal holidays where you
want to travel
well I have at least
I want to
go to uh touring to see a game of
Juventus
and my favorite top
also
um
maybe two
two
I don't have
okay I think you need a little bit more
time to play that I heard this next
question please
um
yeah
the question is
first of all thank you for the
tournament thank you for your game and
if we make the analogy Lionel Messi he
lost his world cup and then he found the
strength to come back
and made another world cup so can you do
something like this
Church
uh
uh new text delicious
um
well actually by this tournament uh a
huge piece of my life preparation work
has finished
but I will play chess more I think
and
we will see in the future
all right thank you next question please
uh
you know uh
first of all
congratulations to both players and
congratulations to Dean with being a
champion
and the question is to design
so what was Asana
got into your memory and will you come
back to us tonight future
what do you think
yeah it's my second time here
yes yeah
good memories
I think
I'd like to get back here if there are
the atonements there
this is
and the second question again to Dean
design in what age did you dream to
become a champion
become the world champion I just want to
um at one point I just want to become
the
prayer Place test
and not to become the word it's not so
important to become more challenging
um
just a second
um I wanted to ask things as you are the
first ever Chinese
a chess player who won the title I asked
this question earlier in the first day
and now everything is more clear so how
does it feel
the first in Chinese world champion yeah
yeah I feel good I think it will uh
inspire a lot of Chinese use young
players preachers because
the atonement I guess was followed by
many step Traders around China
so I hope it will
um
uh
yeah
influence a lot of people
right and right now I'll ask right away
who are the first people that you want
to thank for for this victory of yours
family your coaches your team your fun
maybe yourself yeah yeah I forgot things
myself yeah
all right next question is
the question is
did you feel the pressure because many
experts they give reference to you and
did
it bless you somehow
uh
no many except of
gradually
foreign
[Music]
maybe didn't influence too much
but I think to my opponent it was a
little bit easier to play
because he played for kind of hero like
without less risk
and but anyway the pressure to both
players was more or less measurable
thank you do you have more questions and
there there is anyone who wants to ask
the question now it's time to come
forward and ask the question please
um
now the question is
about a year ago you signed the anti-war
letter about the war in Ukraine and what
is the situation now after a year is
there any pressure from your Russian
colleagues or authorities
uh no their ministers
um
[Music]
I don't think there's much pressure
but about the communication with the
Ukrainian colleagues
I still communicate with those who I
have communicated before and I don't
communicate with those who I haven't
done it before
so it's so it's like before situation
more or less
all right thank you
[Music]
from press
uh I suppose no so now I'll give some
time to a Twitter segment Jesse
foreign
I only have one question and that's to
both of you looking back on the match
including your preparation
what would you have done differently do
you have any regrets
um we will go first with uh yeah with
you
uh win more games and lose less
thank you thank you
well since the results is excellent I
don't have any reports looking back
all right thanks
thank you
um
well there are no more questions I think
uh it's time to conclude the press
conference thank you so much to both of
the players for the great joy that they
give to chest funds for this one month
and yeah thank you to Jan and thank you
to think as well
foreign
[Applause]
overcome by emotion the winning moment
from the 2023 world championship and
what a journey it's been for dingler and
with his struggles to make it to the
candidates he finished second at the
candidate Magnus Carlsen decides not to
defend his cycle that gives dingler in
to the opportunity to fight for his
Ultimate Dream and he found himself on
this very board and then trailing the
match for the most part and finally it
was in game four a rapid day which saw
the best in Ding and now his name is
forever amongst the greatest of the
greats in the Chess World the England
alongside Magnus Carlsen alongside
within art and Anand and Vladimir
kramnik Fabi is this the biggest moment
for a chess player yeah absolutely I
think that it showed with things
emotions after the final moves of the
final game
that yeah this is a dream for every
chess player purely for ding and well
deserved I mean that final game was was
really clutch really really clutch final
day and final game for ding
yeah played a great match and uh you
know they asked him was a child to dream
of yours you asked him in the pre-match
interview uh he earned this Victory he
it was the unlikeliest of circumstances
for dingley rent just the way he even
played in the candidates and then making
it to this championship match when
Magnus said I don't want to play anymore
and then to win this match when he was
down when he didn't lead until that very
last game he won the fourth and final
rapid game the first time the only time
but the most important time that he led
this world championship match was he
just lead he won it
what a day it is for dingler and as the
world congratulates ding as he makes his
name amongst the greatest of all times
he's also being congratulated by the
greatest players of all time five-time
former world champion vishwanathan Anand
there and now until the end of time
ding's name will be written alongside
Magnus alongside on it alongside
Vladimir kramnik and anander saying that
it's impossible to praise both players
enough even today they went at it with
full energy and the fourth game was so
draining however things survived so many
setbacks and saves his best for the last
he also talks about The Miraculous
Journey that dingler and has indeed had
and I think this really sums it up what
we saw today and no matter what you say
about these two players it's just not
enough the amount of Praise that we can
give to dingleren but also to Jana
pomnishi he was truly a gladiator in
this fight Robert yeah I mean he was I
think beyond the pump she deserves a
world of credit the way he played in
this match he was not just taking
peaceful games even in the game he lost
at the end he was playing a game where
he could have liquidated at some point
he could have just forced the draw and I
know he'll be criticized for it because
he ended up losing the game but it was
his fighting spirit that made this match
so fun as early as game two we saw a
decisive game that hasn't happened in
previous World Chess Championship
matches in recent years and then we saw
them trade off four wins in a row with
the white pieces that's not just one
person it takes two to tango it takes
two to play chess and these two played
some excellent chess Yanda pamachi I
mean he's proven that he deserves to be
on this world stage he won the
candidates twice in a row and the chess
he showed the world here in the 2023
world championship match he was that
close from being world champion just one
thing going differently and it could
have been his name Etch in history
yeah I think Jan in the press conference
he really pointed to those final uh
games in the in the classical portion
the game 12
or he was winning and leading the match
and where he could pretty much put it
all away and game 14 I think he was
arguably just as close to putting it
away because if he had spent his time on
an E5 move not played E5 but dot or at
least not play D5 quickly but thought
about that moment I think he might have
come to a different conclusion might
have played the Mover up to B3
potentially and that was really really
close to winning and everything was in
time trouble
um the position was
pretty much just losing virgin
uh so he he pinpointed those two moments
I think once you let it get to Rapid
when you don't close uh close the match
out when you have multiple chances then
it becomes like also psychologically
difficult to uh to be able to you know
win the rapid portion of course it was a
very very close rapid portion as well
and I wouldn't have been surprised at
all to see to see onward I mean he
definitely had his chances also in game
two of the rapid today I think he
pointed that out that he had a very
pleasant position it was never like an
enormous chance like he had in those
basketball games but still he um those
were the moments that he points to and
uh the interesting thing is as soon as
ding he had less opportunities in this
batch but he pretty much seized almost
all of them as soon as he had a chance
in this final rapper Game he sees that
the only chance I can see that he really
like majorly missed was like game eight
right
where he had a few chances to win but
besides that he it feels like Jan had
more chances but ding took more chances
we had 14 big classical fights and we
were talking about fatigue and energy
and stamina for the players but it was
clear that both Yan and ding came with a
clear mindset today to become world
champion there was no question of
tiredness we saw amazing Precision
amazing Courage by both these players
and just in those final moments thing
had the upper hand and he capitalized on
with that brave decision of Rook to G6 a
truly special one of the biggest moments
of dings entire life and at the press
conference he was never asked about what
that meant to him and the moment that he
realized that he is world champion
here's what he said
well quite relieved
the moment I
young resigned the game it was
a very emotional moment
I cannot control my moods on my my
feelings and
yes and I know myself I will
cry I will
burst into tears pop tournament for me
yeah I would like to thanks to my
friends
as it still is sinking in for the 17th
World chess champion thing learn
overtaken by emotions and it was really
interesting how the first word that he
mentioned that came to his mind was
relief no one can understand that with
the toll that the match takes not just
the games that I played but months of
preparation leading up to it this is
your whole life revolving around this
goal this single tunnel vision and Fabi
is that how it is is it relief that
surpasses joy in that moment
yeah I think the amount of tension that
these guys had to deal with over the
last three weeks is so intense that
maybe relief even overtakes uh the joy
that you feel although
I think that on the other side of it if
you lose the match then
um
it's not even like the relief of
exhaustion but just the feeling of how
many chances I had and all the regrets
that that come back and uh you feel like
I mean I'm sure that's what
that's the reason why Yan was like
pointing to those moments in the press
conference that he felt like I had uh I
had those chances and I really really
let them slip uh but for for ding I
think first it's relief and then over
the course of the next few days it will
start to be uh the joy of realizing that
he actually became a world champion but
there's there's that adjustment period
where you don't fully feel it yet and
then it comes to you a bit later that oh
I actually won
it doesn't ding barely have any time to
adjust because he's playing in a
tournament in just a few days if I'm not
mistaken so no rest for the weary I
think Bobby he'll join you for that
event uh but yeah ding you know he as
you said earlier he made the most of his
chances with the exception of game eight
and I would also add game seven because
he did sacrifice in exchange and had a
pleasant position there and then he
froze so uh there are many story lines
from this world championship and Jan you
could hear from him in the press
conference I don't really know why he
was sitting there forever that I felt
very badly for him that was really
uncomfortable to watch if I'm being
completely transparent uh you know it's
not a pleasant experience to sit through
that when everyone is celebrating the
guy on the other side but I will say
that Jan answered the questions he dealt
with it in a way that I think is
admirable and you can see how
disappointed he was not just because the
result didn't go his way but because
there are moves along the way that he
wishes he could take back or play a
little bit more slowly but it was just
that close and it was a nail biter it
was an epic and dingly rent is the it
came out on top
obviously also getting over that game 12
where the math could have essentially
been over is something that is going to
haunt him and it has been a difficult
day for Jan but he's been an absolute
fighter undoubtedly that this match
would not have been what it is if it
wasn't for Yan he was the one who was
leading throughout and definitely a
difficult moment but right now the
congratulations are indeed pouring in
for dingler and I got matar there Anish
giri with one thing to rule them all I
mean it's truly the Twitter King here
is on his game for sure and yeah all I
can say is congratulations to dingley
wren
um he he you know had a difficult
Journey but at the last moment he had
What it Took
massive congratulations to dingley Wren
I mean the way he played today it was
exemplary he is a role model on and off
the chessboard for so many of his new
fans but also those of you who have been
around for a while loving his chest he
famously beat Magus Carlsen the sink
Full Cup tie breaks way back when and
people were looking at whoa he did that
that's really impressive he's been
around for a long time he's been a
little bit quiet in part it's his
demeanor in part because he hasn't been
playing over the board that much but
he's an absolute beast and he Unleashed
that Beast today and that is why he's
the deserving world champion
yeah it's it was a really it was a match
full of a lot of content as well
um despite all the mistakes there were a
lot of interesting ideas a lot of
exciting games and from a purely chess
point of view not talking about the
um the joys and the
um disappointments that both players had
throughout the match and obviously at
this point it's just joy for ding but
from a Pure Chess point of view there
was a lot of really exciting stuff I
enjoyed following you guys when I wasn't
doing the commentary watching uh you
guys do the uh
do the commentary for every game and
every game was exciting and also enjoyed
uh commentating on the games live
and talking about them because they were
super exciting games
it was amazing to have you
or just breaking
SAS the approach of these two absolute
world-class players and I'm sure for
Chad I speak on behalf of chat and I
speak on behalf of myself and Robert
that you made this so special so big
thank you to you to make this possible
for us to actually follow the action
that we did see now dingler and is the
world champion with great power Robert
comes a great responsibility putting
that in because we know how much Fabi
enjoys those movie puns but I have to
ask you Robert how will they continue to
add to this Legacy as world champion
well I'm not an uncle yet but I can't
answer your question I think that for
dingley Wren I mean his legacy is just
getting started uh he's been a worthy
Champion even if not world champion for
many years now his rating crossed 2800
one of the highest rated players in
chess history but now he is the world
champion and there is responsibility
that comes with that and he himself said
he hopes that people in China more
people will watch the game play the game
uh because it isn't the most popular
game in China that's okay but I think it
you know there's an opportunity there
for him to promote it to everyone in his
country they will you know look to him
as a hero and yeah he's earned this
Championship so I think that for dingley
Wren right now he's not going to focus
on that so much he's just going to
celebrate he's going to sort of just
relax for a hot second before he goes
and plays Fabiano in a tournament next
week but uh yeah he is just you know
he's just really a great person and that
comes off in every interview he does and
he is just a worthy Champion so you
cannot say enough congratulations to
dingley Wren I don't know what his
legacy I don't want to prognosticate but
I think that he deserves this moment
just to enjoy it without worrying about
what Legacy he'll leave behind
I don't think it's about his next
ottoman that's coming up I don't think
it is about what he will leave behind
right now is his moment to just live in
the moment he is the world chess
champion and has been a fantastic
last few last three weeks that we've
been on this and I have to say Robert
Abby I'm getting a bit emotional that
it's all over it's been such an amazing
ride and of course a huge shout out to
our chat from across the world who was
on it with us Robert Fabi this was
amazing and a big thank you to our
production crew as well without him none
of this would be possible it's been
amazing casting alongside both of you
thank you so much thank you Chad and we
leave you with the best moments from
things Victorious fire breaks today
goodbye
we can't pick out a clear favorite I
think we see that the players have been
completely evenly matched In classical
chess and Rapid chess I think they're
also going to be completely evenly
matched but in Blitz chess who knows
it's going to be a bloodbath if it gets
to that point and at that point anything
can happen we do have the first move on
the board it's like Ruby one you saw Jan
he's looking like are you are you sure
about that he plays Beast spots it he
spots the queen sacrifice a takes music
is a brilliant move that deserves not
just two exclamation points maybe 20.
what a draw this has been oh my goodness
we saw fireworks on display look at this
view Beyond the Palm she playing the
Spanish Rook C5 played this week
immediately blitzed out the second game
of the rapid playoff and peacefully hot
sweet night F3 that is not a movie scene
by doing in this world championship yeah
and with the shake of Hector he's not
happy defending this position you can
find a way to repeat the moves and
Bishop B1 King HE2 really calm game by
both players E4 on the board as you said
E5 oh for Queenie two you actually do he
probably didn't see that one it's a
brilliant move and actually that means
it's the only move that allowed black to
survive this game oh my God
what is he playing for a win or is some
territory for Jana palmchi who's dipping
to just about a minute and that was a
mistake oh well I can do anything here
seconds away then becoming the world
champion
sits up in his chair but he knows this
might be the last few moves of his world
championship oh my God
it's over dingler and he is the world
just champion
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you